AND IF, SENATORS WHO ARE ON THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WANT TO COME
DOWN AND HELP US ESTABLISH A
QUORUM, THAT WOULD, OF COURSE,
BE HELPFUL. WE ARE IN ROOM, IN
THE STATE CAPITOL, ROOM 112, LET
ME INDICATE WHAT ITEMS ARE ON
CONSENT. THEY ARE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE, AB 2430. ITEM NUMBER 13,
AB 2144. ITEM NUMBER 17 AB 2533.
ITEM 18 AB 202903 AND ITEM 20 AB
3116. WE ALSO HAVE A VOTE ONLY
BILL. ITEM ONE AB 2338
JONES-SAWYER WILL OF COURSE NOT
START WITH THAT ONE. SINCE WE
CANNOT YET VOTE. SO WE WILL
START WITH ITEM TWO, WHICH IS AB
1789 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND YOU MAY PRESENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY BILL 1789
EXPANDS ACCESS IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PORTFOLIO
REINVESTMENT PROGRAM TO
CHALLENGE DEVELOPMENTS IN NEED
OF REHABILITATION IN ORDER TO
AVOID THE LOSS OF PRECIOUS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS THE SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S IS THE SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS, AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND HOUSEHOLDS.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS CRISIS,
CALIFORNIA HAS DEVELOPED OVER
500,000 RENTAL HOMES AFFORDABLE
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES OVER THE
LAST DECADE. AFTER 15 YEARS OF
MORE OF MORE OCCUPANCY, MANY OF
THESE DEVELOPMENTS REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT REHABILITATION
DEVELOPMENTS, WITH THE LOWEST
RENTS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE UNITS ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO LEVERAGE DEBT OR TAX
CREDITS, AND THEREFORE LACK
FINANCING OPTIONS. WITHOUT
REHABILITATION, THESE
DEVELOPMENTS CAN FALL INTO
DISREPAIR AND FORECLOSURE,
MEANING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS ARE LOST AND 20, 20 AND
2021 CALIFORNIA CREATED THE
PORTFOLIO REINVESTMENT PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THIS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED TO
PROVIDE LOANS AND GRANTS TO HCD
FUNDED DEVELOPMENTS THAT HAVE
EXPIRED AFFORDABILITY CONTRACTS,
OR HAVE BEEN HAVE A REMAINING
TERM OF TEN YEARS. HOWEVER,
THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITHOUT OLD HCD LOANS
ALSO NEED REHABILITATION AND
REMAIN UNASSISTED. AB 1789
EXPANDS THE TYPES OF
DEVELOPMENTS THAT CAN QUALIFY
FOR LOANS OR GRANTS TO INCLUDE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT DO NOT HAVE
HCD LOANS, BUT ARE DEFINED IN
THE BILL AS CHALLENGED.
DEVELOPMENTS. IN ESSENCE, MY
FRIENDS, THIS IS SIMPLY LET'S
MAKE SURE WE KEEP OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, UP TO PAR, AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT ON THE
MARKET AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WITH ME TODAY IS MR. MARK
STIVERS, DIRECTOR OF THE
ADVOCACY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP, TO MAKE
COMMENTS. MARK STIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, SAID IT
ALL. I WILL JUST REITERATE THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY WHEN IT COMES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
MAINTAINING WHAT WE HAVE. AND
THIS IS A BILL THAT DOES THAT.
AND ALSO THIS BILL CAME OUT OF A
WORKING GROUP OF MEMBERS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH US. AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE OWNERS OF
THESE OLDER DEVELOPMENTS OF WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO KEEP THEM IN
SHAPE. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THAT, BOTH BREVITY
AND SPECIFICITY. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER, PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. JUST COME TO THE MIC AND
INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT. RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH THE IMB ACTION
IN SUPPORT. DIVYA SHIV WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GREAT ANYBODY ELSE. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD. THERE'S NONE REGISTERED.
SO GLAD THERE'S NOBODY HERE, SO,
WE CAN'T TAKE A MOTION YET, BUT
WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. MEMBERS NICE TO
SEE YOU. ARE. YOU'RE JUST GOING
TO ASK FOR THE. I VOTE? OKAY,
GREAT. OKAY, WE WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS SOON
AS WE HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY THEN
LET US GO TO ITEM THREE, WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
HE'S HERE. SO GO AHEAD. IT'S AB
1840. THANK YOU. NEED ONE, BUT.
OKAY, WE'LL GO THERE. OKAY. NOT
BAD. ANYBODY ELSE WANT ONE?
SEVEN YEARS? YEAH. NOT BAD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF HOME OWNERSHIP
SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ASSEMBLY BILL 1840
ENSURES THE ELIGIBILITY AND THE
DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM INCLUDES
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS.
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
HOUSING INITIATIVES BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL RESTRICTIONS AT THE
STATE LEVEL, LEGAL STATUS CAN
COMPLICATE ACCESS TO HOME LOANS
AND HOME OWNERSHIP ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS POSING A SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIP IN AN ALREADY
CHALLENGING SECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. ENSURING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS BY ALL
QUALIFIED BORROWERS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE OVERALL
SUCCESS AND VITALITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL 1840 IS
MARIA MONTSERRAT CARRO FLORES, A
CHIRLA MEMBER FROM SUN VALLEY
AND CYNTHIA GÓMEZ, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY AND
ADVOCACY AT CHIRLA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA GÓMEZ. MARIA WILL BE
DOING HER TESTIMONY IN SPANISH
AND I WILL BE QUICKLY
TRANSLATING. I'LL START WITH MY
TESTIMONY. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA GÓMEZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF STATE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
WITH THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. CHIRLA CHIRLA
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 1840 AND
ARE THANKFUL FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA ON THIS BILL. IN 2021,
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED A DREAM
FOR ALL PROGRAM TO HELP FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS PURCHASE A
HOME. THIS PROGRAM IS TAILORED
TO HELP LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES BY PROVIDING A SHARED
APPRECIATION LOAN TO HELP COVER
THE COST OF A DOWN PAYMENT. THIS
WAS A SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARDS
HELPING FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS,
AS MANY FIND COVERING THE COST
OF A DOWN PAYMENT TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT HURDLE IN THEIR
ASPIRATIONS TO PURCHASE A HOME.
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE DREAM FOR
ALL PROGRAM CAN BE LIFE CHANGING
FOR FAMILIES, AND IT IS CRUCIAL
WE ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS,
REGARDLESS OF DOCUMENTATION
STATUS, ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE MEANT TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS THRIVE. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO APPROXIMATELY 10
MILLION IMMIGRANTS OF, OF WHOM
NEARLY 2 MILLION ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS COME TO
LIVE, WORK, AND RAISE FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND SHOULD HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO LAY
ROOTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES BY
PURCHASING A HOME AS ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUAL. MOREOVER IMMIGRANTS
ARE PART OF THE REASON WHY
CALIFORNIA IS AN ECONOMIC
POWERHOUSE, CONTRIBUTING ROUGHLY
$51 BILLION IN STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES. UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
HELP FUND THE PROGRAMS THAT MANY
OTHER CALIFORNIANS BENEFIT FROM
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS. AB
1840 WILL ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUAL
IS NOT TURNED AWAY FOR THE
DREAM, FOR ALL PROGRAM, SOLELY
BASED ON THEIR DOCUMENTATION,
STATUS, HOME OWNERSHIP IS ALSO A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO BUILDING
GENERATIONAL WEALTH. BY ENSURING
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE A HOME,
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FURTHER CLOSE THE RACIAL WEALTH
GAP IN CALIFORNIA. AB 1840
ALIGNS WITH OUR GOALS AS A STATE
BY CONTINUING OUR COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL,
ONE WHERE EVERYONE, REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS, CAN
ACCESS THESE CRITICAL PROGRAMS.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON THIS BILL AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB 1840.
THANK YOU. BUENAS TARDES. SOY
MARIA. CARO SOY ORIGINARIA DE
MÉXICO. SOY MADRE DE TRACY. HÌ.
CIUDADANOS. ELLOS TIENEN LA EDAD
DE TREINTA VIÆT CC VIÆT DOS ANOS
COMO COMO MILHARES DE MIGRANTS
VENUS PIES CON ELLOS GANAS DE
SUPERM A STRING DE CUATRO ANOS
DE ESTADOS UNIDOS CON LA META DE
LA CASA INCOMPLETE, MISS
AMERICANO ACTUELLEMENT IN SUN
VALLEY, CALIFORNIA, DONDE RENT
AN APARTMENT. TODOS CAMERAS SOY
TRABAJADORA DE CASA LIMPIO CASA
SI PERSONAS DISCAPACIDADES CADA
MIS INTENTO. PERO NO ES
SUFICIENTE YA LOS PRECIOS DE LOS
HOGARES AND INCREMENTANDO MUY
RAPIDO. ME VISION PARA PODER SER
ESTÁ SUENO REALIDAD ES PODER,
VIVIR TRANQUILAMENTE AND ONDA
PODEMOS ESTAR COMODOS TODOS
TENTANDO APARTAMENTO EL PAGO
SEVEN MUY MUCHO LÀ RENDER C¯
CUANDO LE PEDIMOS QUÊ NIELSEN LA
VIVIENDA NO QUIERE SER IN CAMBIO
SI COMPRAMOS CASA EL NAZARIAN
PARA NOSOTROS BUENO Â TAMBIÉN
SERIA UN ATENCIA NO SOLO PARA
MIS HIJOS TAMBIÉN PARA MIS
NIETOS IN EL DOS MIL, SAY
SOLICITAR INFORMACIÓN PARA
LLEGAR PARA LA COMPRA DE ME
PRIMERO PIDIENDO MUY ALTO. LOS
PAGOS SALAS MUY ALTOS. CUANDO
TENEMOS Â TÍNH UN COSIGNER, EL
CUAL NO LO TENEMOS HOY ESTOY
AQUI IN SACRAMENTO, IN
REPRESENTATION DE ME FAMILIA E
DE LAS MULAS DE TRABAJADORES.
IMMIGRANTS IN CALIFORNIA PIDO UN
BOTO A FAVOR DE LA PROPUESTA DE
CUARENTA ESTE PROYECTO DE LEY
ESTATAL ES NECESARIO PARA PODER
ABRIR EL ACCESO AL APOYO DE
COMPRA DE CASA PARA COMPRADORES
INMIGRANTES E FAMILIAS COMO LA
MIA Ã PORTANTINO'S TODOS LOS
DIAS CON NUESTRO TRABAJO Y
ESFUERZO PARA ESTE ESTADO PARA
MEJORAR UN OPZIONE PARA VIVIR.
GRACIAS POR SU TIEMPO. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MARIA. I'M
ORIGINALLY FROM MEXICO. I AM A
MOTHER OF THREE U.S. CITIZEN
CHILDREN. THEY ARE AGED 30, 26
AND 22 YEARS OLD. LIKE MILLIONS
OF IMMIGRANTS, I CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY WITH THE GOAL OF
BETTERING MY LIFE. I CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES 34 YEARS AGO WITH
THE GOAL OF BUYING A HOUSE AND
COMPLETING MY AMERICAN DREAM.
CURRENTLY, I LIVE IN SUN VALLEY,
CALIFORNIA, WHERE I RENT A22
BEDROOM APARTMENT. I'M A
DOMESTIC WORKER, I CLEAN HOUSES
AND I TAKE CARE OF FOLKS WITH
DISABILITIES EVERY EVERY MONTH.
I TRY TO SAVE MONEY, BUT IT'S
NOT ENOUGH NOW THAT THE PRICES
OF HOMES HAVE GONE UP VERY
RAPIDLY, I ENVISION BEING ABLE
TO LIVE PEACEFULLY WHERE MY
FAMILY AND I CAN LIVE
COMFORTABLY. RENTING AN
APARTMENT. YOUR MONTHLY RENT
GOES TO A LANDLORD WHO, WHEN WE
ASK THEM TO MAKE A WHEN WE ASK
THEM TO FIX ISSUES IN THE HOUSE,
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO THAT. IF
WE WERE TO BUY A HOUSE, THE
MONTHLY PAYMENT WOULD BE TOWARDS
OUR DREAM HOME AND IT WOULD ALSO
BE AN INHERITANCE NOT ONLY FOR
MY KIDS, BUT FOR MY
GRANDCHILDREN. BORN IN 2006, I
SOLICITED INFORMATION TO APPLY
FOR THE FOR THE PURCHASE OF MY
FIRST HOME. THEY ASKED FOR A
DOWN PAYMENT THAT WAS WAY TOO
HIGH FOR ME, AND MONTHLY
PAYMENTS THAT WERE VERY, VERY
EXPENSIVE. WHEN THEY FOUND OUT
THAT I HAD AN ITIN, THEY ALSO
ASKED FOR A COSIGNER, WHICH I
DID NOT HAVE AT THE TIME. TODAY
I'M HERE IN SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTING MY FAMILY AND THE
MILLIONS OF HARD WORKING
IMMIGRANTS IN CALIFORNIA TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB 1840.
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY AND
URGENT TO BE ABLE TO OPEN ACCESS
TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
HELP IMMIGRANTS BUY A HOME.
FAMILIES LIKE MINE CONTRIBUTE TO
THE ECONOMY EVERY DAY WITH OUR
WORK AND WITH OUR WITH THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE MAKE TO
MAKE THIS STATE A BETTER PLACE
FOR EVERYONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LET ME SEE IF THERE'S OTHER
SUPPORTERS HERE WHO WANT TO ADD
ON. JUST COME TO THE MIC AND ADD
ON. MARK STIVERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT. WAS SUCH AN AWKWARD
ROOM DIVISIVE WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT? HI, MY
NAME IS URSULA AND I SUPPORT THE
1840 40. THE MINIMUM SUPPORT LÀ
ARE BASED. ACCORDING. TO. HØI I
SUPPORT AB 1840. JASMINE AND
WIECKOWSKI IN SUPPORT OF AB
1840. I SUPPORT AB 1840. HELLO.
MY NAME IS YESENIA ALTAMIRANO
AND I'M HERE SUPPORTING AB 1840.
STEPHEN SPENCER WITH BROWN TÍNH
ON BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. OPPOSITION GOOD
AFTERNOON, ALEJANDRO SOLIS ON
BEHALF OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION. OKAY. SEEING NONE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES? YES. SENATOR
SEYARTO, THANK YOU, THIS THIS
PROGRAM, THE DREAM FOR ALL
PROGRAM, WAS FUNDED, WHAT, TWO
YEARS AGO OR LAST YEAR, I
BELIEVE, THIS IS THE SECOND
ROUND OF FUNDING THAT'S GONE
OUT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS LAST
BUDGET YEAR, THEY DID 250
MILLION, AND THEY'RE CURRENTLY
IN THE PROCESS OF ANOTHER ROUND
OF 250 MILLION. RIGHT. SO IT WAS
OVERSOLD. THE PROGRAM IS
OVERSOLD ALREADY. CORRECT, ALL
OF THE FUNDS WILL HAVE BEEN
SUBSCRIBED TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GOTTEN THE LOANS. WE ARE REALLY
ONLY TALKING ABOUT AFTER PEOPLE
HAVE PAID BACK THE LOANS. THE
MONEY, WHICH. RIGHT. IN OTHER
WORDS, THE MONEY'S BEEN
ALLOCATED TO PEOPLE. IT WAS A
VERY POPULAR PROGRAM. CORRECT.
IT'S ALREADY POPULAR AND WE'RE
NOT ADDING TO IT YET, I'VE HEARD
A LOT OF STORIES FROM FROM A LOT
OF KIDS, THAT LIVE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. THEY'RE THE SAME
AGES AS THIS LADY'S KIDS, THEY
CAN'T GET HOUSING. AND THE
REASON THEY CAN'T GET HOUSING IS
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THEIR
PARENTS MAY BE RENTING NOW, AT
ONE TIME, THEY MAY HAVE OWNED A
HOME. AND THAT'S AN THAT'S A
DISQUALIFIER FROM BEING ABLE TO
APPLY TO THIS PROGRAM. IF YOUR
PARENTS ACTUALLY OWNED A HOME,
EVEN IF THEY LOST IT AND NOW
THEY DON'T HAVE A HOME, YOU ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR THIS
PROGRAM. SO THIS DREAM FOR
EVERYONE TURNS INTO A DREAM FOR
JUST A FEW ALREADY IN THE IN THE
CURRENT CONSTRAINTS OF THIS,
THIS, CONSTRAINTS OF THIS, THE
BILL, THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN AND
THAT WAS SOMETHING I WAS AFRAID
OF WAS THAT THE VERY PEOPLE THAT
NEED THIS THE WORST AREN'T GOING
TO HAVE ACCESS TO IT. AND SO NOW
WE'RE EXPANDING IT EVEN FARTHER
WITHOUT ADJUSTING AND TAKING
CARE OF THE ISSUES WITHIN THE
BILL ITSELF, BECAUSE I CAN SEE
THIS AS BEING VERY HELPFUL FOR
PEOPLE. BUT IT HAS TO BE HELPFUL
FOR PEOPLE THAT CAN GET ACCESS
TO START PAYING AND ALSO WHEN
THEY PAY THIS BACK, IT HELPS
FUEL THE PROGRAM FOR THE FUTURE.
AND I DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
ALL I SEE IS WE KEEP EXPANDING
WITHOUT ANSWERS TO WHY IT GOT
SOLD OUT IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
WHETHER WE HAVE ACCESS AVAILABLE
ALREADY TO PEOPLE THAT ARE OUR
KIDS, THAT ARE OUT THERE, THAT
ARE STUDENTS, AND, YOU KNOW,
THEY JUST GET OUT OF SCHOOL,
THEY CAN'T EVEN THEY CAN'T
AFFORD A HOUSE. MY KIDS ARE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED. THEY CAN'T
AFFORD A HOUSE. SO I'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THIS
BILL THAT ARE MORE ENCOMPASSING
SO THAT WE CAN INCLUDE EVERYONE
IN, THAT THOSE RESTRICTIONS
DON'T TAKE PLACE, BECAUSE IT IS
CUTTING A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF
THIS PROGRAM. AND, AND IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FIND IS VERY,
VERY HELPFUL TO EVERYBODY, WELL,
THEN IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING MORE MONEY
INTO. BUT IN ORDER FOR US TO DO
THAT, WE NEED TO SEE THAT IT'S
WORKING AND WORKING THE RIGHT
WAY, AND IT'S REACHING EVERYBODY
, INCLUDING PEOPLE THAT ALREADY
LIVE HERE. AND ARE ALREADY
CITIZENS. SO THAT'S MY CONCERN
IS, IS WE'RE GOING TO OVERSELL
THE PROGRAM. NOBODY'S GOING TO
HAVE ACCESS TO IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE ONLY A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS FOR IT ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR VENTURA, GO AHEAD.
YEAH, I AGREE WITH THE SENATOR.
I THINK WE CAN DO SO MUCH MORE
TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM. I WAS
NOT AWARE OF THAT, EXCEPTION
EXEMPTION. I MEAN, YOU DESCRIBED
A STORY THAT HAPPENED TO ME. MY
MOM HAD A HOUSE, AND WE GOT
EVICTED. SO NOW MY SISTER WILL
NO LONGER QUALIFY FOR A PROGRAM
THAT ACTUALLY BEEN TELLING HER
TO APPLY FOR, BUT I ALSO, YOU
KNOW, YOU BE.NO Ã HISTORIA IS
THE DISTRITO DE HÌ C¯ VÆ IN VÌ
DE SAN FERNANDO. YO ENTIENDO LOS
PRECIOS DE LAS CASAS AHI COMO
AUMENTADO CÁC UN MILLON DE
DOLARES. ESTAMOS RIGHT, YOU
KNOW, SHE'S, SHE SHARED THAT
SHE'S, SHE LIVES IN MY DISTRICT
AND, I KNOW HOW THE MEDIAN PRICE
THERE IS $1 MILLION AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS. COMO ME MAMA
TAMBIEN LIMPIA CASAS Â ENTIENDO
YAGO AQUI A UN LUGAR PARA
AGARRAR A SUENO AMERICANO.
VERDAD. AND SO ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
CLARIFY. IF I READ CORRECTLY,
YOU'RE LOOKING TO CREATE A
SUBACCOUNT, RIGHT? THAT'S
CORRECT. THIS IS A SEPARATE, NOT
TOUCHING ANYTHING OF WHAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ALLOCATED FOR THOSE
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
STANDING PROGRAM. WHEN FUNDING
IS APPROPRIATE, THE LEGISLATURE
HAS THE ABILITY TO PUT FUNDS
INTO SUB ACCOUNT THAT THAT MORE
PEOPLE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR, SO
IT DOESN'T DECREASE ANY FUNDING
FROM THE CURRENT PROGRAM. IS
THAT CORRECT? THAT'S CORRECT.
THE TWO ROUNDS OF FUNDING THE
500 MILLION WILL BE APPROPRIATED
UNDER THE CURRENT REGULATIONS.
THIS LAW WOULDN'T TAKE EFFECT
PRIOR TO THOSE FUNDS BEING OUT.
SO IT'S ONLY RESOURCES THAT ARE
COMING BACK. I MEAN, I THINK
WE'RE WE DEFINITELY NEED TO WORK
ON THE PROGRAM ITSELF, EXPANDING
IT FOR MORE PEOPLE. WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO INVEST MORE
MONEY IN IT AS WE HOPEFULLY
BOUNCE BACK FROM A DEFICIT AND
IF WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY,
INVEST IN A SEPARATE SUB
ACCOUNT, WHICH YOU'RE LOOKING TO
DO. SHOULD THIS LEGISLATION MAKE
IT ALL THE WAY THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS IT? I THINK IT'S A
PHENOMENAL IDEA, SO WHEN
APPROPRIATE, I'D BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THIS BILL. GRACIAS A LA
PARTE DE SU HISTORIA A DIOS MIO
ESPANOL. NÓ VERDAD. GRACIAS POR
VENIR A SU HISTORIA CON
NOSOTROS. THANK YOU FOR COMING
AND SHARING YOUR STORY WITH US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'LL
POINT OUT THE EVIDENCE WE HAVE
FROM THE FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING.
IS THAT THE PREDOMINANCE OF THE
MONEY WENT TO THE BAY AREA AND
TOWARDS CAUCASIAN FAMILIES, AND
I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT'S
MORE INCLUSIVE, THAT REMOVES
AMBIGUITY AND THAT CLEARS UP
THAT ALL PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY FOR
A HOME LOAN SHOULD BE ABLE TO
APPLY TO THIS PROGRAM,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU. WE WILL
ONCE WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
ENTERTAIN MOTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION. WILL NOW MOVE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL'S
BILL. WE AGREED TO TAKE THAT ONE
OUT OF ORDER. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL, YOU MAY PRESENT.
AND THAT IS ITEM 21 AB 3160.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES, I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 3160, WHICH
WILL PROVIDE 500 MILLION IN
ENHANCED STATE HOUSING TAX
CREDITS FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS, HELPING TO BUILD
THOUSANDS OF NEW AFFORDABLE
HOMES. IN 2019, CALIFORNIA BEGAN
ISSUING ENHANCED STATE HOUSING
CREDITS TO ADDRESS FINANCING
GAPS ASSOCIATED WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND BETTER
LEVERAGE MATCHING FUNDING.
CALIFORNIA'S ENHANCED CREDITS
HAVE HELPED BUILD TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOMES FOR VERY LOW, LOW AND
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THESE CREDITS HAVE ENABLED
CALIFORNIA TO DRAW DOWN BILLIONS
IN FEDERAL HOUSING CREDITS,
LEVERAGING EXISTING FEDERAL,
LOCAL AND PRIVATE FUNDING AT A
RATIO GREATER THAN 5 TO 1.
DEMAND FOR THESE CREDITS HAS
ALSO BEEN DRAMATICALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED SINCE THEIR
CREATION. AB 3160 WILL ENSURE
THAT THE 500 MILLION IN ENHANCED
CREDITS CONTINUE TO BE
AVAILABLE, PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WITH
ESSENTIAL CERTAINTY AS THEY PLAN
TO BUILD NEW HOMES. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A COALITION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS, HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION. OAN WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS MARK STIVERS, THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OF ADVOCACY AT
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
ONCE AGAIN, MARK STIVERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP, JUST TO PUT A
COUPLE OF SPECIFICS TO THE
STATEMENTS OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
THAT THE STATE HAS ALLOWED THESE
500 MILLION IN ENHANCED STATE
CREDITS, THEY HAVE RESULTED IN
25,000 HOMES AFFORDABLE TO VERY
LOW, LOW AND EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THEY HAVE
HELPED LEVERAGE $5.3 BILLION IN
FEDERAL HOUSING TAX CREDITS THAT
OTHERWISE CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE
LEFT ON THE TABLE. AND THE
OVERALL LEVERAGE HAS BEEN A
RATIO OF MORE THAN 5 TO 1 AS THE
ASSEMBLYMAN DESCRIBED. SO THAT
AND THEN I WOULD JUST ALSO JUST
LIKE TO OBSERVE THAT WE HAVE
46,000 AFFORDABLE HOMES IN THE
PIPELINE. THEY ARE PERMITTED.
THEY ARE READY, SHOVEL READY. WE
JUST NEED TO FINANCE THEM. THIS
CREDITS WILL ACTUALLY HELP US
GET THOSE TO CONSTRUCTION. AND
IT ALSO AS HE HAS SAID, HAS BEEN
A VERY BIPARTISAN PROGRAM. IT
HELPS US BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND REDUCES TAXES AT THE
SAME TIME. THAT'S A WIN WIN.
THANK YOU. GREAT. LET'S SEE IF
THERE ARE OTHER FOLKS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IF YOU
WANT TO COME TO THE MIC. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. DANNY KERN,
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS IN SUPPORT VERY MUCH.
DIVISIVE WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
COREY SMITH. WITH THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION AND SUPPORT.
RAFA SONNENFELD WITH THE OMB
ACTION AND SUPPORT. TIFFANY
MILLER SFM AND SUPPORT. MELISSA
MAY SFAB IN SUPPORT. SHAINA
ENGLUND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
ANGIE MINETTI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT NEVADA MERRIMAN
MID-PEN HOUSING AND SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
? I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
REGISTERED. OKAY ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM SEEING NONE. LET ME
SEE IF ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE, COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE. I APPRECIATE THE
BILL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
AND I WILL, WE CAN TAKE A
MOTION, BUT YOU'RE. YOU MAY
CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I APPRECIATE IT. I APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ALL THESE
ISSUES. AS I JUST MENTIONED. YOU
KNOW, THIS ALLOWS US TO LEVERAGE
SO MANY EXISTING RESOURCES OUT
THERE AND WILL HELP TO BUILD
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES THAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED. SO AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE. EXCELLENT. GREAT. THANK
YOU. I'LL TAKE THAT MOTION AS
SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM. ALL
RIGHT. SO NOW WE WILL GO TO BACK
IN ORDER. PLEASE LOOK AT MY
ORDER AND WE WILL GO TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ'S BILL, AND I
THINK YOU HAVE TWO TO PRESENT,
SO THE FIRST ONE, BUT IF YOU
WANT TO DO IT IN A DIFFERENT
ORDER, IS FINE WITH ME, BUT THE
WE HAVE AB 1886 ITEM FOR AND AB
2560 ITEM SIX. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. WE'LL BEGIN WITH AB 2560.
OKAY. OH THANK YOU. I'LL MAKE
THE ALLOW THE WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD AS THEY BEGIN THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL. AND
AGAIN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT, AB
2560, WHICH REQUIRES A STATE
DENSITY BONUS LAW. BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE COASTAL ZONE
OF CALIFORNIA, WITH EXEMPTIONS
STILL TO ENSURE THAT CRITICAL
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE NOT
THREATENED. AS YOU ARE ALL WELL
AWARE OF, WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
A HOUSING CRISIS THAT RENDERS
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS
VULNERABLE TO HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND CRIPPLING
HOUSING COSTS, IN ADDITION TO
JUST THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS STILL,
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS. IN RESPONSE, THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RIGHTFULLY TAKEN
A NUMBER OF ESSENTIAL STEPS TO
INCREASE SUPPLY OF ALL FORMS OF
HOUSING ACROSS THE STATE.
HOWEVER A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
HOUSING LEGISLATION HAS PASSED
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED INTO LAW
BY THE GOVERNOR AND IMPLEMENTED
OVER THE YEARS, HAS INCLUDED
CARVE OUTS TO EFFECTIVELY EXEMPT
COASTAL CALIFORNIA AND THE
COASTAL ZONE FROM THESE HOUSING
INITIATIVES. THESE CARVE OUTS
HAVE HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
LACK OF HOUSING BEING BUILT IN
THE COASTAL AREAS. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOUND THAT BETWEEN 1980 AND
2010, THE AVERAGE US METRO AREA
GREW BY 22. MORE THAN THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA COASTAL AREA.
LESS EASY TO QUANTIFY ARE THE
COUNTLESS UNITS THAT GO
UNDEVELOPED. BECAUSE THE
MAJORITY OF DEVELOPERS HAVE
COMPLETELY ABANDONED TRYING TO
BUILD IN THE COASTAL AREA, THEY
DUE TO LACK OF OBJECTIVE
BUILDING STANDARDS THAT LEAD TO
LENGTHY AND COST PROHIBITIVE
TIMELINES. AT ITS CORE, AB 2560
IS MEANT TO MODERNIZE OUR
APPROACH TO HOUSING ON THE
COAST. IT IS A REJECTION OF THE
STATUS QUO, WHICH SAYS THAT THE
CURRENT PROCESS FOR BUILDING AND
DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OUR WEALTHY COASTAL AREAS IS
SUFFICIENT, ACCORDING TO SOME,
IT IS ALSO A RECOGNITION OF THE
FACT THAT THE LACK OF OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
IN THE COASTAL ZONE THAT
DEVELOPERS RELY ON TO MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS TO BUILD HOUSING, AND
THAT THEY RELY ON ON THE REST OF
THE STATE TO TAKE ON THE RISKY
INVESTMENT OF BUILDING HOUSING
IS NO LONGER ACCEPTABLE. I FULLY
APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
COAST AS A VALUABLE RESOURCES
THAT I THINK ALL OF US DO FOR
OUR STATE, AND THE NEED TO LEAVE
WITH THE NEED TO HAVE IT,
PROTECTED AND TO STYMIE
DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS THAT ARE
NOT FIT FOR DEVELOPMENT, SUCH AS
WETLANDS NEAR CLIFFS, OR AREAS
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO SEA LEVEL
RISE, AMONG OTHERS. THIS
APPRECIATION IS WHY NOT ONLY WHY
WE NOT ONLY ADDED EXEMPTED AREAS
NEGOTIATED AND AGREED UPON LAST
YEAR BETWEEN THE AUTHOR, AND THE
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL 423,
ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES. BUT WE
ALSO ACCEPTED ADDITIONAL
EXEMPTIONS. THESE EXEMPTIONS
INCLUDE LAND THAT IS WITHIN
100FT OF A WETLAND, ESTUARY OR
STREAM, LAND THAT IS BETWEEN THE
FIRST PUBLIC ROAD AND THE SEA.
LAND THAT IS VULNERABLE TO FIVE
FEET OF SEA LEVEL RISE, LAND
THAT IS DESIGNATED AS PRIME
AGRICULTURAL LAND AND AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED AS
SENSITIVE COASTAL RESOURCE AREAS
. ADDITIONALLY, STATE DENSITY
BONUS IS ARGUABLY THE MOST
APPROPRIATE HOUSING LAW TO
IMPLEMENT IN THE COAST. A
DEVELOPER CAN ONLY UTILIZE THE
INCENTIVES OF THIS LAW IN AREAS
PREVIOUSLY DETERMINED BY THE
LOCAL CITIES AND LOCAL COUNTIES
THAT IT IS FIT FOR HOUSING, NOT
JUST FOR SINGLE FAMILY, BUT IT
MUST BE FOR MULTIFAMILY HOUSING.
AND THIS WAS A DESIGNATION THAT
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAD TO
CERTIFY THEMSELVES THROUGH THEIR
LOCAL COASTAL PLANS. IN OTHER
WORDS, OUTSIDE OF THE
EXEMPTIONS, THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO AREAS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DECIDED WERE FIT
FOR HOUSING BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AB 2560 IS ONLY ASKING THAT WE
INCREASE THE DENSITY IN THESE
RESIDENTIAL AREAS. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT IT IS OFTEN
LOST IN CONVERSATIONS, AND YOU
MIGHT HEAR SOME COMMENTS FROM
SOME THAT THE LACK OF HOUSING IS
MORE THAN A HOUSING ISSUE. IT IS
ALSO AN EQUITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
MATTER FOR THE COASTAL ECONOMY
TO FUNCTION, IT REQUIRES THAT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SERVICE
WORKERS TO SERVE AS A BACKBONE
OF THAT ECONOMY. HOWEVER BEING
UNABLE TO AFFORD TO LIVE NEAR
THEIR JOBS NECESSITATES THAT
THESE WORKERS EXPEND RESOURCES
AND EMIT FURTHER CO2 INTO THE
AIR TO COMMUTE TO WORK. COMP
ENDING THE CLIMATE CRISIS THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO, ADDRESS AND
THAT THE COASTAL COMMISSION IS
ENTRUSTED TO PROTECT TO THIS
POINT, THE AFOREMENTIONED LÀ Ó
REPORT ALSO FOUND THAT, QUOTE,
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL
COMMUNITIES COMMUTE 10% FURTHER
EACH DAY THAN COMMUTERS
ELSEWHERE, LARGELY BECAUSE OF
LIMITED HOUSING OPTIONS.
FINALLY, I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THIS BILL.
THAT'S THE FOCUS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE DENSITY BONUS
AND CONCESSIONS IN THIS LAW. IT
REQUIRES THAT DEVELOPERS MUST
DEED RESTRICT A PERCENTAGE OF
UNITS FOR VERY LOW, LOW OR
MODERATE INCOME INDIVIDUALS. IN
OTHER WORDS, THE DEVELOPMENTS
THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE UNDER
THIS BILL ARE MULTIFAMILY MIXED
INCOME PROJECTS. THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS WE WANT TO SEE IN ALL
OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. I ALSO
WANT TO ADDRESS SOMETHING
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION IS SAYING
THIS BILL DOES NOT EXEMPT
DENSITY BONUS PROJECTS FROM THE
PERMITTING PROCESS. EVERY
PROJECT WOULD STILL NEED TO GO
GET A COASTAL DEVELOPMENT PERMIT
AND GO THROUGH EVERY OTHER
REVIEW PROCESS THAT THEY WOULD
TODAY. AB 2560 SIMPLY SAYS THAT
A PROJECT THAT IS ON A PARCEL
THAT IS ZONED FOR MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING, THAT IS NOT LOCATED IN
THE AREAS EXEMPTED IN THIS BILL,
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE BONUSES AND
CONCESSIONS AFFORDED IN STATE
DENSITY BONUS LAW. JUST LIKE
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE ELSE IN THE
STATE. I'M OPEN TO CLARIFYING
THIS OR OTHER ITEMS IN, AS WE
MOVE THIS FORWARD BY, BUT BY
ENSURING THAT WE INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE COAST
BY INCREASING DENSITY IN AREAS
DETERMINED FIT FOR HOUSING BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEMSELVES,
AND CERTIFIED BY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION, WE CAN MAKE REAL
IMPACT IN HOUSING CRISIS THERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND NOW
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE WITNESSES.
WILL MORE FROM CIRCULATE SAN
DIEGO. WE'LL GO FIRST. GO AHEAD.
HELLO, MY NAME IS WILL MOORE.
I'M POLICY COUNSEL WITH
CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO, A NONPROFIT
, WHOSE MISSION IS TO CREATE
EXCELLENT MOBILITY CHOICES AND
VIBRANT, HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS,
AB 2560 THE BILL BEFORE YOU
WOULD MAKE DENSITY BONUS LAW,
WHICH HAS PROVEN SUCCESSFUL IN
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA TO CREATE
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING EFFECTIVE IN THE COASTAL
ZONE DENSITY BONUS GRANTS,
CONCESSIONS AND INCENTIVES,
CONCESSIONS, INCENTIVES AND
ADDITIONAL UNITS TO PROJECTS
THAT CREATE DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT ONLY
APPLIES IN PLACES THAT ARE
ALREADY ZONED MULTIFAMILY FOR
FIVE OR MORE UNITS. BECAUSE OF
THIS DENSITY, BONUS LAW IS THE
PERFECT TOOL TO CREATE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
COASTAL AREAS WITHOUT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING OUR SENSITIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL HABITATS. AB 2560
APPLYING DENSITY BONUS TO THE
COASTAL ZONE IS A MODEST AND
NARROWLY TAILORED REFORM TO
ADDRESS OUR COASTAL HOUSING
CRISIS. FURTHER AS AMENDED, IT
EXPLICITLY PRESERVES APPEAL
RIGHTS AND BUFFERS OUR SENSITIVE
COASTAL AREAS. THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS MADE HAS AN
IMPORTANT MANDATE TO PROTECT OUR
COASTAL HABITAT AND COASTAL
ACCESS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. IT
IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
REVIEWING MANY TYPES OF HOUSING
PROPOSALS NEAR THE COAST.
UNFORTUNATELY, OVER THE YEARS,
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS
DELAYED OR DENIED NUMEROUS
PROPOSALS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOMES. LAST WEEK, CIRCULATE
RELEASED OUR LATEST REPORT, OF
WHICH I AM THE PRIMARY AUTHOR, A
BETTER COASTAL COMMISSION HOW
REFORMS CAN HELP THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION ADDRESS
AFFORDABILITY, RESIDENTIAL
SEGREGATION AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
I DELIVERED A HARD COPY OF THAT
REPORT TO ALL OF YOUR OFFICES
THIS MORNING IN THAT REPORT, WE
REVIEW THE IMPORTANT MISSION OF
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND
DEMONSTRATE THAT HOUSING IS LESS
AVAILABLE, LESS AFFORDABLE AND
MORE EXCLUSIVE IN AREAS WHERE
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS
JURISDICTION. FOR EXAMPLE,
ROUGHLY TWO THIRDS OF COASTAL
ZONE RESIDENTS ARE WHITE,
COMPARED TO JUST OVER ONE THIRD
OF THE REST OF THE STATE, AND
THE COASTAL ZONE NEIGHBORHOODS
ARE SUBSTANTIALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN SIMILAR NEIGHBORHOODS JUST
OUTSIDE THE COASTAL ZONE. THE
REPORT IDENTIFIES A NUMBER OF
EXAMPLES WHERE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS DELAYED OR DENIED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, OR IN THE
USE OF DENSITY BONUS.
IMPORTANTLY, IN EACH OF THESE
INSTANCES, THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WAS PROPOSED ON LAND
ALREADY ZONED FOR MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING, AND THAT ZONING ITSELF
HAD ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. MOST
NOTABLY, NONE OF THE GROUNDS FOR
DELAY AND OBJECTION IN THESE
EXAMPLES ARE BASED IN ANY
REASONS THAT AN ORDINARY PERSON
WOULD CALL ENVIRONMENTAL. THIS
MEANS THAT AB TWO 560 IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE DENSITY BONUS
WORK AND START TO WRAP UP. THERE
IS A TWO MINUTE LIMIT, AND IT'S
LIMITED AND TARGETED AT, AND IT
WILL TRULY MAKE THE COAST
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL INCOMES. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M NEVADA
MERRIMAN. I'M VICE PRESIDENT OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY FOR MID-PEN
HOUSING. WE ARE A NONPROFIT
OWNER OPERATOR SERVICE PROVIDER,
AND IN THE LAST 50 YEARS, WE'VE
DEVELOPED OVER 125 COMMUNITIES
AND TEN STATE SENATE DISTRICTS.
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW IS A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. VIRTUALLY
ALL OF THE 4500 UNITS IN OUR
PIPELINE, AND 10,000 UNITS IN
OUR PORTFOLIO PORTFOLIO HAVE
USED IT. WITHOUT THIS TOOL, WE
WOULD HAVE ROUGHLY 3500 FEWER
HOMES. IN TWO RECENT EXAMPLES OF
DEVELOPING IN THE COASTAL ZONE,
ONE OF THEM IS JESSIE STREET
PROJECT. IT IS A 50 UNIT, FOUR
STORY PROJECT IN THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ. THE CITY ASKED US TO
USE NEW STATE STREAMLINING
TOOLS. AB 1763 AND AB 2162. AND
THIS PROJECT, ALTHOUGH IT
QUALIFIED FOR MINISTERIAL PERMIT
PROCESSING OF THREE MONTHS, WAS
UNABLE TO ACCESS THIS BECAUSE WE
ALSO NEEDED A COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT. AND IT'S A
STORY OF COLLABORATION, BOTH THE
CITY STAFF AND THE COASTAL
COMMISSION STAFF SHOWED GREAT
PROFESSIONALISM. THEY DID THEIR
BEST TO TRY TO MAKE THE FINDINGS
AND MOVE FORWARD, BUT THEY
SIMPLY, EACH BELIEVE THEY LACKED
AUTHORITY TO MAKE CERTAIN
DECISIONS AND DID NOT HAVE A
CLEAR PATH THROUGH. SO THERE'S A
LACK OF ALIGNMENT. TOP TO BOTTOM
BETWEEN THESE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES. ANOTHER PROJECT,
CYPRESS POINT, IS IN MOSS BEACH
ALONG THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
COASTLINE. WE'VE BEEN TIED UP IN
LEGAL CASES THERE, GOING ON OUR
EIGHTH YEAR OF PRE-DEVELOPMENT,
THIS IS SOMETHING, A SITE THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE HOUSING
ELEMENT IN THE FOURTH CYCLE AS
FAR BACK AS 1980. IT WAS
AFFIRMED AND REAFFIRMED THROUGH
THE LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM AS ONE
OF THE VERY FEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SITES IN THE MID COAST.
THE EXISTING PLAN UNIT
DEVELOPMENT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT WAS 148 HOMES, AND THE
PROJECT AS PROPOSED TODAY IS 71.
SO, MAYBE IT'S COMMON SENSE, BUT
71 UNITS IS A LOT LESS OF AN
IMPACT THAN 148. SO BY GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO GO IN
AND REVISE THE LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAM, IT GAVE OPPORTUNITIES,
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES, TO
HAVE LEGAL CHALLENGES. MARKET
RATE DEVELOPERS ALSO PROVIDE A
RANGE OF AFFORDABILITY BY
UTILIZING THE STATE DENSITY
BONUS LAW. AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE LACK OF HOUSING AT
ALL LEVELS EXACERBATES THE NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM IS SO BIG,
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE ALONE
CAN TAKE ON. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, OTHER FOLKS IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MIC AND
ADD YOUR SUPPORT. DANNY CURTAIN,
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. NINA HARWELL,
AARP CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. COREY SMITH, HOUSING
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
DIVYA SCHIFF, HOUSING CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. MARK STIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MICHAEL
AND WHISPER, CO-SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT. RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH THE NBA ACTION
IN SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF OF
YIMBY ACTIONS, CHAPTERS AND
PARTNERS INCLUDING EAST BAY
YIMBY MOUNTAIN VIEW, YIMBY,
NORTHERN NEIGHBORS, PENINSULA
FOR EVERYONE, SAN FRANCISCO
YIMBY, SANTA CRUZ, YIMBY, SANTA
ROSA, YIMBY, SLOW C¢M URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALIST, GROW THE
RICHMOND VENTURA COUNTY YIMBY
STREETS FOR PEOPLE, SOUTH SIDE
FORWARD, HOW TO ADU PEOPLE FOR
HOUSING, ORANGE COUNTY PROGRESS,
NÓI VALLEY, SOUTH BAY, YIMBY AND
NAPA SOLANO FOR EVERYONE. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MOIRA
THORPE, ON BEHALF OF JUST THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO, SUPPORT ANGIE
MINETTI IN SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
. HOLLY FOR MEETING WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE INNER CITY LAW
CENTER, CIVIC WELL AND THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, AND SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, JARED MOSS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH AND
THE SAN DIEGO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, SUPPORT. NHIÀU TH¤U ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CASSIE MANCINI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LUIS MORANTE, ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL,
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. ANGELA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JORDAN, A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HELLO. TIFFANY MILLER, SAN
FRANCISCO OMB AND STRONG SUPPORT
. HELLO, ALYSSA MAY, SAN
FRANCISCO YIMBY SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S
SEE IF WE JUST HAVE THEM SIT AT
THE FRONT TABLE. YOU CAN SIT AT
THIS FRONT TABLE. C . AND, YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES BETWEEN YOU.
SO NOT EACH. WE'LL TRY NOT TO
USE ALL OF IT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M SEAN DRAKE,
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
WHILE THE COMMISSION CERTAINLY
SUPPORTS THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
MORE DENSE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE, IT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES AB 2560 BECAUSE COASTAL
ACT EXEMPTIONS ARE NOT NECESSARY
TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. I WANT TO
CLARIFY FROM THE OUTSET THAT
DENSITY BONUS LAW ALREADY
APPLIES IN THE COASTAL ZONE. FOR
DECADES, MULTIFAMILY PROJECTS IN
THE COASTAL ZONE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY INCORPORATED THE
MANY INCENTIVES AFFORDED BY
DENSITY BONUS LAW, WHILE ALSO
AVOIDING UNNECESSARY IMPACTS TO
SENSITIVE HABITATS, PUBLIC
COASTAL ACCESS, OR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION EFFORTS. THIS HAS
OCCURRED UNDER CURRENT LAW,
WHICH REQUIRES THE DENSITY BONUS
LAW IN THE COASTAL ACT BE
HARMONIZED SO THAT THE
OBJECTIVES OF BOTH LAWS ARE MET.
THIS BILL WOULD INSTEAD
ESTABLISH THE DENSITY BONUS LAW
SUPERSEDES THE COASTAL ACT AND
INVALIDATES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAMS. CONTRARY
TO WHAT YOU'VE HEARD, THIS IS A
COASTAL ACT EXEMPTION BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS DEVELOPERS TO IGNORE ANY
LOCAL COASTAL POLICY OF THEIR
CHOOSING, INCLUDING EROSION,
SETBACKS, SENSITIVE HABITAT
BUFFERS OR PUBLIC ACCESS WAYS.
THIS EXEMPTION ALSO PUNISHES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE
PROACTIVELY UPDATED THEIR LOCAL
COASTAL PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE
DENSITY BONUS HARMONIZATION
PROVISIONS. AS CITIES LIKE SANTA
CRUZ, WHICH MET ITS HOUSING
PRODUCTION REQUIREMENTS ACROSS
ALL LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY LAST
CYCLE, PARTLY AS A RESULT OF ALL
THE DENSITY BONUS PROJECTS
PERMITTED IN THE CITY, THESE
CITIES ARE PROOF THAT DENSE
INFILL HOUSING AND COASTAL
RESOURCE PROTECTION ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE MEMBERS.
THERE IS A DEMONSTRATED BETTER
WAY TO DO THIS. WE CONTINUE TO
SUGGEST THAT THE AUTHOR AMEND
THE BILL TO REQUIRE COASTAL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, WHO HAVEN'T
DONE SO ALREADY, TO UPDATE THEIR
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAMS TO
INCLUDE DENSITY BONUS
HARMONIZATION PROVISIONS. THIS
WOULD PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY
FOR DEVELOPERS WITHOUT A
NEEDLESS AND DAMAGING COASTAL
ACT EXEMPTION. WE URGE YOU TO
INVEST IN THIS APPROACH. AND
BEFORE I CLOSE, I JUST WANT TO
NOTE, SINCE THE CIRCULATE SAN
DIEGO REPORT WAS MENTIONED, THE
COMMISSION HAS REVIEWED THAT
DOCUMENT SINCE IT CAME OUT
SEVERAL DAYS AGO. I WOULD
OBSERVE THAT THE DOCUMENT RELIES
ENTIRELY ON FIVE PROJECTS AND
OMITS CRITICAL FACTS IN ITS
DESCRIPTION OF THOSE PROJECTS.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE A POINT
FITTING THE LEGISLATIVE AGENDA
PRESENTED TO YOU. NOTEWORTHY,
TOO, IS THAT FOUR OF THOSE
PROJECTS WERE APPROVED, WITH THE
MOST RECENT ONE STILL PENDING.
NONE WERE DENIED. THE COMMISSION
HAS ALREADY PROVIDED A WRITTEN
REBUTTAL, WITH ADDITIONAL
DETAIL, AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT TO THIS COMMITTEE
AS FOLLOW UP. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR, AND
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS THOMAS VALADEZ. I'M THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH
AZUL. AZUL IS A LATINX LED AND
SERVING GRASSROOTS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION WITH A
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON WORKING
WITH LATINX COMMUNITIES TO
PROTECT THE OCEAN AND COAST. I'M
HERE TODAY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE GROUPS THAT SUBMITTED AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED LETTER ON
JUNE 4TH. WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL, UNLESS AMENDED, TO
REMOVE THE EXEMPTION OF THE VAST
MAJORITY OF DENSITY BONUS
PROJECTS IN THE COASTAL ZONE
FROM COASTAL COMMISSION
OVERSIGHT. WHILE WE RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR NEW SOLUTIONS TO
THE STATE'S URGENT HOUSING
CRISIS AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
WITH THE GOAL OF BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE, WE FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREE THAT THE BARRIER TO
THIS GOAL IS THE COASTAL ACT. IN
FACT, THE COASTAL ACT IS THE
ONLY STATUTE PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO ACCESS THE
COAST, AND THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO PREVENT DENSITY BONUS
PROJECTS FROM IMPACTING OR
BLOCKING PUBLIC COASTAL ACCESS.
AND WHILE IT IS TRUE THAT
HOUSING IS AN ASPECT OF
PROVIDING EQUITABLE PUBLIC
ACCESS AND PRACTICED DENSITY,
BONUS LAW PROVIDES ONLY A TOKEN
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
JUSTIFY PROJECTS THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO GENTRIFICATION OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. WE RECOMMEND A MORE
REFINED APPROACH THAT SEEKS TO
BUILD ON EXPERIENCES OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
UPDATED AND AMENDED THEIR LCP TO
INCLUDE POLICIES THAT HARMONIZE
DENSITY, BONUS LAW AND THE
COASTAL ACT. SUCH AN APPROACH
COULD MIRROR AMENDMENTS MADE
EARLIER THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION
TO SB 951 THAT REQUIRED THAT LCP
BE UPDATED TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATES. OUR
GROUPS HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL CONSIDER AN ALTERNATIVE
BEFORE APPROVING AN
UNPRECEDENTED EXEMPTION TO THE
COASTAL ACT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. YOU
CAN JUST COME TO THE MIC WITH
YOUR ME TWOS. A CHAIRMAN
JACOBSON WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND SURFRIDER, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, AUSTIN CHEN. WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION COMMITTEE
OF WEST MARIN. WE OPPOSE AB 2560
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED. YOU SAY
IT'S YOUR JUST A ME TO YOU. YOU
CONVEYED. OKAY I HAVE A GROUP
CAN'T. OH IF YOU CAN LIST YOUR
OTHER GROUP GO AHEAD PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE THE
CLIMATE CENTER CALIFORNIA COAST
KEEPER ALLIANCE. OUR CITY SF
ORANGE COUNTY COAST KEEPER RIVER
ECOLOGY PROJECT, WATERSHED
ALLIANCE OF MARIN PUVUNGA
WETLANDS PROTECTORS, FOREST
UNLIMITED RESOURCE RENEWAL
INSTITUTE, ENVIRONMENTAL
CALIFORNIA NORTH COAST RIVERS
ALLIANCE SOCAL 350. CLIMATE
ACTION, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATERSHED ALLIANCE DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE, CANYON BACK ALLIANCE,
COASTAL LANDS ACTION NETWORK,
SAN FRANCISCO BAY. PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY,
DEFEND BALLONA WETLANDS,
CALIFORNIA RIVER WATCH
ENVIRONMENTAL CENTER OF SAN
DIEGO. CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS.ORG
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY,
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION
NETWORK, HUMBOLDT WATERKEEPER,
GREEN FOOTHILLS, GAVIOTA COAST
CONSERVANCY, SANTA CLARA VALLEY,
AUDUBON SOCIETY, ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTER, LAGUNA FARM, LOS
CERRITOS WETLANDS TRUST,
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL RESOURCES
PROTECTION ALLIANCE,
INCORPORATED, SMITH RIVER, SMITH
RIVER ALLIANCE, SAVE SONOMA
COAST, I'LL KNOW MORE SOCAL
VENICE, CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY, ENDANGERED HABITATS
LEAGUE, PROTECT FIONA WETLANDS,
WEST SONOMA COUNTY ALLIANCE,
SURFRIDER, PUBLIC TRUST
ALLIANCE, FRIENDS OF HARBORS,
BEACHES AND PARKS. BALLONA
WETLANDS INSTITUTE I THINK
YOU'VE REPEATED SOME. SO, NO.
WELL, ACTUALLY, I HEARD THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT BAIONA. YEAH
COAST WALK AND NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE CENTER. THANK YOU. OKAY
I JUST GOT ONE FOR YOU. MELISSA
ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED, UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS STATED.
THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
PAUL GONSALVES, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF ELK GROVE, FAIRFIELD,
NORWALK, PALM DESERT, SANTA
CLARITA AND THOUSAND OAKS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. HELLO.
JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION, UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF CARLSBAD AND RANCHO PALOS
VERDES. RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
KIARA ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SOLANA BEACH IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NATALIE
BROWN, ON BEHALF OF THE PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY.
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. AND
CHRISTY FOY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF REDONDO BEACH, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE
IF THE DAIS HAS ANY COMMENTS.
YES. GO AHEAD. SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE. GO AHEAD. OH,
THAT'S RIGHT, I SAW. YES. THANK
YOU, I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL
COMING FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
BEING THE MAYOR OF A COASTAL
CITY WHERE THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS, WHERE NEARLY EVERY
AFFORDABLE UNIT IS BECAUSE OF A
DENSITY BONUS PROJECT. AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT IT'S A
HIGH LAND VALUE COMMUNITY WHERE
IF A DEVELOPER IS ALLOWED TO ADD
MORE MARKET RATE UNITS, THEN
THEY HAVE TO DEED RESTRICT AND
PROVIDE AFFORDABILITY FOR THE
OTHER UNITS. AND SO RECOGNIZING
THE REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE OF
DENSITY BONUS IN CREATING
AFFORDABILITY AND HIGH LAND COST
COMMUNITIES AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT, AND THEN
EXPLICITLY NOT CARVING OUT WHERE
LARGE PERCENTAGES OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY LIVE, WHICH IS THE
COASTAL ZONE, I THINK IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT POLICY GOAL. SO
THE COASTAL ACT, STILL, WE ALL
OF US IN THIS ROOM AND ON THIS
COMMITTEE, I'M SURE VALUE THE
COAST, WANT OUR PUBLIC TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE COAST. DO NOT
WANT THIS TO BECOME A MIAMI LIKE
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE HIGH
RISES AND PRIVATE BEACHES AND
THINGS THAT WE WOULD NEVER
TOLERATE IN CALIFORNIA AND
HAVEN'T FOR DECADES BECAUSE OF
THE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS OF THE
COASTAL ACT. BUT IT'S
UNQUESTIONED TRUE THAT PROJECTS
THAT PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND ALSO JUST ACCESS TO HIGH
OPPORTUNITY COMMUNITIES ARE
LIMITED. WHEN WE DON'T WHEN WE
DON'T APPLY THE HOUSING LAWS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE REST OF THE
STATE TO THE COASTAL ZONE. SO
I'M, I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
BALANCE THESE ISSUES, BUT THE
WAY I READ THIS BILL, IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY GET OUT OF BALANCE. SO
THIS IS A WAY FOR US TO PROVIDE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOUSING
IN THE COASTAL ZONE, WHILE ALSO
CONTINUING TO PROTECT OUR
SENSITIVE COASTAL RESOURCES.
THANK YOU. CHAIR YOU'RE WELCOME,
SENATOR SATO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO COMING FROM AN INLAND
COMMUNITY, ONE OF OUR
FRUSTRATIONS IS THAT IF THE
COASTAL AREAS DON'T DO THEIR
SHARE OF BUILDING OF THE DENSITY
AND THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
NEEDED, AND THIS BILL WOULDN'T
BE HERE IF IT WAS IF THIS ISSUE
WERE BEING HANDLED CORRECTLY,
THEN THE EFFORT GOES TO MAKING
MORE IN THOSE AREAS WHERE THERE
ARE NO JOBS AND THEN EVERYBODY'S
COMMUTING, JUST LIKE THEY HAD
SAID. SO I THINK WHAT THIS BILL
IS, IS A LESSON IN IF WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE, SOLUTION MINDED,
APPROACHES TO DEALING WITH THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE, THEN LET'S
ISOLATION APPEARS, TO, TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN, AND, AND THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING. I HAVE HEARD
NO ONE, TELL ME HOW EASY IT WAS
TO IN ANY PROCESS THAT HAD TO
DEAL WITH THE COASTAL COMMISSION
, IT WAS ANOTHER LAYER OF
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY HAD TO GET
THROUGH, AND A LOT OF TIMES THEY
COULDN'T EVEN GET THROUGH IT.
AND THEREFORE, THE BILL, THE
HOUSING THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO GO
IN THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO GET
IN, WINDS UP NOT HAPPENING AT
ALL. AND IT WASN'T HOUSING THAT
WOULD LIMIT BEACH ACCESS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, IT WAS
HOUSING THAT MADE SENSE, IT
WOULD, IT WAS HOUSING THAT WAS
SITTING ON VACANT LAND,
APPARENTLY, YOU KNOW, IN AN AREA
WHERE IT COULD VERY WELL HAVE
FIT IN. FINE, BUT THEY CAN'T GET
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. SO I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK THE AGENCY HAS TO LOOK AT.
AND, AND, YOU KNOW, AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE A ROLE
IN WHY SOME OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS COMING THROUGH NOW. IT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE MORE
HOUSING, AND WE HAVE TO HAVE
HOUSING WHERE PEOPLE WORK AND
LIVE OR WANT TO LIVE AND RIGHT
NOW THERE'S AN EXTREME IMBALANCE
OF THAT. SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY, WHEN THE TIME
COMES. BUT RIGHT NOW I HAVE TO
GO PRESENT A BILL BY. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT? NO. OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE CAN'T TAKE MOTIONS YET
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T ESTABLISHED
QUORUM, YOU'RE. HERE. SO WE CAN
DO Ó. BUT WE JUST LOST OUR
OTHER PERSON. YES OH, HE DIDN'T
LEAVE YET. OKAY, SO LET'S SEE IF
WE CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM NOW, DO
WE? ONE, TWO. THREE, FOUR. LET'S
BE GOOD. ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S DO
A ROLL CALL TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
SENATOR SKINNER, I'M HERE.
SKINNER PRESENT. CHOBOQ.
PRESENT. BLAKE SPEER, PRESENT.
BLAKE SPEER. PRESENT. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. PRESENT.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. PRESENT.
PADILLA. SIERRA SERRATO.
PRESENT. BURKE. WAHAB. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE QUORUM. THAT'S A
GOOD THING. MEANS WE CAN TAKE
SOME MOTIONS. ALL RIGHT, SO, I
APPRECIATE THIS, BILL. AND I
APPRECIATE THE COASTAL ACT AND
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. THE,
BEING A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN AND
MY, FOR FIRST EX PERIOD OF TIME
OF MY LIFE, THERE WAS NO COASTAL
ACT. I WATCHED WITH HORROR AS,
DEVELOPERS WOULD, IN EFFECT.
STRIP ALL OF US FROM PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE COAST DUE TO
THEIR, THE DEVELOPMENTS AND
ESPECIALLY AND ALL OF THEM WERE
VERY HIGH END EXCLUSIVE
DEVELOPMENTS, AND SO HERE IS A
RESOURCE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD BENEFIT FROM. AND IF WE
COMPARE TO HAWAII, MANY OF THE
ISLANDS IN HAWAII THAT DID NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE COASTAL
PROTECTIONS FOR YEARS, AND WHERE
, YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN IT'S VERY
TRAGIC. HOWEVER, OUR COASTAL
PROTECTIONS, AS IS BEEN, AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT, AS YOUR
BILL POINTS OUT, NEED TO PROTECT
THE SENSITIVE LAND, NEED TO
PROTECT A VARIETY OF THE COASTAL
RESOURCES. BUT THEY WEREN'T
DESIGNED TO ELIMINATE HOUSING.
NOW, I KNOW THE COASTAL
COMMISSION FEELS THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE OF THE ACT
AND THE DIFFERENT CHANGES HAVE
NOT ELIMINATED HOUSING. AND YES,
THERE HAS BEEN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. SO CERTAINLY WE
KNOW THAT SINCE THE ACT'S BEEN.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO I DON'T WANT
TO GET INTO THAT DEBATE, BUT WE
DO KNOW FROM AND I WANT TO TAKE,
FOR EXAMPLE, OUR TESTIMONY FROM
MID-PEN HOUSING THAT IS NOT JUST
ANECDOTAL THERE. WE HAVE
MULTIPLE, CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
HAVE INDICATED THAT THEY HAVE
THEY DON'T EVEN ATTEMPT TO DO A
PROJECT WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE
BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE BEFORE
THEY CAN, WORK OUT ALL THE, YOU
KNOW, PROCEED. AND AS WE KNOW,
TIME IS MONEY AND HOUSING. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE A GREATER
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING IN COASTAL
AREAS. WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT A
GREATER SHORTAGE, SHORTAGE
THERE. AND AS WAS POINTED OUT BY
SOME OF THE FOLKS IN TESTIFYING,
IF WE GO TO SOME OF OUR MORE
POPULAR COASTAL AREAS LIKE
MENDOCINO AREA OR, MONTEREY AND
SUCH, THE, THE, THE, WHERE THE
ECONOMY IS LARGELY SERVICE OR
TOURIST BASED, THE THEY CAN'T
FIND WORKERS BECAUSE WORKERS
HAVE NOWHERE TO LIVE. SO WE DO
HAVE TO REACH A BALANCE. NOW, I
KNOW I DO APPRECIATE THAT THE
COASTAL ACT FEELS THAT THEY HAVE
THAT WITH THE LOCAL COASTAL
PLANS AND OTHER PROVISIONS, THAT
THAT IS THE CASE. BUT WHEN I
LOOK AT THIS BILL AND I LOOK AT
THE I GUESS I, I KNOW IT DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH FROM THE POINT OF
VIEW OF THE COASTAL COMMISSION,
BUT I LOOK AT THE BILL AND IT IT
RESPECTS THE COASTAL ACT IN
TERMS OF THE, THE PROTECTION OF
THE SENSITIVE AREAS, THE NOTHING
, NOTHING ON THE I DON'T WANT TO
USE THE WRONG WORDS, BUT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ HELPED
ME HERE ON THE PUBLIC ROAD FROM
THE COAST SIDE. GO AHEAD. TO
WITHIN A RADIUS OF WITHIN 100
FOOT. WET A RADIUS OF WETLANDS,
BETWEEN THE SEA AND THE FIRST
PUBLIC ROAD PARALLELING THE SEA.
OR WITHIN 300FT OF THE INLAND,
IN A SENSITIVE COASTAL RESOURCE
AREA. AND IT ALSO AGRICULTURAL
LAND. AND IT HAS TO REFLECT
ALREADY THE LOCALITIES LCP
CORRECT WHICH WHICH WAS APPROVED
BY THE BEEN APPROVED BY THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. RIGHT. SO I
KNOW THIS BILL HAS TO GO TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND THAT
COMMITTEE. SO BACK TO THIS IS
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE. SO OUR
ROLE IS TO ADDRESS HOUSING AND
THE HOUSING SHORTAGES AND THE
NEXT COMMITTEE'S ROLE, OF COURSE
, IS TO IS THE WATCHDOG ON ALL
OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS. SO I'M CONFIDENT
THAT IF THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
THAT I'M MISSING, THAT THAT NEXT
COMMITTEE WILL CATCH THOSE. BUT
I THINK WHEN I THINK ABOUT OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR
JURISDICTION AS THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND WHEN WE KNOW THE
TYPE OF SHORTAGE OF HOUSING THAT
WE HAVE, AND IT'S A SUPPLY
PROBLEM AND THAT WE KNOW
ADDITIONALLY OF THAT SUPPLY
PROBLEM, THE BIGGEST SHORTAGE IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THAT THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW IS WE DON'T
HAVE THAT MANY TOOLS TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BECAUSE IT
NEEDS SUBSIDY. AND THE DENSITY
BONUS TOOL IS THE ABILITY FOR
THE HOUSING DEVELOPER, IN
EFFECT, TO SUBSIDIZE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO WHEN I
LOOK AT IT IN THAT IN ALL THOSE
CONSTRUCTS, IT IS WHY I HAVE A I
RECOMMENDATION ON THE BILL AND
AGAIN, THERE MAY BE SOME ASPECTS
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
THAT, THAT I'VE MISSED. I AM NOT
GOING TO SIT HERE AND SAY THAT,
THAT BECAUSE OUR ANALYSIS WAS
FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON THE HOUSING
SIDE, THOUGH, WE DO ADDRESS, WE
RAISE, YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS OF OPPOSITION AND SUCH
. AND THE NEXT COMMITTEE WILL
DEAL WITH THOSE OTHER CONCERNS,
BUT I WANTED TO MAKE IT CLEAR,
WHY HAVEN'T I SUPPORT ON THE
BILL AND WHY I THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE MORE, I SUPPOSE WHEN I
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF UNITS OF
HOUSING THAT ARE AFFORDABLE IN
ANY AREA THAT IS CONSIDERED
COASTAL ZONE UNDER THE COASTAL
ACT, IT IS, WE KNOW VERY FEW. SO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO THINGS THAT
WOULD ENABLE MORE HOUSING THAT
IS AFFORDABLE WITHIN THAT ZONE
AND IF THE COASTAL COMMISSION,
CLEARLY IT'S IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS ONE. BUT IF IT'S AN
OPPOSITION OF THIS, THEN BEYOND
JUST AN AMENDMENT LIKE TELL ALL
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT DON'T
HAVE LCP YET TO DO LCP, I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE PROACTIVE
ACTION BY THE COASTAL COMMISSION
, BECAUSE IF IT IF WHAT WE ARE
DOING NOW IS ADEQUATE, WE WOULD
HAVE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE. SO LET
ME JUST STATE THAT. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, YOU CAN CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I THINK
YOU'VE SUMMARIZED THE SITUATION
CORRECTLY. THE OPPOSITION SAYS
THAT THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
LAW, IT IS BECAUSE THE PROBLEM
IS UNPRECEDENTED. THE CRISIS IS
REACHED, ALL OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITTEE'S,
ANALYSIS AND YOUR REFLECTION
THAT FROM A HOUSING PERSPECTIVE,
ALL OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PARTICIPATE IN SOLVING THE
HOUSING PROBLEM, THE HOUSING
CRISIS PROBLEM. AND THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE THIS BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY, WE WILL DISCUSS THE,
ASPECTS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES. BUT I WANT ONE TAKEAWAY.
I HOPE, FROM THIS HEARING,
PEOPLE, TAKE THEIR WAS MENTIONED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BLOCK THE
ACCESS TO THE COAST AS A RESULT
OF THIS BILL. IF THE COAST
COMMISSION WAS SO CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT, THEY SHOULD HAVE NOT
APPROVED THE LOCAL COASTAL PLANS
THAT CITIES SUBMITTED TO THEM,
SAYING, WE THINK THAT HOUSING
SHOULD BE BUILT HERE. WHY? WHY
DID THEY APPROVE THEM? BECAUSE,
IN FACT, THOSE PLANS DO NOT
BLOCK FROM COASTAL ACCESS. YOU
WOULD THINK WALKING AWAY FROM
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING ON ROADS
OR, OR PATHWAYS THAT LEAD TO THE
COAST, THAT IS NO ABSOLUTELY
UNTRUE. HOUSING CAN ONLY BE
BUILT WHERE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE
DETERMINED THAT HOUSING SHOULD
BE BUILT. AND BY THE WAY, IT HAS
TO BE MULTIFAMILY HOUSING. WE'RE
NOT EVEN TOUCHING SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSING, WHICH WE KNOW THAT IS
INACCESSIBLE TO THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THE COAST, AND
THAT THEY THOUGHT IT WAS OKAY TO
BUILD HOUSING. AND THE COASTAL
COMMISSION SAID, WE THINK IT'S
OKAY TO BUILD HOUSING THERE AS
WELL. THIS BILL ALLOWS THAT
HOUSING TO ACTUALLY GET BUILT,
TO NOT GET STYMIED, TO NOT GET
DELAYED, AND SOMETIMES,
UNFORTUNATELY, TO NOT STOP
PROJECTS FROM GOING FORWARD,
WHICH ALL ONCE AGAIN REQUIRE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON SITE. SO
WITH THAT, I APPRECIATE YOUR
RECOMMENDATION AND REQUEST YOUR
I VOTE. GREAT. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL? WHO
SAID THEY WOULD? OKAY. SENATOR
MENGIBAR MADE THE MOTION. WE'LL
DO A ROLL CALL. MOTIONS DO PASS
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE. SENATOR SKINNER, A
SKINNER I OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI I
BLAKE SPEAR, BLAKE SPEAR I
CABALLERO. CORTEZ CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I PADILLA
CIERTO UMBERG AND WAHAB. IT'S 5
TO 0. THANK YOU. NOW, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BILL. AND THAT IS ITEM. BACK TO
MY AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB
1886. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AB
1886 IS A BILL THAT WOULD
CLARIFY THAT HCD DETERMINES
WHETHER THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HOUSING ELEMENT IS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE HOUSING ELEMENT LAW,
AND THAT IF A PROJECT IS
SUBMITTED DURING THIS PERIOD OF
NONCOMPLIANCE, IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR THE BUILDER'S REMEDY,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE CITY
REACHES COMPLIANCE BEFORE IT IS
APPROVED. UNTIL RECENTLY, THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY WAS LARGELY
UNUSED AND MANY OF US WERE
PROBABLY UNAWARE OF IT. HOWEVER,
IT'S BEEN A LAW FOR DECADES. IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, WE
HAVE SEEN SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
IN BUILDERS REMEDY PROJECT
APPLICATIONS. DESPITE THE UPTICK
IN PROPOSED PRICE PROJECTS. DUE
TO THE LACK OF CLARITY, MANY
CITIES HAVE USED THE ARGUMENT
THAT SELF-CERTIFYING THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT IS SUFFICIENT
FOR COMPLIANCE PURPOSES. THIS
HAS LED TO MULTITUDE OF
APPLICATIONS NOT BEING PROCESSED
OR OUTRIGHT DENIED, AND VARIOUS
COURT CASES THAT HAVE SLOWED
DOWN HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN
AREAS THAT NEED THE HOUSING,
WHICH IS ALL OF CALIFORNIA AT
ITS CORE, AB 1886 IS A GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL THAT DOESN'T
ESTABLISH A NEW TOOL, BUT IT
CLARIFIES THE EXISTING LAW THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED
DECADES AGO BY CODIFYING THE
SHARED UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HCD AND A
RECENT COURT DECISIONS. AS THE
ANALYSIS IS LAID OUT FOR YOU
TODAY, THE HCD IN FACT
DETERMINES COMPLIANCE OF HOUSING
ELEMENTS, AND AB 1886 PROVIDES
CERTAINTY TO CLEAR UP THIS
AMBIGUITY. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS BILL
WITH YOU, AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MICHAEL LANE FROM THE BAY
AREA, THINK THINK TANK SPUR TO
BE OUR WITNESS. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MICHAEL SPURR
, PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. THE
LEGISLATURE TAKES LOCAL HOUSING
ELEMENTS VERY SERIOUSLY. IN
FACT, IT'S THE ONLY ELEMENT OF
THE GENERAL PLAN THAT MUST BE
CERTIFIED BY THE STATE. THIS IS
BECAUSE THE HOUSING ELEMENT
ENSURES THAT THERE ARE ADEQUATE
SITES TO ACCOMMODATE THE HOUSING
NEEDS OF OUR POPULATION, AS
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND IN ALIGNMENT WITH BOTH HCD
GUIDANCE MEMOS AND COURT CASES,
AB 1886 AFFIRMS THAT ONLY HCD OR
A COURT OF COMPETENT
JURISDICTION CERTIFIES THE
HOUSING ELEMENT TO BE IN
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW. THIS IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASURE TO PROVIDE
CLARITY FOR BOTH DEVELOPERS AND
JURISDICTIONS, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. HAVE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT? JUST COME TO THE MIC
FOR ME. TO RAFA SONNENFELD WITH
THE NBA ACTION AND THE INTEREST
OF BREVITY, I WON'T LIST THE
NEARLY TWO DOZEN, MEMBER
CHAPTERS WHO ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. BOB
NAYLOR, ONE CLIENT FIELDSTEAD
AND COMPANY. THAT'S HOWARD
AHMANSON JR, AN ORANGE COUNTY
PHILANTHROPIST, IN SUPPORT.
ANDREW DODSON, THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
COREY SMITH, HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOINING FROM CALIFORNIA. YIMBY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THOSE OF YOU LEAVING THE
MIC COULD WALK THAT AWAY. YOU'D
STOP THE BLOCKAGE. BUT THAT'S
OKAY. THAT'S A GOOD IDEA. GOOD
IDEA. ALYSSA MAY, SAN FRANCISCO
YIMBY IN SUPPORT. TIFFANY
MILLER, SFHM IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MOIRA TOPP, ON BEHALF OF
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. DIVYA SHIV WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT AND
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
HOLLY DEJESUS WITH LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
CIVIC WELL AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. GRACIELA CASTILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM AND SUPPORT ANGIE
MINETTI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT JARED
MOSS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. SUPPORT
SCOTT, WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL. YOU
CAN COME UP TO THE FRONT IF YOU
LIKE. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BRADY GUERTIN,
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS, ONE OF THE MAIN
CONCERNS WITH THIS MEASURE IS
THAT IT GIVES HCD THE POWER TO
BE THE DETERMINANT OF IF A
HOUSING ELEMENT IS IN COMPLIANCE
OR NOT IN COMPLIANCE. NOW, THE
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL OF OUR CITIES TAKING
YEARS TO GET THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT APPROVED, DESPITE THEIR
BEST EFFORTS, HAS BEEN THAT THEY
HAVE RECEIVED UNCLEAR GUIDANCE
ON THE FINDINGS. IN THESE
EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE A COMPLIANT
HOUSING ELEMENT. NOW, THE
QUESTION THAT WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS, DESPITE CITIES BEST
EFFORTS THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
AND PAST THEIR STATUTORY
DEADLINE TO MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT FOR HOUSING ELEMENT,
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY TO KICK IN,
EVEN IF THEY'RE ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH TO ACHIEVE THE HOUSING
ELEMENT PROCESS OR THEIR CHILD
CERTIFICATION. NOW THE MAIN
CONCERN THAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IS WHAT, INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT WAYS TO FURTHER
CLARIFY AND LOOK AT THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY, WHAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT IN THE STATE IS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
THE PROCESS SO WE CAN GET MORE
CITIES INTO COMPLIANCE TO MAKE
SURE THAT CITIES CAN AVOID
BUILDER'S REMEDY IN THE FRONT
HOLD. AND WE THINK THAT THERE'S
AN APPROACH FORWARD MOVING THAT
WAY. AND WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSING THAT TO
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. AND HAVE
THEY HAVE INFORMED US THEY'RE
NOT LOOKING AT THAT THIS YEAR,
BUT WE ARE HOPING THAT THAT IS A
CONVERSATION IN THE FUTURE,
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL THE BILLS
THAT WE ARE SEEING RELATED TO
HOUSING ELEMENT THIS YEAR. SO
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS. APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE
COMMITTEE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT. I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THOÁT THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION COME TO THE MIC AND
GIVE YOUR ME TO MARK NEUBERGER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION, CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU,
JONATHAN CLAY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ENCINITAS, IN
OPPOSITION. ETHAN NAGLER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
CARLSBAD, CORONA, EASTVALE AND
RANCHO PALOS VERDES, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA. IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSE,
UNLESS AMENDED. ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS, ANY COMMENTS? GO AHEAD.
SENATOR BREAKSPEARE. AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF REPORT POINTS
OUT, IT IT THE BUILDER'S REMEDY
IS, HAS SHIFTED THE POWER
BALANCE. BUT I FROM TO MY
KNOWLEDGE, THERE ARE NO BUILDERS
REMEDY PROJECTS THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN BUILT YET. AND I'M
JUST WONDERING IF YOU HAVE ANY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE WITH THAT,
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE SO FAR
IT'S A THREAT THAT IS WIDELY
FEARED, BUT IT IS ACTUALLY NOT
CREATING ANY HOUSING YET. IT HAS
NOT, WHAT WE HAVE SOME EVIDENCE
OF IS SUBMISSION OF SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS WHICH ARE ARE
MUCH LARGER IN SCALE AND, AND
OFTENTIMES, DON'T FIT WITH LOCAL
LOCALLY APPROVED, PLANNING
DOCUMENTS, AND THEN THEREAFTER
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT, PERHAPS
NEGOTIATIONS TO ACTUALLY BUILD
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROJECTS, BUT
NONE NOT NØ PROJECTS THAT WE
KNOW OF THAT WERE THE ORIGINAL
BUILDERS REMEDY APPLICATION
PROJECT THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT. I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
YEAH. THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
CHAIR, I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THEY'RE ALSO STILL SUBJECT TO
SEQUA. AND SO THERE'S STILL
ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
THAT CAN ALSO BOG DOWN THOSE
TYPES OF PROJECTS. SO WE HAVE
SEEN SOME APPLICATIONS COME
FORWARD. I WOULD SAY THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL BEYOND THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY, JUST TO
CLARIFY THAT HCD OR A COURT OF
COMPETENT JURISDICTION IS THE
ONE WHO CERTIFIES THE HOUSING
ELEMENT. AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
PARTICULARLY I'M FOCUSED ON IN
LA CANADA FLINTRIDGE CASE, THAT
THE AG ACTUALLY INTERVENED ON TO
TRY TO ACTUALLY JUST TO CODIFY
THAT. SO WE'RE ALL CLEAR AND TRY
TO AVOID FUTURE LITIGATION ON
THIS PARTICULAR POINT. YES. NO I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE POINT
OF THE BILL AND I DO SUPPORT IT.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
I UNDERSTOOD WHAT THE LANDSCAPE
WAS, IN CASE THERE WERE PROJECTS
THAT ACTUALLY HAD GONE FORWARD.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR OTOBOKE, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK, I THINK
THE BIGGEST OBSTACLE THAT I HAVE
SEEN ARE ACTUALLY THE POINTS
THAT WERE MADE BY THE OPPOSITION
IN FROM MY, FROM MY CURRENT
DISTRICT, MANY OF THE CITIES
HAVE STATED THAT, MUCH OF THE
PROBLEM, ESPECIALLY ONE THAT I
HAVE THAT IS, PER HOUSING
APPROVED THEIR, THEIR BUILDING.
WONDERFUL. BUT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLES THAT THEY'RE
HAVING IS, JUST GETTING THINGS
THROUGH THE, TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING, AND GETTING THEIR
PROJECTS OR OTHER PROJECTS, BUT
THEIR ELEMENTS APPROVED AND SO I
THINK THAT'S THE ANGLE WHERE I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MOVING
FORWARD, WHERE I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE LEGISLATION ACTUALLY CLARIFY
AND REST IN THE GOVERNOR, TO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT HAVE MORE
CLEAR STANDARDS AS TO HOW THEY
NAVIGATE. AND JUST A STANDARD
PROCESS OF REVIEW, I THINK, IS
WHAT WE ACTUALLY NEED, IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN, RATHER THAN GOING
FROM THIS ANGLE. SO, TODAY I
WON'T BE SUPPORTING THE YOUR
BILL TODAY, BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE SOMETHING ON THAT FRONT TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO HAVE A
STANDARD. STANDARD PROCEDURE FOR
REVIEW BECAUSE THE GOALPOSTS
HAVE BEEN CHANGING QUITE A BIT
FOR, DEPENDING ON WHO'S DOING
THE REVIEW, AND SO THE CITIES I
HAVE A CITY WHO IS LITERALLY HAS
GONE THROUGH SO MANY DIFFERENT.
REVIEWERS, I GUESS YOU COULD
SAY, AND THEY ARE NOT THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO GET FURTHER ALONG
BECAUSE EACH ONE IS SO
SUBJECTIVE AS TO WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO OR NOT DO. SO I THINK, IN
THE FUTURE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MORE OF A STANDARD PROCESS TO,
TO, TO BE IMPLEMENTED RATHER
THAN GOING FROM THIS ROUTE. SO
TODAY I'M NOT GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL, BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT YOU CAN
DO NEXT YEAR WITH REGARDS TO
DEVELOPING A STANDARD PROCESS OF
REVIEW. YEAH. AND IF I MAY,
MADAM CHAIR, AND REPLY, YOU
KNOW, WHEN WE HAVE OPPOSITION
THAT IS WORKING ON, TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH GOALS THAT ARE
REALISTIC AND ACHIEVABLE, THAT'S
CERTAINLY MY APPROACH. ALWAYS IN
THIS CASE, THIS WAS A QUESTION
THAT, CAME UP IN OUR, IN OUR
HOUSE AS WELL, A LOT OF US COME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. SO WE
WE'VE HAD EXPERIENCES WITH
HOUSING ELEMENT, SO WHAT I ASKED
WAS HCD TO PROVIDE US WITH WHAT
THE PROCESS IS. AND SO,
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
NOT HERE TO TALK ABOUT HOW THAT
PROCESS WORKS. SO IT'S BEEN HARD
TO REALLY GET THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
BUT WHAT I DO HAVE IS THE, THE
TIMELINE AND HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS BACK AND FORTH. YOU ARE
POINTING OUT A NEW SONG, A, A
UNIQUE ASPECT WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
RAISED, WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND WE SHOULD PROBABLY
ADDRESS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
SAID TO THE OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT ADDRESSING
THAT. SO LET'S WORK ON THAT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CODIFYING
EXISTING LAW, BUT YOU BRING UP A
UNIQUE POSITION, A UNIQUE POINT,
WHICH IS THE AMBIGUITY PERHAPS
FROM REVIEWER TO REVIEWER. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT FEEDBACK. I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
INTERESTED IN HELPING ADDRESS.
AND AGAIN, IN A DIFFERENT, VIA
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE, WE SHOULD
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
WE'RE ENSURING THAT THE STATE IS
SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS IN A WAY
THAT THEY CAN REACH FINALITY,
WHICH IS TO HAVE AN ADOPTED
HOUSING ELEMENT, AS OPPOSED TO
THIS AMBIGUITY THAT EXISTS.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD HOPE
TO JUST AVOID ENTIRELY IN THE
STATE. SO THANK YOU. OKAY,
CERTAINLY I ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON THIS. I'LL MOVE. OKAY,
SENATOR BLAKESBURG IS MOVED,
AND, I JUST WANT, IN MY READING
OF THE BILL AND ALSO THE
ANALYSIS, I DO NOT SEE THIS, PER
SE, AS ELIMINATING THE ABILITY
OF A CITY TO SELF, CERTIFY.
CERTIFY BECAUSE IT NEVER REALLY
HAD THAT RIGHT. LEGALLY. THE
CITY NEVER HAD THE RIGHT TO SELF
CERTIFY THE CITY HAD THE ABILITY
TO SAY, WE HAVE WRITTEN OUR
HOUSING ELEMENT AND WE'VE
SUBMITTED IT. AND I CAN
CERTAINLY SEE WHY MANY CITIES
MAY HAVE FEEL THEY HAD THE RIGHT
BECAUSE THERE WERE YEARS. I
MEAN, THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT HAS BEEN IN STATUTE FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS, BUT THERE WERE
YEARS WHERE THE, THE STATE
ITSELF DID NOT ENFORCE THE HRA
AND DID NOT, TAKE THE STEPS TO
REALLY REVIEW HOUSING ELEMENTS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE IN
COMPLIANCE AND THEN, GIVE THEIR
STAMP OF APPROVAL. SO I CAN
CERTAINLY SEE WHY THEY THAT
LOCALITIES MAY THINK THAT, THAT
THIS IS SOMEHOW CHANGING THE
RULES, WHEN IN FACT I SEE THIS
BILL AS JUST AFFIRMING THAT
WHICH IS REALLY IN STATUTE. SO I
WANTED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
AND, OF COURSE, I'VE AND I VOTE
ON THE BILL AND WE CAN DO A ROLL
CALL. OR DID YOU CLOSE? DID I
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY? NO.
THAT'S OKAY. THAT'S EXACTLY THE
INTENT. I APPRECIATE YOU
RESTATING THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. ROLL CALL MOTION IS
TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SENATOR SKINNER BY
SKINNER, I OKOBOJI. NO OKOBOJI.
NO. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER,
I CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I PADILLA.
PADILLA. I CIERTO. BURKE. WAHAB
IT'S 5 TO 1. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
KEEP IT ON CALL. THANK YOU. AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WIX, SHE HAS Þ. YOU HAVE A FEW
FOR US, WE'LL START, WHICH I'M
OKAY WITH YOU STARTING OUT OF
ORDER, BUT IF YOU'RE GOING IN
THE ORDER, JUST LET ME KNOW. CAN
I DO 1893 FIRST? YES. YOU CAN.
THAT IS THE ORDER. SO WE WILL
START WITH LOOK AT ME STARTING
ITEM SEVEN WHICH IS AB 1893 WILL
FOLLOW THAT WITH ITEM EIGHT AB
2243 AND FOLLOW THAT WITH ITEM
NINE AB 2580. GO AHEAD WITH
1893. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR, AND
MY SENATOR, WHOM I ADORE, ALL OF
YOU AS WELL, BUT PARTICULARLY MY
SENATOR. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
1893 A BILL TO MODERNIZE THE
BUILDERS REMEDY, WHICH WE JUST
SPOKE ABOUT. AND YOU ASKED SOME
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS. I'M EAGER
TO DIVE INTO THOSE AS WELL.
FIRST, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. AND I'M ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY.
LET ME START OFF BY DESCRIBING
WHAT THE BUILDERS REMEDY IS, AND
THEN I CAN SHARE WHY IT NEEDS
MODERNIZING AND THEN I'LL FINISH
WITH A DESCRIPTION OF HOW WE ARE
PLANNING ON MODERNIZING THAT.
THE BUILDERS REMEDY IS PART OF
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW THAT SAYS IF
A CITY OR COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE A
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENT, THE
CITY OR COUNTY CANNOT DENY A
HOUSING PROJECT JUST BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT COMPLY WITH THE LOCAL
GENERAL PLAN OR ZONING. THAT'S A
LOT OF KNOTS. SO LET ME SAY THIS
MORE SUCCINCTLY. IN A
JURISDICTION WITHOUT A COMPLIANT
HOUSING ELEMENT, THE BUILDERS
REMEDY ALLOWS A DEVELOPER TO
PROPOSE A PROJECT THAT CAN BE OF
ANY SIZE, ANYWHERE IN THE
JURISDICTION. THE GOAL IS TO
COMPEL CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
COMPLETE THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT.
THAT IS THE GOAL OF BUILDERS
REMEDY. WHY IS THIS GOAL? WELL,
BECAUSE WE HAVE A MASSIVE
HOUSING CRISIS, AND THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE CLIMBING OUT OF IT IS IF
EVERY CITY, EVERY COMMUNITY DOES
THEIR PART AND BUILDS THE
HOUSING THAT WE NEED BY
ADOPTING, ADOPTING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE HOUSING ELEMENT
IS HOW EXACTLY WE DO THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY, 1 IN 3
JURISDICTIONS ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW. THOSE JURISDICTIONS ARE
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT SOLVING
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT THEIR
PROBLEM. IT'S THEIR NEIGHBORS OR
SOMEONE ELSE. THEORETICALLY,
THIS WOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM
BECAUSE IN A NON-COMPLIANT CITY
OR COUNTY, WE'D BE SEEING LOTS
OF BUILDERS REMEDY PROJECTS THAT
RESULT IN LOTS OF HOUSING. SO
THAT IGNORING STATE LAW DOES NOT
MEAN AN END TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION. UNFORTUNATELY, AS
NOTED IN THE LAST, BILL THAT WAS
PRESENTED, THE BUILDERS REMEDY
HAS NOT FUNCTIONED THAT WAY.
YES, THERE ARE NOW AT LEAST 100
BUILDERS REMEDIES PROJECTS
PROPOSED IN THE STATE, AND WE
HAVE APPRECIATED THE EFFORTS OF
THOSE DEVELOPERS TO GET HOUSING
BUILT IN THOSE RECALCITRANT
DISTRICTS OR JURISDICTIONS. BUT
WE'VE OBSERVED THAT THOSE
PROJECTS HAVE A HARD TIME
GETTING THE FINISH LINE, BECAUSE
THE LAW INCLUDES ENOUGH
AMBIGUITY THAT MAKE THE PROJECTS
DIFFICULT TO PROCESS AND EASY TO
DELAY. SO TO DATE, AS FAR AS I
KNOW, NO BUILDERS REMEDY
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY
BUILT. THE RISKINESS IS ALSO A
TURN OFF TO TURN OFF A LOT OF
DEVELOPERS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
LIKE TO BUILD IN THESE CITIES.
THE LAW ALSO INCLUDES AN
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT OF 20,
WHICH SOUNDS LOFTY, BUT ACTUALLY
MAKES MOST HOUSING PROJECTS
ECONOMICALLY INFEASIBLE. THE
RESULT IS THAT THE CURRENT
BUILDERS REMEDY ISN'T ENOUGH OF
A CREDIBLE THREAT TO GET NEARLY
100 JURISDICTIONS INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE LAW,
WHICH IS WHY WE NEED TO
MODERNIZE THE LAW. WORKING WITH
OUR SPONSORS, ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROB BONTA, WE HAVE CRAFTED A
BILL THAT REMOVES ANY AMBIGUITY
ABOUT WHERE THE BUILDERS
REMEDIES, WHERE BUILDERS REMEDY
WOULD APPLY, HOW MUCH DENSITY
WOULD BE ALLOWED, AND WHAT
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS WOULD APPLY.
IT ALSO ENHANCES FEASIBILITY BY
REDUCING THE AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS, SOMETHING THAT
DOES NOT RENDER PROJECTS
INFEASIBLE. THE AIM IS TO CREATE
A SELF-ENFORCING MECHANISM THAT
FACILITATES A SUSTAINABLE AMOUNT
OF HOUSING IN THOSE CITIES THAT
HAVE NOT COMPLIED WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW. NOW, THIS BILL IS
NOT WITHOUT CONTROVERSY. I
RECOGNIZE, AND I WANT TO
PROACTIVELY SPEAK TO SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD. ONE CONCERN RAISED BY
SOME OF OUR YIMBY ALLIES AND
YIMBY FAMILY, OF WHICH I
CONSIDER MYSELF, IS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD NOT FUNCTION AS WELL
AS THE EXISTING BUILDERS REMEDY,
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY FLAG
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN BUILDERS
REMEDY PROJECTS DEVELOPED. WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF LAWSUITS, BUT THAT
HAS NOT RESULTED IN A LOT OF
ACTUALLY UNITS BEING BUILT,
WHICH MEANS ROOFS OVER PEOPLE'S
HEADS, ROOFS OVER FAMILIES,
HEADS. ANOTHER CONCERN IS THAT
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS IN THE
EQUITY COMMUNITY, WHO HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT REDUCING
THE AFFORDABILITY LEVELS IN THE
BILL, OUR RESPONSE TO THEM IS
THAT WHILE WE KNOW THAT HAVING A
HIGH AFFORDABLE AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENT FEELS GOOD, THE GOAL
IS TO ACTUALLY GET HOUSING
BUILT. AND IF YOU HAVE TOO HIGH
OF AN INCLUSIONARY ZONE, IT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
PROJECTS TO PENCIL. WHILE SOME
PROJECTS ARE ABLE TO MAKE THE
20% AFFORDABLE, MOST AREN'T EVEN
IN VERY STRONG ECONOMIES. IN SAN
FRANCISCO RECENTLY REDUCED THEIR
INCLUSIONARY FROM 20% DOWN TO
12. AND THAT IS A MARKET THAT
WILL PAY A LOT OF MONEY FOR
HOUSING. A MORE REALISTIC
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT MEANS
MORE BUILDERS REMEDY PROJECTS
ARE FEASIBLE, WHICH MEANS MORE
CITIES WILL COMPLETE THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT. AND SPEAKING OF
THE CITIES, WE APPRECIATE THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES IS NOT TRYING
TO DEFEND CITIES THAT DO NOT
COMPLY WITH THE STATE LAW. IN
FACT, THEIR MAIN CONCERN TO DATE
HAS BEEN THAT HOUSING ELEMENT
PROCESS CAN MAKE IT TOO HARD FOR
GOOD ACTORS FOR CITIES TO GET
APPROVED. I AGREE WITH THAT
POSITION, AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT YOU ARE RAISING, AND I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM ON THAT
ISSUE. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS SPECIFIC BILL.
AND IN FACT, MAY WARRANT ANOTHER
BILL IN THE FUTURE, WHICH I'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK ON. ANOTHER ISSUE
THEY HAVE RAISED IS THAT
RECENTLY AMENDED VERSIONS OF THE
BILL INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT
PROHIBIT A CITY FROM EFFECTIVELY
DENYING A PROJECT WHICH IS WHICH
IS BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY SIT ON A PROJECT FOR TOO
LONG, OR PUT IT THROUGH SO MANY
PROCESSES THAT THEY'RE GETTING
TO KNOW WITHOUT ACTUALLY HAVING
A NO VOTE. WE HAVE A WHOLE
SELECT COMMITTEE. WE HAD A FOUR
HOUR HEARING ON THIS THIS
MORNING, DISCUSSING THE VARIOUS
PERMITTING REFORM NEEDS THAT WE
NEED TO TACKLE. SO THAT BEING
SAID, WE AGREE THAT WE DIDN'T
LAND THE LANGUAGE IN THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THIS BILL, AND IT
COULD BE SEEN AS CREATING MORE
UNCERTAINTY AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE FOCUSED ON DECREASING
UNCERTAINTY. AS SUCH, I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEAGUE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT. IN CONCLUSION, I
REITERATE WHAT I SAID BEFORE WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS. I THINK THAT'S WHY ALL
OF YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE TO DO
SO, THAT REQUIRES 100% OF OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES DO THEIR
PART BY HAVING A COMPLIANT
HOUSING ELEMENT. BUT IF YOU
REFUSE TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW,
THERE SHOULD BE A CONSEQUENCE.
AND I CAN THINK OF NO BETTER
CONSEQUENCE THAN HOUSING IN THAT
COMMUNITY. OUR GOAL HERE IS THAT
HOUSING IS THAT BUILDER'S REMEDY
NEVER GETS USED. IT'LL NEVER GET
USED BECAUSE CITIES WILL
ACTUALLY COMPLY WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT. BUT IF IT DOES, WE WANT
TO HAVE A CLEAN LEGAL RATIONALE
FOR HOW BUILDERS REMEDY IS USED.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE BILL,
OUR JANET SANFORD, REPRESENTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AND
FRANCES MARTY, SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF STRATEGY AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT CALIFORNIA YIMBY,
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY ALEX FISCH,
SPECIAL ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WHO CAN HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. WE HAVE
FIVE MINUTES TOTAL FOR THE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. YOU CAN YOU
CAN SHARE IT. SO PROCEED.
HOWEVER YOU CHOOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JANICE STANFORD. I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROB BONTA, I WANT TO START BY
THANKING ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS
FOR AUTHORING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND FOR HER
LEADERSHIP, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY HAS BEEN ON THE
BOOKS SINCE 1990. IT WAS
INTENDED TO SERVE AS A
COMPLIANCE TOOL TO ENCOURAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENTS, AND TO PROVIDE
A PATH FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT,
EVEN WHEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FAIL
TO DO SO. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
LACK OF CLARITY AND THE EXISTING
BUILDER'S REMEDY STATUTE HAS LED
TO LOCAL DISPUTES AND
LITIGATION, WHICH IS DELAYING
HOUSING PROJECTS. AB 1893 WOULD
CLARIFY THE BUILDERS REMEDY AND
BRING IT INTO THE 21ST CENTURY.
A LOT HAS HAPPENED SINCE 1990.
THIS BILL WOULD ALIGN THE
BUILDERS REMEDY WITH A PLETHORA
OF OTHER STATE LAWS THAT HAVE
BEEN PASSED SINCE THE BUILDERS
REMEDY WENT ON THE BOOKS, 30
PLUS YEARS AGO, LIKE AB 2011, SB
35 AND 423 AND RECENT REVISIONS
TO THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT AND DENSITY BONUS LAW. THE
BILL ALSO ALIGNS THE BUILDERS
REMEDY WITH OTHER STATE
PRIORITIES THAT HAVE EMERGED
SINCE THE BILL. THIS REMEDY WAS
ADOPTED LIKE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES, PROMOTING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND URBAN
INFILL AND NEAR TRANSIT CENTERS,
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
CONSIDERATIONS LIKE KEEPING
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING AWAY FROM
HEAVY INDUSTRIAL USE. WE WANT
CITIES TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE,
BUT IF THEY WANT THE BUILDERS,
REMEDY SHOULD PROMOTE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN PLACES WHERE IT
MAKES SENSE. MODERN DAY
STANDARDS. AB 1893 WOULD ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY HAS SPIRALED OUT
OF CONTROL. HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND
AND AFFORD HOUSING. WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE AND MIXED INCOME
HOUSING TO BE BUILT, AND WE ALSO
NEED MANY MORE SMALLER PROJECTS
TO BE BUILT, LIKE TOWNHOMES,
WHICH TEND TO HAVE LOWER PRICE
POINTS THAN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
AB 1893 WOULD MAKE THE BUILDERS
REMEDY WORK BETTER, PROVIDE
CLARITY FOR DEVELOPERS, CITY
PLANNERS AND COURTS, AND UNLOCK
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
BUILD HOUSING TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR SKINNER
AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA MARTIN AND I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA YIMBY, AN
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ENSURING ABUNDANT, SECURE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
AB 1893, AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS, WHICH AIMS TO
MODERNIZE AND STRENGTHEN THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY. THE BUILDERS
REMEDY IS A CRITICAL TOOL FOR
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. WHEN FAILS
, WHEN CITIES FAIL TO ADOPT
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENTS.
HOWEVER, AS WAS DESCRIBED
EARLIER, AMBIGUITIES IN THE
CURRENT LAW HAVE HINDERED ITS
EFFECTIVENESS, RESULTING IN
CONFUSION, DELAYS, AND
LITIGATION. INSTEAD OF THAT MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING PRODUCTION, AB
1893 ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES BY
PROVIDING CLEAR, OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS FOR THE BUILDERS
REMEDY. THE BILL DEFINES THE
CRITERIA FOR QUALIFYING
PROJECTS, ESTABLISHES ALLOWABLE
DENSITIES AND LOCATIONS, AND
ENSURES THAT LOCAL STANDARDS DO
NOT PRECLUDE ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE DEVELOPMENT BY
MODERNIZING THE BUILDERS. REMEDY
AB 1893 WILL PROVIDE CERTAINTY
FOR DEVELOPERS, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND COURTS. IT WILL
ENCOURAGE MORE HOUSING PROJECTS,
ESPECIALLY BY SMALLER BUILDERS,
WHILE GIVING CITIES CLEAR LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS IN THE APPROVAL
PROCESS. AB 1893 MAKES THE
CRITICAL REFORMS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO ENABLE THE BUILDERS
REMEDY TO FULFILL ITS ORIGINAL
PURPOSE, WHICH WAS TO
INCENTIVIZE LOCALITIES TO COMPLY
WITH STATE HOUSING LAWS, WHILE
ALSO CREATING A CLEAR,
ACTIONABLE PATHWAYS FOR
DEVELOPMENT. WHEN CITIES FAIL TO
MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS. WE
BELIEVE THAT AB 1893 WILL UNLOCK
THE POTENTIAL OF THE BUILDERS
REMEDY, LEADING TO A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN HOUSING PRODUCTION.
THAT'S WHY, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY, I URGE YOU TO
VOTE AYE ON AB 1893. LET'S WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
THAT WELCOMES EVERYBODY WHERE
EVERY PERSON HAS THE CHANCE TO
LIVE IN A THRIVING COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS WHO
WANT TO BE THE METOOS COME TO
THE MIC. GOOD AFTERNOON, NINA
HARWELL, AARP CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. GREAT IF YOU WANT TO
EXIT THAT WAY. THANK YOU, BOB,
FOR FIELDSTEAD IN SUPPORT. COREY
SMITH WITH THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. FOR
MEETING WITH THE LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
BUILD CASA SPUR AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY, CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT
. HELLO. GRACIELA CASTILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SILVIO FERRARI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
IN SUPPORT. HI, ANGIE MINETTI,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, SUSAN
MEDINA. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS
AND SUPPORT. I THINK FOR OUR
OPPOSITION. SO LEAD OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE. OKAY?
YEAH. COME OVER. TIME AND YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES BETWEEN. YOU
ALSO. OKAY. I'LL GO FIRST. HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M MICHELLE PARISET
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES. AND HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE 26 POLICY
HOUSING, LEGAL AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS, WE JOINED IN COMMENTS ON
OUR LETTER DATED JUNE 12TH. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR ENGAGING WITH US, AND
I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THAT
ENGAGEMENT WHILE WE SHARE THE
AUTHOR'S INTERESTS IN ENSURING
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ADOPT
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENTS, WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
1893, UNLESS AMENDED, TO ADDRESS
A NUMBER OF CONCERNS. FIRST, THE
LONG STANDING 20% AFFORDABILITY
CONTRIBUTION FOR BUILDERS REMEDY
PROJECTS SHOULD BE RESTORED.
THESE PROJECTS ARE ENTITLED TO
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS THAT ADD
VALUE THAT FAR OUTSTRIPS THAT
AVAILABLE UNDER STATE AND LOCAL
TOOLS DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE THE
INCLUSION OF AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
ALL HOUSING PROJECTS THAT VALUE
SHOULD BE USED TO DELIVER
DESPERATELY NEEDED UNITS FOR
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES. WHILE THE
BUILDERS REMEDY HAS SERVED AS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL TO ENSURE
APPROVAL OF NUMEROUS 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
EMERGENCY SHELTERS OVER THE
YEARS AS IT WAS INTENDED TO DO,
IT HAS RECENTLY STARTED TO BE
USED BY MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS,
PROPOSING PROJECTS IN
NON-COMPLIANT JURISDICTIONS. IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, AT A
TIME WHEN HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IS
NATURALLY SLOWING DUE TO
UNFAVORABLE ECONOMIC CONDITIONS,
THE STATE HAS SEEN WELL OVER
20,000 UNITS OF HOUSING, 20% OF
THEM AFFORDABLE PROPOSED AND
MIXED INCOME PROJECTS. USING THE
BUILDERS REMEDY, THIS
SIGNIFICANT RISE IN USE SHOULD
SIGNAL THAT THE AFFORDABILITY
CONTRIBUTION IS NOT A BARRIER TO
ITS USE. DURING THE FIFTH
HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE, HCD
PROJECTED THAT THE STATE NEEDED
TO PRODUCE 486,000 UNITS OF
ABOVE MODERATE INCOME OR MARKET
RATE HOUSING. IN THE END, CITIES
AND COUNTIES ISSUED BUILDING
PERMITS FOR OVER 727,000 UNITS
OF MARKET RATE HOUSING. IN OTHER
WORDS, THE STATE MET 150% OF ITS
RINA GOAL FOR MARKET RATE
HOUSING. IN CONTRAST, IT MET
JUST 34% OF THE GOAL FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND 22% OF THE
GOAL FOR VERY LOW INCOME HOUSING
. THE GOAL OF STATE HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW IS TO ENSURE THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
PRODUCING HOUSING FOR PEOPLE AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS AND MEETING
COMMUNITY NEEDS. THESE NUMBERS
CLEARLY ILLUSTRATE WHAT WHICH
NEEDS ARE BEING MET AND WHICH
ARE NOT. THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO
WEAKEN A TOOL THAT IS HELPING TO
ADDRESS THE SIGNIFICANT
IMBALANCE IN HOUSING PRODUCTION
FOR THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS. SIMILARLY, AB 1893
INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT WEAKENS
LOCAL INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS, ALLOWS DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD AT LOWER DENSITIES THAN
A JURISDICTION HAS ZONED FOR. AT
A TIME WHEN WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENCOURAGE
DENSE DEVELOPMENT. AS ONE
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND IT ALLOWS ALREADY
PROPOSED PROJECTS TO REDUCE
THEIR AFFORDABILITY
CONTRIBUTION. THESE CHANGES
REDUCE THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
BUILDERS REMEDY TO DELIVER
HOUSING OVERALL AND PARTICULARLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THIS IS THE
WRONG DIRECTION OUR ORGANIZATION
, ALONG WITH THE DOZENS THAT
SIGNED OUR LETTER, ARE HARD AT
WORK THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE SURE ALL CITIES AND
COUNTIES TAKE SERIOUSLY THEIR
OBLIGATION TO ADOPT A HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT COMPLIES WITH STATE
LAW AND FULFILLS THEIR LEGAL
DUTY TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER
FAIR HOUSING, WHILE SUPPORTING
EFFORTS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS, WEAKENING THE
AFFORDABLE K¾T STANDARD,
UNDERMINING LOCAL INCLUSIONARY
REQUIREMENTS, AND ALLOWING
REDUCED DENSITY RAN COUNTER TO
THESE OBJECTIVES. THANK YOU, AND
WE HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER OUR
AMENDMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M RAFA
SONNENFELD, POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
YIMBY LAW AND NIMBY ACTION,
YIMBY LAW AND YIMBY ACTION
ORGANIZED OVER 24,000 GRASSROOTS
VOLUNTEERS TO SUPPORT HOUSING
PROJECTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
TOGETHER, BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE WEIGHED IN ON 266 HOUSING
PROJECTS IN 2023 AND 2024 ALONE.
YIMBY LAW ALSO SUES CITIES WHEN
THEY FALL, FAIL TO APPROVE
HOUSING. WE FILED 19 LAWSUITS IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE 2019. YIMBY LAW
HAS A DATABASE OF BUILDERS
REMEDY PROJECTS, WHICH, AS FAR
AS WE KNOW, IS THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE IN THE STATE AND
CONTAINS OVER 160 PROJECTS IN
SOME STAGE OF THE ENTITLEMENT
PROCESS. TOGETHER, YIMBY ACTION
AND NIMBY LAW ARE OPPOSED TO AB
1893, UNLESS AMENDED BECAUSE IT
WILL RESULT IN SIGNIFICANTLY
FEWER HOMES COMPARED TO THE
CURRENT BUILDERS REMEDY, AND
WILL NOT REDUCE UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. BILL
ADVOCATES ARGUE THE TRADE OFF
WILL RESULT IN MORE HOUSING
ACROSS, BECAUSE THE PROJECTS
WILL BE HARDER FOR CITIES TO
DISAPPROVE. HOWEVER, WE HAVE
FOUND THAT MAJOR BARRIERS TO
DEVELOPMENT USING THE BUILDERS
REMEDY ARE ARE QUESTIONS SUCH AS
WHETHER A CITY HAS A COMPLIANT
HOUSING ELEMENT, WHICH ARE
ADDRESSED BY REFORMS SUCH AS AB
1886, WHICH WE HEARD EARLIER
TODAY, OR WHETHER OR NOT AN
APPLICATION IS COMPLETE. IN A
STATED ATTEMPT AT REDUCING
UNCERTAINTY, AB 1893 ALLOWS
DEVELOPERS TO APPLY ZONING FROM
THE CLOSEST NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
PERMITS THE DENSITY PROPOSED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT. UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS DRAG AND DROP ZONING WILL
INCREASE UNCERTAINTY THAT
PROJECTS WILL BE APPROVED
BECAUSE IT WILL CAUSE MORE
CONFLICT AND DISAGREEMENT OVER
WHETHER OR NOT DEVELOPERS HAVE
COMPLETE APPLICATIONS. THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM ALSO LIMITS THE
OVERALL SIZE OF BUILDERS REMEDY
PROJECTS AND REQUIRES A LOWER
PERCENTAGE OF PRICE CONTROLLED
HOMES. THIS MEANS FEWER HOMES
OVERALL AND FEWER SUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOMES. WE PROPOSED A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS TO AB 1893
THAT WOULD AVOID AN INCREASED
UNCERTAINTY AND NOT PLACE LIMITS
ON THE POTENTIAL SIZE OF
BUILDERS REMEDY PROJECTS, WE
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO
ON AB 1893, UNLESS AMENDED, TO
ENSURE THE 160 BUILDERS REMEDY
PROJECTS ALREADY IN THE PIPELINE
CAN GO THROUGH, EVEN IF THEY
HAVEN'T YET SUBMITTED A FORMAL
APPLICATION, AND THAT FUTURE
BUILDERS REMEDY PROJECTS CAN
MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
UNNECESSARY, UNNECESSARY
UNCERTAINTY AND DELAY. IN
CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE HOUSING
SHORTAGE, WE CAN'T AFFORD TO ADD
MORE BARRIERS TO BUILDING HOMES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GREAT THOSE
OF YOU WHO WANT TO ADD ON, YOU
CAN COME UP TO THE MIC. ETHAN
AGUILAR, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF RANCHO PALOS VERDES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS BRADY.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU. BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL HOUSING
LAW PROJECT, THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT, CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, AND
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
RURAL HOUSING OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED, ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE TWO
TESTIFIERS. NHIÀU. TH¤U ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER LAW AND
POVERTY, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. CHRIS LEE, ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA,
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION BUT
HAVE REQUESTED AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE COUNTY'S CONCERNS.
THANKS JENNIFER DODD OF
COMMUNITIES FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATOR. HOPE TO BE
ON THE OTHER LINE. BARRY COUNCIL
DOESN'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL, BUT WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
OUR AMENDMENTS, AND WE HOPE TO
BE THERE IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
SO THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. YES. THANK YOU, SO I
WAS LISTENING CLOSELY TO THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS, AND I TO
ME, THIS SEEMS LIKE ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE ARE MANY
POSSIBLE CHANGES THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT BE BETTER ON BALANCE, BUT
THE REALITY OF 160 PROJECTS AND
NONE OF THEM HAVING MADE IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE TO ME,
INDICATES A REAL PROBLEM. SO I
THINK THAT THE DATA THAT I'VE
SEEN SHOWS THAT 20%
AFFORDABILITY AND AN
INCLUSIONARY ORDINANCE IS ALMOST
NEVER SUPPORTABLE, THE MARKET
RATE UNITS CAN'T SUPPORT THAT
THAT LEVEL, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE 50%
OR 80% AFFORDABILITY SO THAT WE
COULD REALLY END UP WITH MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS. I THINK, YOU
KNOW, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, WE
NEED TO HAVE MORE DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE NEED ACTUALLY TRUE PUBLIC
HOUSING SO THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOW INCOME ARE ABLE TO LIVE
INSIDE INSTEAD OF LIVING OUTSIDE
ON THE STREETS. SO IT'S THE MY
PERSONAL FOCUS ON THAT LEADS ME
TO WANT TO HAVE AS MUCH
AFFORDABILITY AS POSSIBLE. BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BILL IS
THAT IT'S 13, WHICH SEEMS LIKE
ABOUT AN AMOUNT THAT COULD BE
SUPPORTED BY THE MARKET RATE
UNITS, AND THEN SOME OTHER
SLIDING AREAS FOR DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES OF LOWER OR VERY LOW,
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME. SO AND THE
AUTHOR COULD CLARIFY THAT IF YOU
WANTED TO. BUT TO ME, IT SEEMS
LIKE WE DO NEED TO MAKE SOME
TWEAKS HERE. AND THE AUTHORS
BILL SEEMS LIKE IT'S LIKELY TO
IMPROVE THINGS. AND SO I'M HAPPY
THAT YOU'RE WORKING IN THIS
SPACE, ESPECIALLY WITH FOLKS WHO
ARE USUALLY FRIENDS AND I'M SURE
WILL BE AFTER THIS, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, FOCUSING ON THE OVERALL
GOAL OF PROVIDING MORE HOUSING
AND MAKING SURE THAT, THAT WE'RE
ALL WORKING TOWARD THAT. OF
COURSE, THERE WILL BE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION, BUT BUT
ULTIMATELY, I AM SUPPORTING THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. IF YOU WANT
TO CLARIFY, YOU CAN, APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS, YES, MADAM CHAIR.
SO YEAH, IT'S, 13% LOW INCOME,
10% VERY LOW INCOME, 7%
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME, AS I
MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, SAN
FRANCISCO JUST RECENTLY REDUCED
THEIR INCLUSIONARY BECAUSE
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIND THE
BALANCE OF LIKE, HOW MUCH CAN
YOU REQUIRE BECAUSE WE NEED THAT
HOUSING. BUT IT ALSO HAS TO
PENCIL OUT. AND THAT'S THE
TRICKY ISSUE. RIGHT. AND WE DID
A LOT OF ANALYSIS WITH UC
BERKELEY'S TERNER CENTER TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT NUMBER
TO LAND ON, SO THAT'S WHY WE
LANDED ON THOSE NUMBERS. WHAT'S
AND WE REALLY TRYING TO MAKE
THIS DATA DRIVEN IN TERMS OF
WHAT CAN ACTUALLY PENCIL OUT SO
THAT BUILDERS REMEDIES ACTUALLY
TRULY A USEFUL TOOL AS OPPOSED
TO SOMETHING THAT JUST GETS
LITIGATED? OKAY. LET ME SEE IF
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. SENATOR I
GET THAT I'M COMING FROM REAL
ESTATE, AND I'M THINKING I GET
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO, TO
ADDRESS. AND I AND I, I ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH BERKELEY. WERE
THERE ANY CONVERSATIONS ON THERE
WITH ADDRESSING THE ACTUAL THE
REASON WHY HOUSING IS SO
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD IN CALIFORNIA
HAS HAS THERE BEEN ANY
CONVERSATIONS ON ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE?
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
IT, THIS IS THESE ARE ALL
BAND-AIDS, RIGHT? BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL NOT ADDRESSING WHY WHY
IT'S SO EXPENSIVE TO BUILD. I
MEAN, I KNOW WHY I HAVE AN IDEA,
BUT WE'RE DATA BASED AND IS, YOU
KNOW, IN SACRAMENTO WHEN IT
COMES TO LEGISLATIVELY. SO THE
CONVERSATION THAT I DON'T SEE
HAPPENING HERE IS WHY DON'T WE
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY THE UNDERLYING FACTORS,
WHY WE CAN'T BUILD AND WHY
BUILDERS CAN'T FIND THAT ABILITY
TO PENCIL OUT THE PROJECTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA? THAT'S
A BIG QUESTION, AND I THINK HAS
A LOT OF COMPONENTS TO IT. I
COULD SPEND ALL DAY TALKING
ABOUT IT, BUT I THINK THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THINGS. AND YOU COULD
TALK ABOUT INTEREST RATES, YOU
COULD TALK ABOUT SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES, YOU COULD TALK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THE FACT THAT WE MADE
IT VERY DIFFICULT TO GET TO.
YES, TO HOUSING, RIGHT? THERE'S
ALL THESE DIFFERENT IMPEDIMENTS
THAT THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY
DESIGNED SO THAT WE DON'T BUILD
HOUSING. WE MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO BUILD MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
SO MANY DIFFERENT COMPONENTS TO
THAT QUESTION. THIS ISN'T GOING
TO SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM, BUT WHAT
OUR GOAL HERE IS TO TRY TO
CREATE A REAL MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THAT CITIES ARE ACTUALLY
COMPLYING, THAT THEY ARE
ADHERING TO THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW. AND YOU RAISED AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION, I THINK, IN
THE IN THE PREVIOUS BILL, AROUND
ENSURING THAT HCD IS DOING THEIR
PART IN THIS. AND I'M HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT TOWARDS
THAT END, BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL, BUT I THINK,
YOU KNOW, AND I'M OBVIOUSLY I'M
NOT. WE HAVE FOLKS HERE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OFFICE WHO
COULD TALK MORE ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WHY THIS DOES NEED TO BE, I
THINK, MORE LEGALLY CONSISTENT
AND MODERNIZED IN A WAY SO THAT
IT IS ACTUALLY A USEFUL TOOL SO
THAT IT'S NOT JUST RESULTING IN
LAWSUITS, BUT IT'S RESULTING IN
HOUSING, WHICH IS WHAT OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL REALLY IS. ALL
RIGHT, SO THIS ONE, ON THE FACE
OF IT, LET'S TAKE OUR DEBATE ON
THE BILL. WE HAD A FEW MINUTES
AGO AROUND, USING THE DENSITY
BONUS IN, A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON DENSITY BONUS
WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE. AND WE,
THE COASTAL COMMISSION, OF
COURSE, OPPOSED THAT BILL. OUR
COMMITTEE ENDED UP, WITH AN I
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OBVIOUSLY, NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE NOT I SHOULDN'T
SAY NOT ONLY WE HAVE A SUPPLY
CRISIS, BUT THE LARGEST SUPPLY
SHORTAGE IS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THE DENSITY BONUS
IS A TOOL TO GET AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SO ON THE FACE OF THAT,
THIS COMMITTEE, GIVEN THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE RECOGNIZE,
SHOULDN'T BE, YOU COULD SAY,
WOULDN'T, BE SUPPORTIVE OF A
PROVISION THAT REDUCES THE
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT.
HOWEVER AS THE AUTHOR HAS
POINTED OUT, AND I THINK ALL OF
US KNOW THE AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENT THAT HAS BEEN IN OUR
, BUILDERS REMEDY TO DATE HAS
NOT RESULTED IN ANY AFFORDABLE
UNITS. IT'S NOT RESULTED IN ANY
UNITS. SO SO, IT'S THE OLD
QUESTION OF IS, SHOULD WE LET
AND I APPRECIATE THAT OUR
OPPOSITION IS NOT THAT THIS MAY
NOT BE AN ANALOGY YOU LIKE, BUT
ARE WE GOING TO LET PERFECT BE
THE ENEMY OF THE GOOD, MEANING
THAT WE THE PERFECT IS LEAVING
IT ON PAPER AS CONSTRUCTED, EVEN
THOUGH IT HASN'T RESULTED IN ANY
UNITS BEING BUILT? OR ARE WE
WILLING TO MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT
THAT MIGHT, RESULT IN AND AGAIN,
THERE'S NO GUARANTEES IN ANY OF
THE STATUTES WE DO, BUT THAT
MIGHT RESULT IN ACTUALLY SOME
UNITS BEING BUILT UNDER BUILDING
BUILDERS REMEDY AND SOME NUMBER
OF THOSE BEING AFFORDABLE. SO
THAT'S THE, THE APPROACH THAT WE
TOOK. THERE WERE, OF COURSE,
THERE'S MORE THINGS IN THIS BILL
THAN JUST THAT PROVISION. BUT
GIVEN THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
PRIMARILY AROUND THAT PROVISION,
THÀNH, I WANTED TO ADDRESS IT.
NOW THE, THIS BILL IS GOING TO
GO TO IF IT PASSES THIS
COMMITTEE, IT WILL GO TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HAS, THE THAT COMMITTEE HAS
LOOKED AT ISSUES LIKE
AFFORDABILITY. BUT WHAT I WANTED
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT IS THAT THE
HOUSING ASPECT OF THIS BILL AND
THE AFFORDABILITY IS THIS
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION. AND IF
THERE IS HAD WE THIS COMMITTEE.
HAD A SOLUTION TO THE YOUR
CONCERNS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
REALLY HURT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. WE WOULD HAVE
RECOMMENDED SOME AMENDMENTS, BUT
WE DIDN'T AND PRIMARILY WE
DIDN'T BECAUSE IN THE HATE
AGAINST HATE, THE OBVIOUS
BECAUSE NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HAS YET BEEN BUILT UNDER THE
BUILDERS REMEDY. NOW IT'S
CONCEIVABLE THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME, WAYS TO HELP ENSURE THAT
WE DO GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING OUT
OF THIS, THAT WE'RE NOT STILL IN
A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE AND IF FOR
SOME REASON IT'S WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL, THAT PERHAPS IT
SHOULD BE RAMPED UP. BUT THE
POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT
WE'RE, WHAT THE CONCLUSION THAT
OUR ANALYSIS CAME TO AND WHY,
WHICH SEEMS PERHAPS CONTRARY TO
OUR OTHER POSITIONS, WHY WE ARE
WE DID NOT ASK FOR AMENDMENTS IN
THAT SECTION. NOT SURE WHAT ELSE
TO SAY ABOUT IT. I PROBABLY, IF
I, WEREN'T DEALING WITH 20 BILLS
ON THE AGENDA, I MIGHT BE MORE,
BUT ANYWAY. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WANT TO
COMMENT TO THIS ONE. SENATOR
CABALLERO, GO AHEAD. MY
APOLOGIES, MADAM CHAIR. NO
WORRIES. ANOTHER, WE'RE ON 1893,
AB 1893 AND WE HAVEN'T TAKEN UP,
2243 YET. NO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE. YEAH, FOR SURE. AND I
APPRECIATE, THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS, I, I SUPPORT WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO ON THIS,
AND SO I WANT TO I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE I HAD THE RIGHT
BILL. OH, OKAY. NOT A WORRY. ALL
RIGHT. I THINK WE WILL LET YOU
CLOSE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WELL, I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION, WOULD LOVE TO WORK
ON THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED HERE. WE'RE TRYING TO
LAND THE PLANE HERE TO MAKE THIS
A USEFUL TOOL. AGAIN. IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ALL THINGS TO ALL
PEOPLE, BUT WE HOPE IT'S GOING
TO BE MOVING THE BALL FORWARD TO
MODERNIZE THIS SO THAT IT'S A
TOOL SO WE CAN ULTIMATELY BUILD
MORE HOUSING, WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO, AND
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL? OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION. LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
OKOBOJI. NO. OKOBOJI NO. BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
MENGIBAR. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
CIERTO. UMBERG. WAHAB. IT'S 4 TO
1. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL HOLD THAT
AND KEEP IT ON CALL. AND WE WILL
GO TO YOUR NEXT BILL, WHICH IS,
AB 2243. WE'LL GO WITH THAT.
HELPED OR NOT? OKAY. HI. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS NUMBERS TWO OF THREE.
AND THEN I WILL BE OUT OF YOUR
HAIR, I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
2243, A BILL TO CLARIFY AND
EXPAND AB 2011. FIRST OF ALL,
THANKS TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS. MADAM
CHAIR, WE ARE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE PROPOSED TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE SUGGESTED.
AB 2011, ALSO KNOWN AS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HIGH
ROADS JOBS ACT OF 2022, WAS A
BILL I AUTHORED IN 2022. IT
ALLOWS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
MULTIFAMILY INFILL HOUSING IN
AREAS ZONED FOR RETAIL, OFFICE
AND PARKING LOTS IN RETURN FOR
MAKING THOSE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS BY RIGHT,
DEVELOPERS NEED TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON SITE AND
ENSURE THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE ARE PAID. THE
PREVAILING WAGE. SINCE THE
ENACTMENT OF AB 2011, THERE HAVE
BEEN SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES TO THE
ECONOMY, INCLUDING THE COLLAPSE
OF COLLAPSE OF DEMAND FOR OFFICE
SPACE, THE REDUCED DEMAND FOR
BRICK AND MORTAR RETAIL, AND AN
INCREASE IN INTEREST RATES.
THOSE CHANGES HAVE CREATED BOTH
DEMAND AND OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN
UP SITES WHERE HOUSING COULD
BECOME MORE ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE. ADDITIONALLY, SINCE AB
2011 ENACTMENT, HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE IDENTIFIED ASPECTS OF THE
LAW'S LANGUAGE THAT ARE
SUBJECTIVE AND OPEN TO
INTERPRETATION. THIS SUBJECT
SUBJECTIVITY HAS LED TO PROJECT
DELAYS AND DISSUADED UTILIZATION
OF THE LAW. IT IS ALSO LED TO
INCONSISTENT APPLICATION ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND CREATED THE
POTENTIAL FOR UNNECESSARY
LAWSUITS. AB 2243 WOULD ADDRESS
BOTH OF THESE ISSUES BY
EXPANDING AB 2011 GEOGRAPHIC
APPLICABILITY AND CLARIFYING
ASPECTS OF THE LAW THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO INTERPRETATION IN
TERMS OF GEOGRAPHIC EXPANSION,
AB 2243 WOULD APPLY AB 2011 TO
THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF PROJECTS.
REGIONAL MALLS THAT EXCEED 20
ACRES IN SIZE. THE CONVERSION OF
OFFICE TO HOUSING EVEN IF THE
SITE IS NOT ALONG A MAJOR
COMMERCIAL CORRIDOR, SITES
WITHIN 500FT OF FREEWAYS AND
3200FT OF OIL EXTRACTIONS. AS
LONG AS THOSE PROJECTS WERE,
USED, REQUIRED AIR FILTRATION
SYSTEMS, AND TO EXISTING HIGH
RISE DISTRICTS, EVEN IF THE SITE
IS NOT ALONG A COMMERCIAL
CORRIDOR IN TERMS OF REMOVING
SUBJECTIVITY, AB 2243 INCLUDES A
SERIES OF CLARIFICATIONS,
INCLUDING CLARIFYING THAT ALL
ASPECTS OF AB 2011 PROJECTS ARE
MINISTERIAL AND NOT SUBJECT TO
SEQUA, AND CLARIFYING HOW AB
2011 INTERSECTS WITH DENSITY
BONUS LAW AND SPECIFICALLY THAT
ANY SITE REMEDIATION NEEDS TO
OCCUR AFTER PROJECT APPROVAL BUT
BEFORE THE SITE CAN BE OCCUPIED.
IMPORTANTLY THE AB 2243 DOESN'T
TOUCH AB 23 LABOR STANDARDS OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STANDARDS,
WHICH IS WHY IT IS STILL
SUPPORTED BY THE AB 2011 DIVERSE
COALITION OF CONSTRUCTION,
LABOR, SEIU, CA, AFFORDABLE AND
MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS AND OTHER
PROCESSING ORGANIZATIONS. I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SINCE
THE BILL PASSED OUT OF ASSEMBLY
ON CONSENT, WE HAVE RECEIVED
OPPOSITION FROM SOME
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL APPLIES AB 2011 TO
SITES NEAR FREEWAYS. I DEEPLY
RESPECT THE HECK OUT OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND WORK WITH
THEM. IN MANY WAYS, I APPRECIATE
WHAT THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR AND I
THINK THEIR THAT WE'RE FULLY
ALIGNED, THAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO
LIVE IN HOUSING THAT IS BOTH
AFFORDABLE AND SAFE. THAT'S WHAT
I'VE TRIED TO DO WITH AB 2011
AND IN THIS BILL, ALLOW THE
HOUSING TO BE PERMITTED QUICKLY
WHILE MAKING SURE THAT LAND
UNDERNEATH THE AREA, THE SORRY,
THE AIR INSIDE ARE CLEAN AND
PARTICULARLY ON THE SETBACKS FOR
FREEWAYS, WHICH I'VE SPOKEN TO
SOME OF YOU ABOUT. AND THIS IS A
REAL ISSUE, ESPECIALLY IN LA,
WHERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
FREEWAYS. WE ALSO WANTED TO
BRING CONFORMITY TO THE
STANDARDS THAT WERE SET FORTH IN
SB FOUR, WHICH I THINK MOST OF
YOU PROBABLY VOTED FOR AND OR
COAUTHORED. AND SO THIS BILL
MIRRORS THOSE STANDARDS ON THOSE
FREEWAY SETBACKS. SINCE THE
OPPOSITION HAS COME IN, WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND AIR QUALITY EXPERTS
AND EVEN MECHANICAL ENGINEERS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR BUILT IN
MITIGATION MEASURES ARE
SUFFICIENT AND IMPLEMENTABLE.
AND, WE WILL CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, HOPEFULLY WITH
SUPPORT FROM COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND I'M COMMITTED TO GETTING IT
RIGHT IN THIS BILL. AB 2011 HAS
ONLY BEEN LAW FOR LESS THAN A
YEAR. DURING THIS PERIOD, HIGH
INTEREST RATES HAVE DAMPENED THE
WHOLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
MARKET, FRANKLY, ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, BUT SPECIFICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHILE WE HAVE
SEEN SOME SUCCESSES WITH AB
2011, I HAVE A BIG PROJECT. THE
SENATOR'S THE CHAIR, AND I DO,
THE NORTH BERKELEY BART PROJECT,
WHICH HAS BEEN YEARS IN THE
MAKING, WHICH IS NOW BEING AB
2011, IS BEING USED. WE'VE GOT
PROJECTS IN SAN FRANCISCO, IN
SAN DIEGO, IN LOS ANGELES, ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. WE'VE ALSO
STARTED TO GET A LOT OF FEEDBACK
ON HOW WE CAN MAKE THE LAW
ACTUALLY BETTER. AND MY GOAL
WITH THIS BILL, IS TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE DOING THAT. YOU
KNOW, I'M, I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE
IN COMMITTEE, I'M SIX YEARS INTO
A 12 YEAR TERM, SO I'M LIKE
LEGISLATIVELY MIDDLE AGED. I'M
ALSO ACTUALLY MIDDLE AGED, BUT
I'M LEGISLATIVELY MIDDLE AGED.
AND WHAT I'VE SORT OF RECOGNIZED
IN MY TENURE HERE IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU DO THESE
BIG BILLS, AND THEN THEY GO OUT
INTO THE WILD AND YOU SEE HOW IT
ACTUALLY WORKS, WHAT'S WORKING,
WHAT'S NOT WORKING, HOW CAN WE
MAKE IT MORE APPLICABLE? SO
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE IN
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED, IS
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
BUILD MORE HOUSING AND WE CAN DO
IT SAFELY. THAT IS WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S A TOOL THAT CAN
BE USEFUL, AS FOLKS ARE TRYING
TO BUILD THE HOUSING THAT THEY
NEED. THAT PROVIDES BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS THAT WE
BELIEVE IN, THE LABOR STANDARDS
THAT WE BELIEVE IN, AND THE
STREAMLINING THAT WE KNOW IS
NECESSARY. SO WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT. AND HERE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS COREY SMITH, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION. AND OUR FRIEND DANNY
CURTIN FROM THE CARPENTERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MEMBER. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE, COREY SMITH. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION OR THE
HAC FOR SHORT. I DIDN'T PICK THE
NAME, WE'RE A HOME BUILDING
INDUSTRY FUNDED NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CREATING MORE
HOMES FOR RESIDENTS AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS, AND A PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB 2243, BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
CREATING MORE HOMES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AND THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THAT. THE PASSAGE OF THE
LANDMARK BILL A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO HAS BEEN CRITICAL IN
EXPEDITING HOUSING ACROSS THE
STATE, AND WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE LOOKED AT IT AND WHO ARE
USING AB 2011 TO CREATE NEW
HOMES. BUT AS MENTIONED, THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO STRENGTHEN
THE BILL AND DELIVER MORE
HOUSING AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. THE CLARIFICATIONS
WILL IMPROVE THE LAW AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN, TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL SITES TO BE DEVELOPED
FOR HOUSING. AND SINCE THOSE
SITES WERE PREVIOUSLY INELIGIBLE
FOR THIS SORT OF STREAMLINING,
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT HAPPEN
AND THEREFORE EXPAND PRODUCTION
THROUGH THE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, ESPECIALLY FOR INFILL
HOUSING LOCATIONS. AND AT THE
TIME SINCE IT WAS ORIGINALLY
PASSED, WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS REACH OUT TO US SAYING
THAT THEY WANT TO USE THE LAW,
BUT IT DIDN'T QUITE FIT EXACTLY.
AND SO THIS BILL EXPANDS THOSE
ELIGIBILITY OPPORTUNITIES. AND
WITH THIS ADDITIONAL SITES ARE
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
STREAMLINING, CLEARING THE WAY
FOR HOUSING IN KEY LOCATIONS
ALONG WITH THEIR AMENITIES.
ADDITIONAL SERVICE, TRANSIT AND
JOBS. AND BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER, THIS BILL
ALSO REDUCES THE PROCESS AND
INCREASES CERTAINTY, WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY DECREASE THE COST OF
BUILDING NEW HOUSING, WHICH IS
REALLY CRITICAL AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT, DANNY
CURTIN, CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS, IN REFERENCE TO YOUR
LAST COMMENT. I'VE BEEN I'M A
LITTLE PAST MY MIDDLE AGE AROUND
HERE, AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THE ARC OF HISTORY TENDS TOWARDS
PROGRESS. SO THAT'S A LONG WAY
OF SAYING WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
THANK YOU ALL FOR ADDRESSING
PROBABLY THE MOST STABLE
HOUSING, SOCIAL, ECONOMIC AND
GROWINGLY POLITICAL PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE FACING, THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. I
WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK THIS
LEGISLATURE, THE GOVERNOR AND
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WICKS, FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS ONLY
ONE SIDE OF THE COIN. THE OTHER
SIDE IS THE WAGE CRISIS IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND SEVERAL OTHERS. BUT
IN THIS ONE IN PARTICULAR, THE
WAGE GAP AND THE GROWING WEALTH
GAP IN CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST WAGE GAP IN THE COUNTRY.
I JUST READ THAT IN ALL PLACES.
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER AND A
COUPLE OF ARTICLES THEY'VE BEEN
HAVING ON HOUSING. ALMOST HALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING WORKERS
ARE CLASSIFIED AS LOW, VERY LOW
OR EXTREMELY LOW INCOME. THAT'S
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS, POVERTY
WAGES, 85% ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
BECAUSE OF THE LOW WAGES IN THE
HOUSING INDUSTRY, WHICH IS
ALMOST HALF THE STATE'S
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE.
CALIFORNIA RANKS 46TH IN THE
COUNTRY FOR CONSTRUCTION WAGES.
THAT'S THE SAME TIME THIS LOW
WAGE WORKFORCE, 160,000
FAMILIES, RECEIVES AN ANNUAL
PUBLIC SUBSIDY OF OVER 3
BILLION, CLOSER TO 4 BILLION.
NOW, I BELIEVE IN SAFETY NET
PAYMENTS DUE TO THE, QUOTE, LOW
WAGE, OFTEN EXPLOITATIVE
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION SECTOR.
THAT'S A UC BERKELEY REPORT FROM
2021, APPROXIMATELY 1 IN 4
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY,
EITHER MISCLASSIFIED OR OFF THE
BOOKS. THAT'S A 2014 REPORT, SO
I'M SURE IT'S SIMILAR. IF NOT
WORSE. ROUGHLY $1 BILLION IN TAX
PAYMENTS IS BEING LOST TO THIS
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY, THE TOTAL
ANNUAL GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY TO THE
WORKERS, TO THE WORKERS OF WORST
ACTORS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IS LITERALLY $5 BILLION
A YEAR. THAT'S GOVERNMENT FUNDS
THAT'S GOING INTO THIS INDUSTRY
TO REALLY, HELP THE WORST ACTORS
PERFORM IN THIS INDUSTRY. IT'S
NOT GOOD WAGE THEFT IN HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION IS DESCRIBED AS
RAMPANT BY THE CALIFORNIA BEALL
BUREAU OF FIELD ENFORCEMENT,
2018 CHANCES OF AN INSPECTION BY
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER IS ONCE
EVERY 300 YEARS. LA TIMES AUDIT
OR REPORTING ABOUT AN AUDIT
RECENTLY. I DO WANT TO THANK
THIS LEGISLATURE AGAIN ON SOME
OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
PASSING TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WAY TO GO IS A PRIVATE SECTOR
LABOR MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY, SELF
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM, WHICH I
THINK WILL PAY DIVIDENDS IN THE
YEARS TO COME. AND SORT OF
LASTLY, CALIFORNIA'S FRIEND, THE
TWO, THE SECOND HIGHEST PERCENT
OF THEIR INCOME ON RENT, SECOND
TO HAWAII, THE MEDIAN HOME IN
CALIFORNIA HAS REACHED $900,000.
A HOUSEHOLD WITH TWO JOBS PAYING
MORE THAN, WHAT, THREE QUARTERS
OF CALIFORNIANS MAKE, WHICH IS
$94,000 A YEAR AT A 75% LEVEL.
TWO JOBS WITH THAT STILL DON'T
QUALIFY FOR A MEDIAN HOME IN
CALIFORNIA, ONLY 16% OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS COULD
AFFORD THE MEDIAN HOME 16.
AGAIN, ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
ARTICLES I JUST WANT TO END WITH
ONE LAST THOUGHT AT HOME IN MY
BLOCK, WHICH SOLD FOR $380,000
IN LATE 2018. SOLD IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR FOR $777,000. MORE
THAN DOUBLED IN FIVE YEARS. THE
PERCENTAGE OF WAGES CONTRIBUTING
TO THAT INCREASE IN VALUE IS
ZERO. IT'S DOUBLED IN FIVE
YEARS. THERE WERE NO WAGES
INVOLVED. WE NEED TO FIX THE
HOUSING CRISIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, ALL OF YOU. THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
FABULOUS. THANK YOU, WE ALSO
NEED TO DEAL WITH THE WAGE
CRISIS. THANK YOU. OKAY. GREAT.
THANK YOU. DAN. ALL RIGHT. THOSE
WHO WANT TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT,
YOU CAN, GET TO THE MIC. BROUGH
FELDMAN WITH THE ACTION AND
SUPPORT. FRANCESC MARTI,
CALIFORNIA GMB IN SUPPORT. BOB
MUELLER FROM FIELDSTEAD AND
COMPANY IN SUPPORT RON ROULETTE
NOR CAL CARPENTERS UNION IN
SUPPORT EUGENE MORRIS CARPENTERS
LOCAL 152 OUT OF STANISLAUS SAN
JOAQUIN, MERCED, MARIPOSA AND
TUOLUMNE COUNTY IN SUPPORT
CHESTER HALEY, NORTH CAL
CARPENTER'S IN SUPPORT. MITCHELL
VINCIGUERRA CARPENTERS LOCAL
2236, IN OAKLAND IN SUPPORT.
NINA HARWELL, AARP CALIFORNIA,
IN SUPPORT. HOLLY FROM
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF SPUR AND THE INNER
CITY LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT
NEVADA. MERRIMAN MID-PEN HOUSING
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MONICA
BROWN, NORTH CAL CARPENTERS
UNION LOCAL 22, IN SUPPORT
ANGELA ADAMS FROM NORTH CAL
CARPENTERS SUPPORT SETH HOWARD
WITH CARPENTERS LOCAL 1789,
SOUTH LAKE TAHOE. WE SUPPORT
ARMANDO MURILLO, CARPENTERS
LOCAL 405, SAN JOSE,
OVERWHELMINGLY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. PALM BAY LAMKINS NORTH CAL
CARPENTERS UNION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HERLINDA ALFARO,
NORCAL CARPENTERS UNION IN
SUPPORT. LIMÓN FRAUSTO, NORCAL
CARPENTERS UNION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CESAR PLASENCIA,
NORCAL CARPENTERS UNION LOCAL
405, SANTA CLARA COUNTY, IN
SUPPORT. GRACIELA CASTILLO
CRANKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, SYLVIO
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE BUILDING
OWNERS AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION.
IN AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS KYLE
SWARNS, A FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
AT 751 IN SANTA ROSA, IN SUPPORT
. GOOD AFTERNOON. ONASSIS
MACFARLANE, NORCAL CARPENTERS
UNION, SOLANO COUNTY, IN SUPPORT
. MATT LASHAY WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. CÁC
MANCINI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT ANGIE
MINETTI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, JOSE MARTINEZ, LOCAL
152, SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. MR. CHAIRMAN SCOTT,
WHICH, ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS, CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL, THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS, THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES,
AND THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
UNION. I AM A TWEENER, WE'VE NOT
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
, BUT I DO WANT TO MENTION I'M
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR, BUT OUR ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY IS, IS THAT IN
2022, THERE WAS A ACCORD THAT
WAS REACHED BY THE LEADERSHIP IN
BOTH HOUSES, WHEREBY THERE WAS
ONE SET OF WORK, WORK FORCE
PROTECTIONS PLACED IN AB 2011
AND A SEPARATE SET OF WORK FORCE
PROTECTIONS PLACED IN SENATOR
CABALLERO'S AB SIX. AB SIX DEALT
WITH COMMERCIAL AND RETAIL
CONVERSIONS. AB 2243 NOW EXPANDS
THE 2011 PROCESS TO APPLY TO
THAT SAME CATEGORY OF PROJECT,
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT IN,
FURTHERANCE OF THE DEAL THAT WAS
REACHED BETWEEN BOTH HOUSES,
THERE NEEDS TO BE WORK FORCE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE MORE
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT WAS IN AB SIX
THAN WHAT WAS IN AB 2011. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AS WE'VE
COMMITTED TO, ON THIS
OUTSTANDING ISSUE. THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONIES.
NOW WE WILL CONTINUE WITH, OUR
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. NØ
. ALL TIMES. OKAY THE WITNESSES
WILL HAVE FIVE MINUTES TOTAL
BETWEEN BOTH OF YOU. YOU CAN
DIVIDE IT AS NEEDED. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS KYLE FARRAR. I'M THE
WESTERN PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT
FRACTRACKER ALLIANCE. EXCUSE ME.
FRACTRACKER ALLIANCE, WHERE I'VE
WORKED CONDUCTING ACADEMIC
RESEARCH ON THE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION OPERATIONS SINCE
2009, I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB 2243, UNLESS
AMENDED, TO KEEP SCL REVIEWS FOR
AREAS PROXIMAL TO HIGHWAYS AND
ALSO PROXIMAL TO OIL AND GAS
WELLS, AS OUTLINED IN STATE BILL
1137, WHICH WAS NOT ADDRESSED. I
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE MY
EXPERTISE ON THE FATE AND
TRANSPORT OF OIL AND GAS
POLLUTANTS FROM THE SOURCES OF
POLLUTION. I'VE SEEN AND
DOCUMENTED FIRSTHAND THE
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS, THE LEAK
FROM OIL AND GAS WELLS. I'VE
INSPECTED HUNDREDS OF WELLS AND
DOCUMENTED MANY DOZENS OF WELL
SITES LEAKING NEAR HOMES AND IN
COMMUNITIES. THE COMPLAINTS I'VE
FILED HAVE RESULTED IN NOTICES
OF VIOLATIONS OR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS FOR THOSE OPERATORS. I
MUST STRESS THESE LEAKS OCCUR
REGULARLY AS A RESULT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT. ON THE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS CORRODED
AND DETERIORATED THEM. THE
LEAKING HYDROCARBONS INCLUDE A
COCKTAIL OF TOXIC AND
CARCINOGENIC CHEMICALS. THE
LITERATURE SHOWS THAT THESE
EMISSIONS CONTRIBUTE TO
INCREASED HEALTH IMPACTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS, INCLUDING LOW
BIRTH WEIGHT AND OTHER NEGATIVE
BIRTH OUTCOMES, ASTHMA
EXACERBATION, CANCER AND
NEURODEGENER DISORDERS. AMENDING
AB 2011 TO EXEMPT DEVELOPMENT
NEAR OIL AND GAS SITES FROM
CYCLE REVIEW IS A MISTAKE FOR
MULTIPLE REASONS. FIRST, VOCS.
VOLATILE ORGANIC COMPOUNDS ARE A
MAJOR RISK DRIVER OF HEALTH
IMPACTS FOR COMMUNITIES LIVING
CLOSER TO OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION
OPERATIONS AND HIGHWAYS. THESE
TOXIC AND CARCINOGENIC CHEMICALS
EXIST AS VAPORS IN A GAS AND A
GASEOUS STATE. THESE POLLUTANTS
CAN NOT BE CAPTURED BY THE
PROPOSED MERV 13 FILTERS, OR
EVEN MORE PROTECTIVE HEPA
FILTERS. THESE PROPOSED FILTERS
ARE INSUFFICIENT TO MITIGATE
RISK FROM THESE SOURCES OF
POLLUTION. MERV 13 FILTERS ARE
DESIGNED TO REMOVE PARTICULATE
MATTER 1 TO 3 MICRONS IN
DIAMETER, MEANING THEY ARE ALSO
INSUFFICIENT TO FILTER OUT THE
ULTRAFINE DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER EMITTED FROM HIGHWAY
TRAFFIC. ADDITIONALLY, OUTDOOR
ENVIRONMENTAL EXPOSURES HARM
EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL CHEMICALS,
AND PLAY A MAJOR ROLE IN HEALTH,
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN WHO
SPEND A DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT
OF THEIR TIME OUTDOORS COMPARED
TO ADULTS. THIS BILL, THEREFORE
PUTS CHILDREN AT AN ELEVATED
RISK OF EXPOSURE. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO
ON AB 2243 UNLESS AMENDED, TO
KEEP THESE PROTECTIONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JONATHAN
PRUITT. I AM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE,
OR CEJA. SAY HOW RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES AB 2243 UNLESS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE THE ORIGINAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SAFEGUARDS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COMMITTED
TO IN AB 2011? WE APPRECIATE OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
OUR ALLIANCE AGREES THAT DEEPLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A KEY NEED
FOR MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS,
AND APPRECIATES THE SERIOUSNESS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TAKE THIS
CHALLENGE. AT THE SAME TIME, IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
ARE HEALTHY AND SAFE. THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
WOULD UNDERMINE THE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS MADE BY SB 1137. IN
2022, WHICH WAS CRITICAL TO
SAFEGUARDING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ADDRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICES IN COMMUNITIES BY NOT
FULLY ACCOUNTING FOR THE HARMS
OF LIVING NEAR FREEWAYS AND OIL
AND GAS WELLS, AB 2243 RISKS
CONTINUING CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY
OF ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM AND
INJUSTICE IN WHICH SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES ARE DESIGNATED AS
SACRIFICE ZONES. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT AB 2243
ELIMINATES AB 2011 SETBACKS AND
ALLOWS DEVELOPERS TO INSTALL
MORE 13 AIR FILTERS INSTEAD.
THIS WILL PUT FUTURE RESIDENTS
OF THE HOUSING AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY AT A GREATER RISK OF
EXPERIENCING ADVERSE HEALTH
IMPACTS DUE TO THE EXPOSURE TO
TOXIC AIR POLLUTION. THE MERV 13
FILTERS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED FOR
NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. PER
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE
STANDARDS. THEREFORE, WHAT AB
2243 IS PROPOSING IS NOT BETTER
THAN THE STATUS QUO. THE AIR
FILTERS DO NOT ADDRESS PROBLEMS
RELATED TO WATER OR SOIL
CONTAMINATION OR EXPOSURE TO
OUTSIDE POLLUTION, A REPORT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE POLICY
EVIDENCE CONSORTIUM HIGHLIGHTS
HEALTH PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
FREEWAY PROXIMITY, INCLUDING
INCREASED ASTHMA AND CHILDREN,
ASTHMA AND CHILDREN DIABETES ALL
CAUSE MORTALITY, LUNG CANCER
MORTALITY AND HEALTH, HEART
DISEASE MORTALITY. IN ADDITION,
WE WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
CLARIFY SOME COMMON
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT WHAT
AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED TO ANALYZE
UNDER SEQUA PARTICULAR, THE
LANGUAGE THAT CEQA IS NOT A TOOL
FOR ASSESSING AND, BY EXTENSION,
MITIGATING THE IMPACT OF THE
EXISTING ENVIRONMENT ON THE
PROPOSED PROJECT. ONE PAST
ENVIRONMENT HARM ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AND POLLUTION. COMBINED
WITH THE PROJECT'S IMPACT CAN
IMPACT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND MUST
BE ANALYZED. FOR EXAMPLE,
EXCAVATION AND DEMOLITION
DISPLACEMENT FROM A PROPOSED
PROJECT IMPACT THE SURROUNDING
ENVIRONMENT AND THE COMMUNITY.
THESE, COMBINED WITH EXISTING
AND PAST PROJECTS, EXACERBATE
OVERALL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
AN EIR REQUIRES AN ANALYSIS OF
THESE CUMULATIVE IMPACTS TO
CREATE MITIGATION MEASURES IF
THEY'RE SIGNIFICANT. THIS IS
CRUCIAL FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES, SO THAT
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS CAN WEIGH IN AND
SUGGEST PROJECTS SPECIFIC
MITIGATION MEASURES TO PROTECT
THEIR ENVIRONMENT. THE EIR
PROCESS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMUNITY GROUND TRUTHING. THERE
IS NOT ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR
SOLUTION FOR MITIGATION. IN SOME
WE CAN WE CAN IMPROVE AB 2243 BY
REINSTATING THE FREEWAY AND OIL
AND GAS SETBACKS. THAT'S
LEGISLATURE FIRST AGREED TO AN
AB 2011. THESE SETBACKS WOULD BE
PROHIBIT AB 2011 STREAMLINE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FROM BEING
SITED WITHIN 3200FT OF
FACILITIES THAT REFINED OR
EXTRACT OIL AND GAS AND PROHIBIT
AB 2011 STREAMLINE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITHIN 500FT OF
FREEWAYS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL NOW LEAD, WE'LL PROCEED
WITH ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN ROOM 112. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY
GIRTON, ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. CÁC ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF LA HABRA, NEWPORT
BEACH AND SANTA ANA WITH OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITIONS. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS TERRY ROBINSON.
I'M HERE WITH CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT SAN DIEGO, OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. REINA TAYO. WITH PEOPLE
ORGANIZING TO DEMAND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC RIGHTS IN SAN FRANCISCO
IN OPPOSITION. UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. HELLO. FRANCES
YASMEEN MOTIWALA OF ACTIVIST SAN
DIEGO HERE TO OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED. GOOD AFTERNOON, VALERIE
REYES, ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITIES
FOR A BETTER ENVIRONMENT. AND
I'M HERE TO OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED, TO INCLUDE A HEALTH AND
SAFETY SETBACKS. THANK YOU.
HELLO, EVERYBODY. MY NAME IS
MORGAN GONZALEZ. I'M A RESIDENT
OF WILMINGTON AND WITH
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT AND SAY I'M OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. HI,
I'M SHARIFA TAYLOR, I'M WITH
COMMUNITIES FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT AND SIERRA, AND I'M
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY SETBACKS.
JENNIFER CAÑADA REGISTERING THE
POST UNLESS AMENDED. POSITIONS
OF ESPERANZA COMMUNITY HOUSING,
HOUSING EQUITY AND ADVOCACY
RESOURCE TEAM, LOS ANGELES AND
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M HANNAH
HIÂU WITH SIERRA AND COMMUNITIES
FOR A BETTER ENVIRONMENT AND I
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED, TO
INCLUDE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
SETBACKS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MAYA HERNANDEZ WITH
SIERRA AND COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT HERE TO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. MARIE
CALHOUN WITH CBE AND SIERRA HERE
TO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. HELLO,
TYLER EARL, ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CBE AS WELL AS, THE STANDING
TOGETHER AGAINST NEIGHBORHOOD
DRILLING LOS ANGELES. COALITION
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT AND THE VOICES IN
SOLIDARITY AGAINST OIL AND
NEIGHBORHOODS COALITION OPPOSE,
UNLESS AMENDED, WITH THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY SETBACKS. THANK YOU,
I'M ABBY COSTELLO. I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL FROM CHULA VISTA. I'M
HERE WITH SAN DIEGO 350 AND
SIERRA, AND I'M OPPOSED ON THIS
AMENDED. HI, I'M SHEILA MONACO.
I'M ALSO A STUDENT WITH SAN
DIEGO 350 AND SIERRA AND I'M
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS DAVE
SHUKLA. I'M THE OPERATIONS
DIRECTOR OF THE LONG BEACH
ALLIANCE FOR CLEAN ENERGY ON
BEHALF OF LBB'S AND 350
LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE OPPOSE,
UNLESS AMENDED, FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY SETBACKS. THANK YOU.
GRACIE OROZCO WITH THE CENTER ON
RACE, POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT HERE, ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK, CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY ACTION,
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE,
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION
LEADERSHIP, COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY, AND
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, LOS ANGELES,
RESPECTFULLY REGISTERING OUR
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITIONS
FOR THE INCLUSION OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY SETBACKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
WE'LL NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. AND FOR TIME CONSTRAINTS,
WE'RE GOING TO GO AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH, SENATOR CABALLERO
FIRST, IF YOU DON'T MIND VERY
MUCH, APOLOGIZE. I NEED TO GO
OVER AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
ANOTHER COMMITTEE, BUT, I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. I THINK WE'RE WE'RE ALL ON
THE SAME PAGE, WE DESPERATELY
NEED HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND, AND OUR FASTEST
GROWING HOMELESS POPULATION.
THÀNH ARE SENIORS OVER THE AGE
OF 65, AND IT IS PEOPLE OF COLOR
, IN PARTICULAR, AFRICAN
AMERICANS. IT'S PEOPLE THAT HAVE
WORKED THEIR ENTIRE LIFE HERE IN
THE STATE OR SOMEWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY, AND THEY REACH THE
RETIREMENT AGE AND THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE HERE ANYMORE
BECAUSE THEY ARE ONE STEP AWAY
FROM A HIGH MEDICAL BILL THAT
DRIVES THEM OUT OF THE HOUSING
THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE. SO WE
NEED TO PRODUCE. THAT'S JUST THE
BOTTOM LINE, BUT WE DID REACH A
DEAL, AND, I THINK WE WORKED
REALLY, REALLY HARD TO HAVE YOUR
BILL DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN
MY BILL DID. AND I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO REALLY KIND OF FIGURE
OUT, HOW WE RESOLVE IT, BUT I, I
FEEL VERY CONFIDENT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. WHEN
THE WHEN THE VOTE COMES UP. BUT
I JUST WANTED YOU TO KNOW THAT I
DO APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THE IN THE
HOUSING AREA, INCLUDING HELPING
ME GET MY BILL OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY, WHICH I WHICH IS NOT
ALWAYS AN EASY THING TO DO IF
YOU'RE IN THE SENATE. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT BUT, SO
JUST I PUT A, PUT A POINT ON
THAT I HAVE TO RUN OVER AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND ANOTHER.
BUT I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL HERE
TODAY AND WE'LL MOVE IT ON. SO
THANK YOU. I KNOW, I KNOW, I'VE
SEEN YOU AROUND HERE A LITTLE
BIT, MR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR KHÎI. WE'LL NOW MOVE
FORWARD WITH, SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. YES. THANK YOU. SO
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO THE LAST
BILL, ABOUT THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY, WHERE YOU'RE TAKING
SOMETHING THAT'S EXISTING AND
THEN MODIFYING IT TO MAKE IT
WORK BETTER. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO
CHANGE. I THINK MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL IS SO POWERFUL BECAUSE
PROJECTS THAT THAT ARE APPROVED
MINISTERIAL Kò ARE THE
DEVELOPER, THE DEVELOPER GOES
THROUGH A CHECKLIST OF THINGS
THAT ARE REQUIRED AND WHEN THEY
CAN MEET ALL THOSE THINGS, THEN
THEY GET THE STAMP OF APPROVAL
AND THE BUILDING PERMIT AND THEY
CAN BUILD. SO, HAVING A PROCESS
THAT IS CERTAIN AND IS MORE TIME
BOUND IS REALLY IMPORTANT. AND
MY READING OF THIS BILL IS THAT
CERTAIN THINGS ARE MINISTERIALLY
APPROVED. IT'S MORE BROAD
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL, AND THEN
OTHER THINGS HAVE BEEN NARROWED.
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO ASK THE
AUTHOR OR HER LEAD WITNESSES
ABOUT THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERN
ABOUT THE 500FT FROM A FREEWAY,
OR 3200FT FROM AN ACTIVE OIL OR
GAS EXTRACTION FACILITY. IT
SEEMS THAT THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE MERV 13 AIR
FILTRATION SYSTEM, AND SO I
THINK IT'S QUITE POSSIBLE THAT
THAT IS ADEQUATE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH, AND SO THERE
DOESN'T NEED TO BE AN ADDITIONAL
CEQA PROCESS ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO HEAR
DIRECTLY ABOUT WHAT YOUR
RESPONSE IS TO THE CONCERNS
ABOUT LIVING WITHIN 500FT OF A
FREEWAY. YEAH. SO FIRST OF ALL,
I APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
COMING IN AND RAISING THOSE
CONCERNS, BECAUSE I THINK THOSE
ARE THE RIGHT CONCERNS THAT WE
SHOULD BE RAISING WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOUSING, OR
ANYTHING REALLY, ANYTIME WE HAVE
PROXIMITY TO THOSE TYPES OF
FACILITIES OR HIGHWAYS, I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM. WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS. WE CAN CONTINUE
THOSE. WE'VE ALSO CONSULTED
OUTSIDE, COUNSEL IN TERMS OF AIR
QUALITY EXPERTS AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN
THE RIGHT PROVISIONS, WE'RE
BRINGING THIS BILL WILL BRING
CONFORMITY TO THE SB FOUR
STANDARD AROUND FREEWAYS THAT
WERE PUT INTO EFFECT WITH THAT
BILL, WHICH I THINK MOST OF YOU
VOTED FOR, MAYBE SOME OF YOU
WERE COAUTHORS. SO I THINK THAT
CONFORMITY, I THINK, IS
IMPORTANT. THIS IS ALSO, SIMILAR
CONFORMITY TO THE SB 423,
STANDARDS IN TERMS OF, AROUND
OIL FACILITIES. SO WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT PREVIOUS BIGGER
HOUSING BILLS IN TERMS OF, YOU
KNOW, WHAT THEY HAVE DONE SO
THAT WE'RE NOT REINVENTING THE
WHEEL ALL THE TIME AND TRYING TO
BRING CONFORMITY IN A WAY WITH
AN EYE TOWARDS, THE STRONGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS WE CAN
PUT FORTH THAT ALLOWS US TO
BUILD THE HOUSING THAT WE NEED.
BUT IT IS A PARTICULAR CHALLENGE
IN LOS ANGELES BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY HIGHWAYS, WE COULD MAKE
LOS ANGELES JUST EXEMPT FROM
BUILDING HOUSING BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY HIGHWAYS. IF WE
DON'T WANT TO BUILD NEAR NEAR
HIGHWAYS BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
OF THEM, SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT THE RIGHT WHAT ARE THE RIGHT
REMEDIES TO MITIGATE AGAINST
SOME OF THOSE POTENTIAL NEGATIVE
IMPACTS THAT YOU CAN GET FROM
THE HOUSING, IF THAT MAKES
SENSE. THANK YOU. CHAIR, IF YOU
DON'T MIND IF. YEAH, I MEAN,
DRIVING ON THE FREEWAYS IN LA,
IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF HOUSING ACTUALLY NEXT TO THE
FREEWAY. AND THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT NEXT TO
THE FREEWAY WITH ABSOLUTELY NO
PARTICULATE, PREVENTION FROM
BEING BREATHED IN IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
WHICH, WHICH REALLY ARE
DISASTROUS. SO BUILDING MORE
HOUSING AND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
LIVE INSIDE WITH THE APPROPRIATE
MITIGATION IS, I THINK, EXACTLY
WHERE WE SHOULD BE GOING. SO
IDENTIFYING WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES WHEN WE ARE LIVING
WITH WITHIN THAT PROXIMITY OF
THE FREEWAY AND THEN APPLYING IT
AS PART OF THE MINISTERIAL
PROCESS? TO ME, THAT VERY MUCH
MAKES SENSE. SO I JUST I WAS
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS HAD BEEN THE ADEQUATE
ANALYSIS OF THE MERV 13 AIR
FILTRATION SYSTEM AS BEING THE
RIGHT THING. YEAH AND OR IF THAT
WAS STILL BEING WORKED OUT, BUT
BUT WHATEVER THE RIGHT THING IS
THAT WE'RE DOING IT. I WANT THE
STRONGEST STANDARDS WE CAN GET
THAT'S TO ALLOW FOR THE HOUSING,
AND THAT'S THE PLANE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO LAND HERE. AND WHERE
WE'LL CONTINUE TO HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OPPOSITION,
BECAUSE IT'S YOU'VE RAISED IT,
OTHERS HAVE RAISED IT AS WELL.
SO I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
WORKING ON. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MANAGER THANK YOU SO MUCH,
YOU KNOW, WE TALKED ABOUT SOME
VERY SIMILAR ISSUES. YOU'RE
RIGHT. LÀ A LOT OF A LOT OF
FREEWAYS. I HAVE SIX IN MY
DISTRICT. FIVE OVERLAP EACH
OTHER. THE CONCENTRATIONS
PRETTY, PRETTY HEAVY, MADAM VICE
CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE OPPOSITION
JUST TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
RELATED TO SB FOUR. SB FOR THOSE
PREDOMINANTLY ALREADY CREATED.
RIGHT. THE PLACES OF WORSHIP,
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES ARE
ALREADY THERE, HOPEFULLY NOT
SUPER CLOSE TO OUR FREEWAYS, BUT
THEY'RE THERE. THEY EXIST. IT,
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THIS WOULD
SIMPLY JUST MATCH WHAT WE
ALREADY PASSED AND IS ALREADY IN
LAW, NO. THAT'S INCORRECT. THE
SB FOUR, THERE ARE MANY OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS ONE, WHICH WAS
THE OIL AND GAS SETBACK IN SB
FOUR. THERE IS AN OIL GAS
SETBACK AND THAT'S 3200FT, THERE
IS A FREEWAY FOR 500FT. THERE'S
ALSO A SETBACK PROVISION FOR
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIAL USES BEING,
1200 FEET TO 1600 FEET, OR 1200
FEET TO 600FT TO BELOW. AND
THAT'S A THAT'S BASED OFF OF THE
SCALE ON I BELIEVE IT'S BASED
OFF OF THE AIR DISTRICT'S, SORT
OF PERMITTING THAT THEY GIVE IF
A SPECIFIC FACILITY IS ABLE TO
EMIT A SPECIFIC THRESHOLD OF A
POLLUTANT, IT HAS TO ACQUIRE A
SPECIFIC PERMIT, AND THAT'S WHAT
IT'S HELD ONTO. BUT THERE ARE
MANY, PROVISIONS IN SB FOUR THAT
WERE NOT COVERED IN AB 22, 43.
THE AUTHOR YOU STATED THAT THERE
ARE CAN I IF I COULD CLARIFY, IF
YOU'RE, ON THE ON THE HIGHWAY
SETBACK, SPECIFICALLY THOSE NEAR
US BEFORE. SO THERE IS A 500
FOOT SETBACK IN SB IN YOUR BILL.
SO MY BILL INCLUDES THE AIR
FILTRATION HÌNH, REQUIREMENTS
THAT SB FOUR INCLUDED, IN AND
AROUND THE HIGHWAYS, BUT NO
SETBACKS ON IT. CORRECT. ON YOUR
BILL. OKAY OKAY. NO, SAME AS SB
FOUR. MADAM VICE CHAIR, I JUST
NEED SOME CLARIFICATION BECAUSE
I THINK I'M STILL A LITTLE
CONFUSED. ABSOLUTELY. I'M GOING
TO GO TO THE AUTHOR HERE
CONFUSED AS WELL. SO YEAH. LET
ME ASK ON SB FOUR HAS A HAS A
WITHIN 500FT RIGHT. YEAH YEAH SB
FOUR HAS WITHIN 500FT AIR
FILTRATION REQUIRES IT'S THAT MY
BILL MIRRORS AND MATCHES. OKAY.
AND SO YES, FOR AIR AIR
FILTRATION SPECIFICALLY ON THE
HIGHWAY SETBACKS. OKAY SO THERE
IS A HIGHWAY SETBACK IN YOUR
BILL. NO SORRY. THERE ARE NOT
THERE'S A THERE'S AN L FOR AIR
FILTRATION REQUIREMENT WITHIN
500FT WHICH, WHICH MATCHES WHAT
SB FOUR IS SAME. IT'S THE SAME
AS SB FOUR. GOT IT. BUT
CONSTRUCTION CAN HAPPEN WITHIN
500FT, CORRECT? YES. SIMILAR TO
THIS BEFORE. GOT IT. OKAY, WITH
THOSE REQUIREMENTS. OKAY, I KNOW
YOU'VE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING. I KNOW YOU'VE MADE ME
THAT COMMITMENT AND YOU'VE
YOU'VE SAID IT AGAIN HERE. THAT
IS ONE OF MY BIGGER CONCERNS. I
THINK WHERE I SEE THE DIFFERENCE
IS WHAT I, WHAT I'VE MENTIONED
IS, IS SB FOUR, ARE THOSE
BUILDINGS ARE THERE. THESE ARE
NEW CONSTRUCTION THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY CREATE EVEN MORE,
HARM, I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
BUILD WAY MORE HOUSING. WE'RE
NOWHERE NEAR 100. I SHARED WITH
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I LOVED
2011 EVEN BEFORE I GOT HERE. I
WISH MY CITY WOULD TAKE MORE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT, BUT I WOULD
ALSO SAY THE STANDARDS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MY CITY AND LÀ, I
CRITICIZE THE AQMD. I DON'T
THINK WE'RE DOING ENOUGH. SO I
DON'T THINK THE STANDARDS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST, AT LEAST IN THE
CITY OF L.A, ARE GOOD ENOUGH TO
PROTECT MY COMMUNITY. SO AS
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO LOOK AT
WHAT STANDARD TO UTILIZE, I WANT
TO LOOK AT THEM AS A NORTH STAR
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FAILED. A LOT
OF MY COMMUNITIES. SO I WOULD
LOOK AND IMPLORE FOR YOUR TEAM
TO LOOK AT SOMETHING THAT IS
REALLY ACTUALLY GOING TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES. YEAH, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT, WHICH IS WHY
WE'VE SOUGHT OUTSIDE COUNSEL
OUTSIDE EXPERTS IN THIS SPACE TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND, LIKE, WHAT IS
THE MOST AGGRESSIVE THING THAT
WE CAN DO IN TERMS OF REQUIRING
THE NECESSARY SAFETY GUARDS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SAFE WHILE STILL ALLOWING FOR
THE HOUSING WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO BUILD THE HOUSING. THE OTHER
OPTION IS WE MAKE IT DIFFICULT
TO BUILD THE HOUSING. IT COSTS
EVEN MORE MONEY, SPECIFICALLY IN
AREAS THAT HAVE, YOU KNOW, NEAR
FREEWAYS AND OTHER PLACES AS
WELL, WHICH JUST INCREASE THE
COST BURDEN ON ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO THAT'S THE
LIKE PLANE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LAND IS HOW CAN YOU, ENSURE THAT
WE MAKE IT EASIER DOING SO WITH
THE RIGHT SAFEGUARDS? I'M VERY
COMMITTED TO IT. I'D LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON IT, IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN THAT, I SHARE THE
CONCERN AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION ON THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO HAVE THE
STRONGEST STANDARDS THAT WE CAN
PUT FORTH WHILE STILL ALLOWING
FOR THE NECESSARY HOUSING THAT
WE NEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT. JUST WERE ADDRESSING ONE
INJUSTICE. LET'S NOT CREATE
ANOTHER INJUSTICE. BUT I THINK
THE SENATOR SAID IT CORRECTLY. I
THINK IT BAFFLES ME THAT WE
ALLOW PEOPLE TO SLEEP ON THE
STREETS NEXT TO FREEWAYS, BUT
THEN WE WON'T BUILD NEXT TO
FREEWAY. SO I GET THAT CONUNDRUM
AS WELL. I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL AND I DO I I'LL TAKE
YOU UP ON THAT OFFER, WORKING
TOGETHER AND FINDING A HOW WE
CAN LAND THIS PLANE. OKAY. THANK
YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS BY OUR MEMBERS? OKAY
SEEING NONE. LET ME TAKE A LOOK.
YEAH THEN WE CAN CALL FOR A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. MEMBER WICKS,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL. OH, I
GUESS WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION.
WOULD ANYBODY LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION ON THE BILL? THANK YOU.
SENATOR, WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PADILLA. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
SKINNER, OKOBOJI, A OKOBOJI. I
BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I
CABALLERO. CORTEZ CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I PADILLA.
PADILLA I. SATO. UMBERG. WAHAB
THAT'S 5 TO 0. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
IT OPEN. YEAH. WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS NEXT. THIS IS HER LAST
BILL. OKAY WE'LL NOT PROCEED
WITH AB 2580 BY MEMBER WICKS.
THANK YOU, MISS. HEAR ME? THERE
WE GO. THIS ONE HOPEFULLY WILL
GO MUCH MORE QUICKLY. SO
APPRECIATE YOUR ALL'S PATIENCE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT MEMBER
WICKS. WOULD YOU MIND WAITING
JUST A TAD WHILE IT GETS A. WE
HAVE. YEAH. ME TOO. DID YOU GET
THE VÌ? NO. OKAY. WE HAVE
WITNESSES EXITING THE, THE ROOM.
QUITE EXCITED. THE LAST BILL WAS
MORE POPULAR THAN THIS ONE. I
GUESS. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE ABOUT TO
CLOSE THE DOOR. JUST AS LONG.
LET'S JUST WAIT TILL THE DOOR
CLOSES AND WE'LL CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT. MEMBER WICKS, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS FOR BEARING WITH ME
HERE, THROUGH THE MARATHON OF
THE WICKS BILLS, THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME PRESENT AB 2580. THE
PURPOSE OF AB 2580 IS TO
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE
INTERSECTION OF HOUSING POLICY
AND HISTORIC PRESERVATION.
HISTORIC DISTRICTS AND BUILDINGS
DESIGNED AS HISTORICALLY
SIGNIFICANT RECEIVE SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS THAT SUBJECT NEW
DEVELOPMENTS, BUILDING
RENOVATION AND DESIGN CHANGES TO
A MORE RIGOROUS AND THOROUGH
REVIEW PROCESS. THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
PRESERVING OUR STATE'S RICH
PHYSICAL AND CULTURAL HERITAGE,
AS ARE THE TAX BREAKS THAT THE
STATE PROVIDES TO QUALIFYING
HISTORIC BUILDINGS. HOWEVER, THE
HISTORIC PRESERVATION PROCESS
CAN ENCOURAGE ABUSE BY THOSE WHO
WEAPONIZE IT AGAINST HOUSING
PRODUCTION, PARTICULARLY IN
WEALTHY SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE NOT
WILLING TO ACCEPT GENTLE
INCREASE IN DENSITY FROM
DUPLEXES AND ADUS. THIS ABUSE OF
THE HISTORIC DESIGNATION PROCESS
IMPEDES OR BLOCKS URGENTLY
NEEDED HOUSING WITHOUT
PROTECTING OUR IMPORTANT
RESOURCES. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NO MEASURES IN PLACE TO ENSURE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EXAMINE THE
INTERSECTION OF THEIR HISTORIC
PRESERVATION POLICIES WITH THEIR
HOUSING POLICIES. AB 2580 SEEKS
TO ADDRESS THIS DEFICIENCY IN
TWO WAYS. IT WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DISCUSS IN THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT, HOW HISTORIC
PRESERVATION POLICIES AND
PRACTICES COULD CONSTRAIN NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. IT ALSO
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
LIST ALL NEW HISTORIC
DESIGNATIONS IN THEIR ANNUAL
PROGRESS REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TOGETHER,
THESE CHANGES WOULD INCREASE
TRANSPARENT THèC AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE
INTERSECTION OF HOUSING POLICY
AND HISTORIC PRESERVATION
POLICY. NOW, I KNOW WE HAVE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FROM
PRESERVATION ADVOCATES THAT WE
ARE STIGMATIZING HISTORIC
PRESERVATION OR NOT EMPHASIZING
ITS VALUE. LET ME BE CLEAR THAT
IS NOT MY INTENT, NOR IS IT THE
LANGUAGE I USE WHEN DISCUSSING
THE BILL. AS I'VE ALREADY SAID,
HISTORIC PRESERVATION IS A
CENTRAL ESSENTIAL TO PRESERVING
OUR STATE'S RICH PHYSICAL AND
CULTURAL HERITAGE. THAT DOESN'T
MEAN WE SHOULD IGNORE ITS
EFFECTS WHEN DEVELOPING HOUSING
POLICY, JUST AS WE DON'T IGNORE
OTHER IMPORTANT EFFECTS, LIKE
ZONING, BUILDING STANDARDS, OR
EVEN THE IMPACT FEES WE USE TO
FUND IMPORTANT PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. BECAUSE ONLY IF
WE EXAMINE THE ISSUE, WE CAN
FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS
BOTH THE GOALS OF PRESERVING, OF
PRESERVATION AND HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN A WAY THAT IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO BOTH WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS FRANCIS
MARTY, SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGY AND GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AT CALIFORNIA YIMBY. GOOD. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS FRANCIS MARTY,
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA YIMBY
HERE AS A PROUD SPONSOR TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2580,
CALIFORNIA IS A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OF OVER 80,000
NEIGHBORS DEDICATED TO MAKING
OUR STATE AN AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE, WORK, AND RAISE A FAMILY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT HISTORIC
PRESERVATION PLAYS A VITAL ROLE
IN PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S
ARCHITECTURAL HERITAGE AND
CONSERVING PLACES OF HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE. HOWEVER, NO
MEASURES ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BALANCE LEGITIMATE HISTORIC
PRESERVATION THÀNH WITH
POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON A
COMMUNITY'S ABILITY TO MEET ITS
HOUSING NEEDS. AB 2580 WOULD
ENHANCE THE TRANSPARENCY OF
NEWLY ADOPTED HISTORICAL
DESIGNATIONS BY REQUIRING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REPORT THEM TO
HCD IN THEIR ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORTS, AND MONITOR HOW NEW
DESIGNATIONS COULD IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO MEET HOUSING NEEDS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT HINDER THE
PRESERVATION OF HISTORIC
RESOURCES. IT SIMPLY REQUIRES
REPORTING AND MONITORING OF ALL
NEW HISTORIC DESIGNATIONS AND
EXAMINES HOW PRESERVATION
PRACTICES MAY CONFLICT WITH
OTHER WITH OUR HOUSING NEEDS.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT
CALIFORNIA YIMBY RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
2580. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, WE'LL PROCEED WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 2580.
WITHIN THE ACTION AND SUPPORT.
HOLLY. FOR MANY DAYS, LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF SPUR
AND THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
IN SUPPORT. SALAS AND MATT AND
I, HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 2580. THANK YOU, BEFORE I
BEGIN, I HAVE A QUESTION. I HAVE
AN ASSOCIATE WHO IS TO JOIN ME
TODAY. BUT SHE COULD NOT APPEAR
BECAUSE OF A MEDICAL ISSUE. SHE
IS INSTEAD SUBMITTED A LETTER.
MAY I READ THAT ON HER BEHALF? I
GIVE MY COMMENTS. I DO NOT SEE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT. IS IT? OH
MADAM CHAIR IS BACK.
SORRY I HAVE TO READ HER. OKAY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS CINDY
HEITZMAN. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
PRESERVATION FOUNDATION, AND I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING 13
HISTORIC PRESERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE TO OPPOSE AB 2580, OUR
OPPOSITION IS ROOTED IN THE
BILL'S, FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS. THE
BILL IS BASED ON THE UNSUPPORTED
ASSUMPTION THAT HISTORIC
PRESERVATION NOMINATIONS ARE
BEING EXPLOITED BY PREDOMINANTLY
AFFLUENT NEIGHBORHOODS TO BLOCK
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE, NO DATA,
NO CASE STUDIES, NOTHING TO
SUBSTANTIATE THIS CLAIM. WHEN
ASKED WHICH CITIES ARE ABUSING
THE NOMINATION PROCESS, THOSE
OFTEN CITED ARE BERKELEY, LOS
ANGELES, SAN FRANCISCO, PALO
ALTO, PASADENA, SAN DIEGO. ALL
OF THESE CITIES PARTICIPATE IN
THE CERTIFIED LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM, WHICH IS A FEDERAL
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO ENSURE A
BALANCED AND REGULATED APPROACH
TO HISTORIC NOMINATIONS. OVER 60
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM, AND THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE A SYSTEM TO
NOMINATE HISTORIC RESOURCES AND
REPORT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO THE
OFFICE OF HISTORIC PRESERVATION.
WE MET WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM
CALIFORNIA YIMBY TO TALK ABOUT
WAYS THAT WE COULD POSSIBLY
AMEND THIS TO MAKE THIS MORE
FAVORABLE, BUT OUR OPPOSITION,
QUITE FRANKLY, LIES IN THE BASIS
OF THIS BILL, AND THAT IS
HISTORIC PRESERVATION IS BEING
ABUSED. YOU HAVE TO MONITOR IT
AND YOU HAVE TO REPORT IT. THE
PROBLEM THAT AB 2580 CLAIMS TO
ADDRESS IS OVERSTATED. LESS THAN
5% OF THE DEVELOPED AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DESIGNATED AS
HISTORIC. IN LOS ANGELES, ONLY
7% OF THE BUILDING STOCK IS
HISTORIC OR ELIGIBLE FOR
DESIGNATION THÀNH. 40% OF
FEDERAL HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
PROJECTS SUPPORT NEW HOUSING
THROUGH ADAPTIVE REUSE OR
MAINTENANCE OF EXISTING HOUSING
THROUGH THESE VERY IMPORTANT TAX
CREDITS. NOW WE HAVE THE STATE
HISTORIC TAX CREDIT COMING ON
BOARD, AND WE EXPECT THAT NUMBER
WILL INCREASE. HISTORIC
PRESERVATION HAS NOT BEEN AN
IMPEDIMENT TO CREATING HOUSING.
THE BILL SPONSOR, CALIFORNIA
YIMBY, HAS CLEARLY INDICATED
THAT THIS BILL IS BASED ON ABUSE
OF PRESERVATION NOMINATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE, AND THEY CITE,
QUOTE, THE AB 2580 IS A CRUCIAL
FIRST STEP IN THE ABUSE AND
PREVENTING THE ABUSE OF HISTORIC
PRESERVATION RULES. IT'S THEIR
WORDS, NOT MINE. THE INTENT IS
ALARMING. IT IS UNSUBSTANTIATED
BY FACTUAL EVIDENCE OF ABUSE. WE
CANNOT SUPPORT A BILL WHEN THE
BILL SPONSOR INTENDS TO THROTTLE
HISTORIC DESIGNATIONS AND WILL
FURTHER ISOLATE THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY PURPORT TO
PROTECT. IT DOES NOTHING TO
CREATE NEW HOUSING. IT'S ABOUT
NOTHING. IT'S ABOUT MONITORING
HISTORIC PRESERVATION WHERE
THEY'RE ALREADY MONITORING
PROVISIONS IN PLACE. IT'S A
TROJAN HORSE DESIGNED TO WEAKEN
HISTORIC PRESERVATION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE AB 2850. PARDON ME. 2580.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
WANT TO COME TO THE MIC? MADAM
CHAIR, I THINK SHE HAD ASKED IF
SHE COULD. OH. OH, OKAY. YOU'VE
GOT TWO MINUTES REMAINING. THANK
YOU. THIS IS SUBMITTED ON BEHALF
OF PAIGE AND TURNBULL
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM IN SAN
FRANCISCO FROM ONE OF THEIR
PRINCIPALS, CHRISTINA DICUS.
BASED ON MY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE AND OBSERVATIONS, I
WRITE TO EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION
TO AB 2580 AS I DON'T SEE HOW
THIS BILL WILL ACCELERATE.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IS BASED ON
MISINFORMATION AND WILL CREATE
MORE HOUSING AND BUREAUCRACY
RATHER THAN REMOVING BARRIERS TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. I AM
WRITING AS A PRINCIPLE OF THE
CULTURAL RESOURCE PLANNING
STUDIO PAGE AND TURNBULL
HISTORIC PRESERVATION
ARCHITECTURE AND PLANNING FIRM
HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED AND
ADAPTIVELY REUSING HISTORIC
BUILDINGS ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR
OVER 50 YEARS. I SUPPORT THE
PRESERVATION OF HISTORIC
NEIGHBORHOODS, AND I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE FACING A
HOUSING CRISIS. THESE DO NOT
HAVE TO BE COMPETING GOALS
REQUIRED. HOUSING REPORTING IS A
BURDEN TO UNDERSTAFFED CITIES,
AND THIS TASK WILL MAKE STAFF
RESOURCES, TAKE STAFF RESOURCES
AWAY. THE COST OF THIS WORK WILL
INEVITABLY FLOW THROUGH TO THE
APPLICANT'S HOUSING DEVELOPERS
BY INCREASING THE COST OF
HOUSING. SINCE 2020, OUR
PRACTICE HAS SEEN THE BIGGEST
IMPEDIMENT TO BUILDING HOUSING
IS COST AND FINANCING, NOT
NECESSARILY ZONING POLICY. WHAT
IS MORE, IN LATE MAY 2024,
CALIFORNIA YIMBY SENT OUT AN
E-BLAST WHICH READS IN PART. A
FEW MONTHS AGO, A GROUP OF
NIMBYS IN SAN MATEO ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY FOUND A LOOPHOLE AND
ARE TRYING TO BLOCK THE
CONSTRUCTION OF DESPERATELY
NEEDED NEW HOMES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. GET THE
NEIGHBORHOOD DESIGNATED AS A
HISTORIC DISTRICT. WE'RE SEEING
MORE AND MORE OF THIS ACROSS THE
STATE IN 2024. THE MOVEMENT IS
FIGHTING BACK. CALIFORNIA YIMBY
IS THE SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN
BUFFY WICKS, AB 2580. IT'S A
CRUCIAL FIRST STEP TOWARD
REINING IN THE ABUSE OF HISTORIC
PRESERVATION RULES. I WOULD LIKE
TO SPECIFICALLY DISCUSS THE CASE
IN SAN MATEO, REFERENCED ABOVE.
PAGE AND TURNBULL HAS BEEN
PREPARING THE NOMINATION TO
DESIGNATE A HISTORIC RESIDENTIAL
DISTRICT TO THE NATIONAL
REGISTER OF HISTORIC PLACES ON
BEHALF OF A LOCAL GROUP OF
CITIZENS. PROPONENTS OF AB 2580
HAVE SPREAD FALSE INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS NOMINATION EFFORT,
WHICH HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
INFORMING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS BILL. IT IS A RED HERRING
TO POINT TO THE AREA BEING
NOMINATED AS A HISTORIC
DISTRICT. AS A POSTER CHILD OF
HISTORIC PRESERVATION
OBSTRUCTION, WHERE IT CONSISTS
OF 1% 450 OF 39,732 OF TOTAL
CURRENT RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
IN THE CITY OF SAN MATEO, AND
FAR LESS THAN THAT IN TOTAL
PARCELS. FURTHERMORE, THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL WOULD
LIKE THE PUBLIC TO BELIEVE THAT
THE BAYWOOD HISTORIC DISTRICT
NOMINATION SAN MATEO, WAS
PREPARED IN AN EFFORT TO THWART
HOUSING DENSITY. IN FACT, IT WAS
SPURRED IN REACTION TO THE
DEMOLITION OF OLDER SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES WITH NEW, MUCH
LARGER SINGLE FAMILY HOMES. THE
LOCAL GROUPS STRIVE TO RECOGNIZE
THE AREA AS A HISTORIC DISTRICT,
WITH THE HOPE THAT IT WOULD SPUR
THE CITY OF SAN MATEO TO
CONSIDER PLANNING TOOLS THAT
WOULD ENCOURAGE COMPATIBLE
ALTERATIONS IN NEW CONSTRUCTION,
INCLUDING ADUS AND JUNIOR ADUS,
WHICH ARE ALLOWED IN HISTORIC
DISTRICTS TO INCREASE DENSITY.
WHILE I RECOGNIZE THE CRITICAL
CRITICAL NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AB 2580 INTRODUCES
BUSYWORK THAT WILL NOT
EFFECTIVELY REMOVE BARRIERS TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT, YOUR TIME
IS ELAPSED. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO, INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. LET ME SEE
IF THERE'S ANY. GO AHEAD.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE FOUR BILLS FROM
YOU TODAY, SO, MY READ ON THIS
BILL IS THAT IT IS RELATIVELY
MODEST. SO, I THINK HISTORIC
PRESERVATION IS A VERY IMPORTANT
VALUE. AND IN MANY WAYS, IN
CALIFORNIA, WE DON'T PRESERVE
OUR HISTORY AS MUCH AS WE
SHOULD. WE SEE MORE BECAUSE IT'S
CHEAPER TO START A FRESH TEAR
DOWN AND BUILD NEW. WE SEE THAT
HAPPENING, AND I, MOURN THE LOSS
OF SOME OF OUR OLDER STRUCTURES.
AND SEE PICTURES OF, OF THE WAY
THINGS USED TO LOOK, EVEN OLD
SCHOOL HOUSES AND THINGS. AND
YOU RECOGNIZE OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD WHERE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO BUILDING.
SO I THINK RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF HISTORIC
PRESERVATION IS A VALUE IN THE
SAME WAY THAT PROVIDING MORE
HOUSING IS A VALUE, AND WE ALSO
SEE THAT THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT LATCH ON TO WHATEVER FOR A,
A POSSIBLE OPTION TO AVOID
BUILDING HOUSING COULD BE. SO
THERE MIGHT BE A COMMUNITY THAT
SAYS, WE WANT TO BE A MOUNTAIN
LION SANCTUARY. WE WANT TO BE A
HISTORIC PRESERVATION OF THE
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD OR THE
ENTIRE CITY OR COMMUNITY. AND SO
THE I THINK WHEN YOU WHEN, WHEN
THIS IS USED AS, AS A RUSE TO
ESSENTIALLY AVOID OBLIGATIONS IN
SOME OTHER PART OF THE CODE,
WHICH INVOLVES BUILDING, HOUSING
, IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
IS IT THAT THAT IS ACTUALLY
STOPPING THE CREATION OF
HOUSING. SO THERE ARE I HAVE
SEEN EXAMPLES OF PROPOSED
HISTORIC PRESERVATION ON
BASICALLY VAST OPEN PARKING LOTS
WITH ONE DERELICT BUILDING
SITTING ON IT, THAT, THAT, THAT,
THAT THE NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND IT
DOES NOT WANT THAT TO BECOME A
METRO SALAS THAT MIGHT HAVE A
LOT OF TRAFFIC AND THE
EXTERNALITIES THAT CAN BE
PERCEIVED AS NEGATIVE TO
BUILDING MORE HOUSING. SO TO ME,
THIS BILL DOESN'T IS NOT AN
OVERREACH BECAUSE WHAT IT IS
DOING IS YOU USED SOME REALLY
COLORFUL LANGUAGE, WHICH I
APPRECIATED. I DON'T SEE IT AS
THROTTLING HISTORIC
PRESERVATION, BUT I DO SEE IT AS
MONITORING HISTORIC PRESERVATION
. SO, ASKING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHO ALREADY ARE EXTENSIVELY
INVENTORYING WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THEIR CITY IN THEIR AS PART OF
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS
TO, PUT THEIR ARMS AROUND ALL
THE DIFFERENT UNITS OR SECTIONS
OF THEIR CITY THAT MIGHT HAVE
THE HISTORIC PRESERVATION
DESIGNATION OR ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF GETTING IT. AND THEN
TO REPORT THAT AS A WHOLE, TO
ME, THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
AND WOULD ALLOW FOR SOME
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS AND DATA TO
BE PROVIDED. SO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL, I THINK THAT IT'S, IT'S
MODEST AND I, I HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO VALUE ADAPTIVE REUSE
AND HISTORIC PRESERVATION AND
PROTECTING THE PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT CONNECT US TO OUR
PAST, BECAUSE THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT VALUES THAT I THINK
ARE VERY MOST COMMUNITY MEMBERS
DO SHARE. THANK YOU CHAIR. AND I
WILL, WITH THAT MOVE, THE BILL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS? ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES? ALL RIGHT. OH SORRY.
GO AHEAD PLEASE. I JUST DIDN'T
YEAH, SURE. I WANTED TO MENTION
SOMETHING, SOMEONE WHO COMES
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE. WE ADORE
HISTORY. WE REALLY TRY TO.
ESPECIALLY MY IN MY CITY, WE
HAVE A VERY ENGAGED, HISTORICAL
COMMUNITY SOCIETY. I JUST WANT
TO. FOR THE RECORD, I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY, BASED
ON MY UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
BILL DOES. SO I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE. WE'RE
UNDERSTANDING IT THE SAME WAY,
AS THE OPPOSITION MAY BE
SUPPORTING IT, BUT JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY, A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR, BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION
SAID THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD MUCH
OPPOSITION TO, TO CONSTRUCTION
BASED ON HISTORICAL,
DESIGNATIONS. SO THE QUESTION
THAT I WANT TO POSE IS WHY THIS
BILL, SINCE WE'RE NOT WE DON'T
WE HAVEN'T HAD AN ISSUE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE. I THINK
WE HAVE HAD SOME CONCERNS, WHICH
IS WHY I JUST THINK WE NEED MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO UNDERSTAND HOW
HISTORIC PRESERVATION IS USED,
THAT THIS BILL IS VERY MODEST,
AND IT'S REALLY JUST ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND UNDERSTANDING
WHEN STUFF IS BEING DESIGNATED
AS HISTORIC OR BEING NOMINATED
AS SUCH, AND REQUIRING SOME
BASIC REPORTING TO THAT AND ALSO
THOUGHTFULNESS AROUND WHEN
YOU'RE DOING YOUR HOUSING
ELEMENT, IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
BANNING ANYTHING. IT'S NOT
GETTING RID OF ANYTHING. IT'S
NOT, YOU KNOW, BUT WE I MEAN,
WE'VE SEEN IT IN MY DISTRICT IN
BERKELEY. WE'VE SEEN IT. I'M
SURE THE SENATOR CAN ATTEST TO
THAT, IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. AND SO I THINK HAVING A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF ITS USE
AND ITS APPLICATION TO ENSURE
THAT IT IS BEING USED FOR WHAT I
THINK WE ALL AGREE IT SHOULD BE
USED FOR TO PROTECT OUR TRULY
HISTORIC AREAS WITHOUT
POTENTIALLY BEING, WEAPONIZED.
AND SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
THERE'S YOU CAN'T GO WRONG WITH
MORE SUNLIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY
ON ANY POLICY MAKING ISSUES.
THIS ONE INCLUDED. I DON'T KNOW
IF WITH THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE THE
SPONSORS TO ALSO TALK TO THAT
OR, IF OR IF YOU FEEL LIKE I'VE
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION. NO I
JUST SO BASED ON MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
OPPOSITION STATED, WAS THE FACT
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THE
REPORTING DONE, IS THAT CORRECT
OR YOU DO FOR CERTIFIED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO IS THAT NOT
QUITE EXTENSIVE ENOUGH OR, OR
SUFFICIENT. SURE. SO I CAN I CAN
ADDRESS THAT. SO, IN OUR VIEW,
NOTHING IN THE CERTIFIED LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM, WHICH WAS
MENTIONED BY THE OPPOSITION,
ACCOUNTS FOR THE IMPACT OF
HISTORIC PRESERVATION ON
HOUSING. SO THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT
COVERED, SO AND IF CITIES ARE
ALREADY COLLECTING AND REPORTING
THIS INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO, IT SHOULD BE MUCH
EASIER TO PROVIDE TO HCD. SO, SO
WE SEE THIS AS, THE AUTHOR SAID,
AS A BALANCED APPROACH THAT
DOESN'T HINDER, THE PRESERVATION
OF HISTORIC RESOURCES. IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES A THOROUGH EXAMINATION
OF HOW PRESERVATION PRACTICES
MAY CONFLICT WITH HOUSING NEEDS,
AS WE DO ALREADY WITH OTHER
UNNECESSARY PUBLIC FUNCTIONS. WE
ALREADY DO THIS WITH THE
BUILDING CODE, SO WE THINK THIS
APPROACH, WHAT IT ALLOWS TO DO
IS THE CITIES TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT WAYS TO MITIGATE THOSE
CONFLICTS. SO IT SHEDS SOME MORE
SUNLIGHT ON THE ISSUE. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. OKAY. I'M JUST
LOOKING AT THE OPPOSITION.
WHETHER OR NOT SHE HAS. WELL,
WE. YEAH OKAY, WE HAVE A MOTION,
AND I DID NOT ASK YOU TO CLOSE
YET, SO PLEASE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, AND I WILL BE
DONE WITH. ALL RIGHT. GET RID OF
ME. YOU CAN KICK ME OUT, ALL
RIGHT, LET'S, TAKE A ROLL CALL
ON THE, BILL. MOTION IS TO PASS
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
OTRO BOGUE. ACHO. BOGUE AYE.
BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. SATO. UMBERG
WAHAB. SIX ZERO. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. IT HAS SIX
VOTES. AND. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WIX. WE FINISHED YOUR
THREE BILLS, AND NOW WE CAN GO
TO ASSEMBLY. MEMBER WARD, WE
HAVE ITEM TEN. ANOTHER. YOU'RE A
YOU'RE A TRIAD ALSO. ALL RIGHT.
SO DO YOU WANT TO GO IN THE
ORDER THAT IT IS THE FILE ORDER
AS THEY'RE LISTED, THAT WOULD BE
GREAT, MADAM CHAIR. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL START LAST DAY. I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF BEING BEFORE SENATE
HOUSING THIS, THIS YEAR. GREAT.
I DO HAVE. WE'LL START WITH ITEM
TEN AB2005 WILL GO TO 11 A,
B2597 WILL GO TO 12 A, B TWO,
EIGHT, NINE THREE. JUST FOR
THOSE WATCHING. OKAY. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. THIS BILL A B 2005
ALLOWS OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES TO UTILIZE THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT TO
CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR OUR CSU STAFF AND FACULTY,
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, ONLY 46%
OF OUR FACULTY AND 53% OF STAFF
CAN AFFORD A HOME IN OUR STATE.
THIS LACK OF ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS INCREASED
THE DIFFICULTY OF RECRUITING AND
RETAINING DIVERSE AND QUALITY
STAFF. CURRENT DATA SHOWS THAT
OVER 9000 OF CURRENT CSU FACULTY
AND STAFF WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
LIVE WITHIN THE PROSPECTIVE
HOUSING BUILT WITH THESE TAX
CREDIT. AND AS WE ALL KNOW,
STAFF AND FACULTY ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE DIVERSITY AND
QUALITY OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM,
NOT ONLY FOR OUR STAFF, BUT FOR
OUR STUDENTS, BY ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE TAUGHT BY STAFF AND
FACULTY THAT REPRESENT THEIR OWN
BACKGROUNDS THROUGH PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION. YOU MAY REMEMBER,
CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO THE LIGHT TECH TO OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
WELL AS OUR K-12 FACULTY. GIVEN
THE RISING COST OF HOUSING THAT
WE HAVE SEEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS, THIS
BILL WOULD PROTECT THESE MEMBERS
OF OUR CSU FACULTY BODY AND
STRENGTHEN OUR UNIVERSITY'S
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
ADEQUATE HOUSING FOR WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. I HAVE AGNES WONG
NICKERSON, THE VP OF BUSINESS
AND FINANCIAL AFFAIRS AND CFO
FOR SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY,
AND ADRIANA GOMEZ FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR TO
SUPPORT WITH ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. OKAY, GREAT, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR SKINNER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
AGNES WONG NICKERSON, VP AND CFO
AT SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON AB 2005, A BILL THAT
WILL PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
HELPING CSU ADDRESS THE HOUSING
NEEDS OF OUR 53,000 FACULTY AND
STAFF MEMBERS. US NEWS AND WORLD
REPORT RECENTLY LISTED SAN DIEGO
AS THE MOST EXPENSIVE PLACE TO
LIVE IN THE US. THE AVERAGE RENT
OF A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IS
ABOUT $2,900 PER MONTH. IN SAN
DIEGO. IN COMPARISON, THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE MONTHLY RENT OF
A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IS JUST
$1,300. THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS NEAR CAMPUS
STRAINS THE FINANCES OF FACULTY
AND STAFF AND CONTRIBUTES TO
LONGER COMMUTES, INCREASED
TRAFFIC CONGESTIONS, AND
ULTIMATELY A LOWER QUALITY OF
LIFE. AS A SYSTEM, WE ALSO RISK
LOSING TALENTED INDIVIDUALS TO
OTHER STATES OR INDUSTRIES,
POTENTIALLY UNDERMINING THE
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE AND
INNOVATIVE RESEARCH CAPABILITIES
OF OUR 23 UNIVERSITIES. THE BILL
SEEKS TO HELP ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES BY EXTENDING TO THE
CSU THE SAME ABILITY K THROUGH
12. SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE TO RECEIVE LOCAL
AND STATE FUNDS OR TAX CREDITS
DESIGNATED FOR AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING. IT ALSO ALLOWS THE CSU
TO PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE RENTAL
UNITS FOR FACULTY AND STAFF
OCCUPANCY. WHEN BUILT ON
UNIVERSITY OWNED LAND. THIS
MEASURE WILL HAVE THE IMPACT OF
OPENING UP LAND ON CSU OWNED
PROPERTY FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN EFFECT, AB 2005 EMPOWERS CSU
TO TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS TO BUILD
ON OUR EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF. ON BEHALF OF
CSU AND 22 OTHER CAMPUSES IN OUR
SYSTEM, I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL,
RECOGNIZING THE PROFOUND IMPACT
THAT THE AVAILABILITY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WILL HAVE ON
OUR DEDICATED FACULTY AND STAFF
WHO EDUCATE AND SERVE THE
STATE'S FUTURE LEADERS AND OUR
AND ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. YOU
YOU'RE HERE FOR TECHNO, ARE YOU
ALSO GO AHEAD. YES. ADRIANA
GÓMEZ WITH THE CSU OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HERE TO
SUPPORT WITH TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. OKAY, LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THEY CAN COME TO THE MIC
. GOOD AFTERNOON. ANGIE MINETTI
HERE IN SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, BRIAN
MIRAMONTES WITH ASTHMA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH ENP ACTION IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE. DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. LET US SEE
IF THERE'S ANY COMMENTS. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR BREAKSPEARE,
BRIEFLY, THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND
I MOVE IT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
SO YOU HAVE A MOTION AND, GO
AHEAD. WE'LL LET YOU CLOSE.
THANK YOU. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. EXCELLENT. WE'VE
GOT A MOTION. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE OKOBO. OKOBO I BLAKE. SPEAR.
BLAKE SPEAR. I CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I PADILLA. PADILLA I.
SATO. UMBERG WAHAB SIX ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON CALL, AND
WE'LL LET YOU GO TO THE NEXT
ONE, WHICH IS AB 2597.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THIS WILL BE ASSEMBLY
BILL 2597 AND GOOD GOVERNMENT
MEASURE INTENDED TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, STAKEHOLDERS AND
HCD HAVE MORE CAPACITY AND TIME
TO PRODUCE, EDIT AND REVIEW
CLOSE TO 200 HOUSING ELEMENTS
WHICH ARE SIMULTANEOUSLY Dð ON
EACH HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE FOR
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITHIN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS, AREA OR SCAG,
THE BILL DOES SO BY CREATING TWO
PHASES OF HOUSING ELEMENT DUE
DATES FOR SCAG SIX MONTHS APART,
SO THE WORKLOAD SPIKE WITHIN HCD
IS MUCH MORE MANAGEABLE FOR ALL
PARTIES AND GOOD QUALITY HOUSING
ELEMENTS CAN BE DRAFTED,
REVIEWED APPROPRIATELY AND
ADOPTED WITH LESS STRAIN IN THE
FUTURE. AT THE SUGGESTION OF THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES, WE ALSO
INCORPORATED SOME RECENT CHANGES
THAT WOULD STREAMLINE THE
APPEALS PROCESS AT THE COGS AND
ALLOW FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS TO RECEIVE THEIR FINAL
ARENA ALLOCATION. ROUGHLY THREE
MONTHS SOONER, AND ULTIMATELY TO
GET STARTED ON THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT SOONER AND HAVE MORE
TIME TO COMPLETE THEM. ONLY AN
EXTREMELY SMALL HANDFUL OF
APPEALS WERE APPROVED. THE TWO
LARGEST COGS IN THE PAST CYCLE,
ONE OUT OF 20 IN A BAG AND TWO
OUT OF 52 IN SCAG. SO IT DOES
NOT APPEAR THAT DEDICATING THREE
MONTHS OF EXTRA TIME TO
ADJUDICATE THEM IS PARTICULARLY
FRUITFUL. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CREATING EFFICIENCIES AND
IMPROVING TIMELINES FOR HOUSING
ELEMENTS TO HELP OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS MEET THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS. AND IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WE HAVE HERE
WITH US, BRADY GORDON FROM THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AT
THE TIME YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SO WE SEE,
THERE'S NO KEY WITNESS TO JUST
TO TECHNICAL, BUT LET'S JUST SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WHO WANTS TO COME TO THE MIC
AND, WEIGH IN. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY GREEN, ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES, APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD TAKING OUR
RECOMMENDED CHANGES AGAIN, THE
GOAL, AS WE'VE DISCUSSED
THROUGHOUT THE DAY, IS TO LOOK
AT TIMELINES TO MAKE IT BETTER
FOR OUR CITIES TO MEET THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENTS. WE THINK THIS
IS ONE ROUTE TO DO THAT GIVEN
THE CONCERNS NOW, WE HOPE THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP IN A LONG
WINDED PROCESS TO LOOK AT THE
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS AS A
WHOLE TO MAKE SURE OUR CITIES
ARE GOOD. SO HERE TO COPY ANY,
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU GUYS HAVE. THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT. LET'S SEE ANY OTHER
ADD ONS OKAY. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NONE REGISTERED. BUT JUST IN
CASE, ALL RIGHT. AND DO ANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR OR THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES? ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
PADILLA AND, WE DID HEAR CLOSE.
AND I WOULD RESPECT ONLY IF YOU
WANT TO ADD ANYTHING MORE.
AGAIN, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. OKAY, THEN WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL. MOTIONS
DO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. OKOBO SORRY. THIS
IS 2597. NO ZUCKERBERG. NO.
BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE PADILLA.
PADILLA AYE. SERRATO. BURKE.
WAHAB. THAT'S 5 TO 1. ALL RIGHT.
GREAT. SO NOW WE HAVE YOUR LAST
BILL. AB 2893.
THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, LET ME START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
ALIGN WITH MY FOCUS AND GOALS OF
THIS LEGISLATION. AS CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO NAVIGATE THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR UNHOUSED
POPULATION, ALONG WITH THE STATE
HOUSING CRISIS, WE'VE LEARNED
THAT THESE ISSUES ARE OFTEN
INTERTWINED. MANY OF UNHOUSED
CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT HOMELESS
DUE TO THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS. THIS CREATES A
NEGATIVE AND UNSUSTAINABLE
SITUATION THAT CAN OFTEN LEAD
THEM TO DRUG USE AND MAJOR
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS. AND ONCE
A PERSON BEGINS STRUGGLING WITH
ADDICTION AND THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS THAT COME WITH THAT, IT
BECOMES HARDER AND HARDER FOR
THEM TO FIND HOUSING. SOBER
LIVING FACILITIES ARE OFTEN TOO
STRICT AND UNSTABLE FOR THEIR
SITUATION, AND TEMPORARY HOUSING
IS NOT LONG TERM ENOUGH FOR THEM
TO ADEQUATELY NAVIGATE OUT OF
THEIR ADDICTION. ONE OPTION THAT
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR PEOPLE WHO
FIND THEMSELVES IN THIS POSITION
IS RECOVERY HOUSING, WHICH
FOCUSES ON TREATMENT BUT NOT TO
THE EXTENT OF CLINICAL SETTINGS.
RECOVERY HOUSING ALLOWS
FLEXIBILITY AND IS STABLE ENOUGH
TO PROVIDE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
PEOPLE CAN SUCCESSFULLY PROGRESS
OUT OF THEIR ADDICTION. OUR BILL
HERE. AB 2093 ESTABLISHED A
STATE CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
RECOVERY HOUSES THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. RECOVERY HOUSES HAVE
PROVEN SUCCESSFUL WHEN
CONCURRENTLY RUN AND PAIRED WITH
HOUSING FIRST PRINCIPLES, WHICH
ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
PLACED INTO HOUSING AS AN EARLY
STEP SO THEY HAVE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT TO MOVE FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING THEIR ISSUES. THE
STABILITY AND SERVICES PROVIDED,
AS WELL AS A REQUIREMENT THAT
RESIDENTS ARE GENUINELY WORKING
THROUGH THEIR ADDICTION, WILL
CREATE A POSITIVE AND PRODUCTIVE
ENVIRONMENT AND PROVIDE A
GENUINE SOLUTION TO OUR STATE'S
HOUSING AND PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
. THE CERTIFICATION STANDARDIZES
CARE AND REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL
RECOVERY HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA,
WHILE ALSO MAKING AVAILABLE AS A
TOOL THE STATE CAN USE TO
ADDRESS TREATING OUR UNHOUSED
POPULATION. I HAVE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2893, AMY HÌNH
SHAIKH, WHO IS ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR, THE CHER
COLLABORATIVE HOUSING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, HONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS AMY
HINES-IKE WITH WILDCAT
CONSULTING, AND I'M REPRESENTING
CHER COLLABORATIVE HOUSING SHARE
. COLLABORATIVE HOUSING HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR 30 YEARS, AND
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
OPERATING 40 SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITY RESIDENCES IN THE LA
AREA AND CULVER CITY, AND LONG
BEACH. AND THEIR MODEL IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT. IT HAS AN
INCREDIBLE SUCCESS RATE AND WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT FOLKS
DESERVE A CHANCE. AND WE'RE
GIVING THEM THIS CHANCE WITH
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
OUR HONORABLE AUTHOR FOR LEADING
THE WAY IN THIS, FASHION. AND
WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. LET'S SEE, ANY ADD ONS IN
SUPPORT COMPANY IN THE WORLD?
OKAY. ANY OTHERS? ALL RIGHT. DO
WE HAVE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
ANY TWEENERS. OKAY. BEFORE I ASK
FOR, OUR COLLEAGUES COMMENTS,
AND, I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENT. I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF OUR HOUSING FIRST
POLICY, AND I DO NOT WANT IT
ERODED. HOWEVER I DO THINK IT'S
LEGITIMATE. THERE ARE,
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE, WHO ARE
HAVE ACHIEVED SOBRIETY OR HAVE
DEALT WITH THEIR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AND WANT TO HAVE A
SETTING WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE LESS TEMPTED. I CAN SUPPORT
THAT, BUT NOT IN A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE THAT SETTING WOULD, IN
EFFECT, CAUSE THEM TO LOSE THEIR
HOUSING IF, LIKE MOST PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER, IF
THEY FALL OFF THEIR SOBRIETY, WE
KNOW THAT FOR MANY AND MOST
FOLKS WHO ARE DEALING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER, THEY MAY
EXPERIENCE MANY TIMES WITH
RELAPSES. WHAT, OF COURSE WE
HOPE. AND THE PURPOSE OF ANY OF
OUR SUPPORTIVE CIRCUMSTANCES IS
TO GIVE THEM THE SUPPORT AND THE
CONDITIONS SO THAT THEY COULD
ACHIEVE. WE HOPE THAT PERMANENT,
THEIR, THEIR ABILITY TO LEAVE
THAT, ADDICTION PERMANENTLY. BUT
IT IS A DIFFICULT THING FOR
ANYONE WHO HAS STRUGGLED WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER KNOWS IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT AND WE DO NOT
WANT TO HAVE ANY EROSION IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THEN THEY ARE
LEFT UNHOUSED. SO I APPRECIATE,
OUR ABILITY TO THREAD THAT
NEEDLE, BUT TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS, WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE
AND MOST IMPORTANT THING. SO,
THAT'S WHAT THE AMENDMENTS DO,
PLUS THE TECHNICAL ONES THAT YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE IDENTIFIED AS
TO, YOU KNOW, NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE IN LINE WITH
OTHER STATUTES. SO, I DON'T KNOW
IF ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO MAKE
COMMENTS OR GO AHEAD, SENATOR
CHAIR. SURE. SO I'M VERY AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED, I ECHO THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH PEOPLE
WHO, WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE, WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY THEY DON'T IMPOSE ANY
TRIGGERS THAT COULD HELP, ALLOW
THEM TO, TO RELAPSE, WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE FACILITIES, THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TO ADDRESS HERE,
ONE THING IS RELAPSE ICING, AND
ANOTHER ONE IS CREATING AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE IT'S
PERMISSIVE OF USING, YOU KNOW,
SMOKING OR DRINKING OR DRUGS,
WHERE, YOU KNOW, YOU CONTINUE
TO, TO DO THAT. DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA AS TO WHETHER OR NOT WHERE
DO YOU WHERE DO THESE FACILITIES
STAND WITH REGARDS TO ONE THING?
IS BEING RELAPSING, COMING HOME
AND SAYING, OKAY, I'M GOING TO
TRY MY BEST. AND ANOTHER ONE IS
SAYING, OKAY, YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
DRINK OR I CAN'T IMAGINE DOING
DRUGS IN THE FACILITY THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET WELL IN.
BUT, NOT BEING AS STRICT WITH
WITH THAT COMPONENT. YEAH THANK
YOU. IT'S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION
TO TEASE OUT SO THAT WE'RE CLEAR
BECAUSE IT COMES UP THIS
QUESTION WOULD COME UP OFTEN.
AND RECOVERY HOUSES, YOU KNOW,
WOULD NOT HAVE POLICIES THAT
WOULD CONDONE OR PERMIT, ON SITE
CONSUMPTION OR USE OF, OR OF
DRUGS OR OTHER RULES WHICH ARE
ESTABLISHED WHICH ARE MEANT TO
BE ADHERED TO. NOW, THAT SAID,
IF SOMEBODY PRESENTED THEMSELVES
OR CAME INTO AN ENVIRONMENT,
WHAT I THINK DISTINGUISHES US IN
THIS SITUATION, AND SORT OF
FOLLOWING A HOUSING FIRST MODEL,
WHICH, BY THE WAY, DOES NOT MEAN
HOUSING ONLY OF COURSE, WE WANT
TO HAVE THE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THERE. IS THAT IT SHOULDN'T BE
JUST RIGHT THERE IN THAT MOMENT
AND ON ON AS A SINGULAR REASON,
A REASON TO EXPEL ANYBODY AND
THROW THEM BACK OUT ONTO THE
STREETS. RIGHT. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS A
CONSTRUCTIVE WAY TO BE ABLE TO
REACH AROUND THAT INDIVIDUAL AND
SUPPORT THEM, AND THAT DOES
INCLUDE IT, ESPECIALLY IF THEY
WERE BECOMING DISRUPTIVE OR
INFLUENTIAL ON ANY OF THE OTHER
PARTICIPANTS WITHIN THAT, THAT
SETTING, THAT THERE SHOULD BE
MAYBE A BETTER LOCATION THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE A
WARM HANDOFF, A MORE APPROPRIATE
SETTING FOR THEM TO DEAL WITH
ANY ISSUES THEY HAVE IN THE
MOMENT, SO IT IS, I THINK, TO
THE CHAIR'S POINT, YOU'RE REALLY
TRYING TO THREAD A NEEDLE HERE,
THAT IS MAKING SURE THAT BY
FOLLOWING SOME OF THESE EXAMPLES
THAT THEY WOULD BE BETTER
QUALIFIED, POTENTIALLY TO
COMPETE FOR CERTAIN AREAS OF
FUNDING WHERE HOUSING FIRST IS A
REQUIREMENT, BUT BRINGS THEM UP
TO A PLACE OF CERTIFICATION THAT
DOES NOT ALSO UNDERCUT, THE
IMPORTANT, ENVIRONMENT AND
IMPORTANT STANDARDS THAT WE
HAVE, FOR SUCCESSFUL ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL PARTICIPANTS. THIS
REMINDS ME A LOT OF SENATOR
NEAL'S BILL, THAT WE JUST HEARD
JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS BACK,
VERY KIND OF SIMILAR. AND THAT'S
WHY I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES. THANK YOU OF YOUR
GOAL. THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE TWO
OUTCOMES, MAIN OUTCOMES YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR WITH THE BILL IS THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS ITSELF.
AND THEN ULTIMATELY QUALIFYING
THE CERTIFIED RESIDENCES FOR
STATE HOMELESS FUNDING. IS THAT
CORRECT THAT THEY WOULD THEN BE
ABLE TO COMPETE, OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW, MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED, AS WE KNOW, AND
OUR BUDGET CONVERSATIONS. BUT,
IT WOULD ALLOW THEM ACCESS AND
BEALL ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO,
SUPPORT THEMSELVES. SO, SO THE
ONLY THE ONLY CONCERN I HAVE AND
I JUST ASK YOU TO SPEAK TO IT
IS, AND IT COMES FROM DOING SOME
WORK IN THIS SPACE LEGISLATIVELY
AND OTHERWISE IS, WHAT
CONFIDENCE DO YOU HAVE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE? QUOTE,
FOLKS WHO ARE QUALIFIED TO MAKE
THE ASSESSMENT AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THE SOBER LIVING ENVIRONMENT
OF THE RESIDENCE IS CERTIFIABLE
OR NOT, ARE THEY GOING TO DO
RULEMAKING? AND THEN WHO MAKES
THAT DETERMINATION? WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGED WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT, I'LL ASK MY, OUR SPONSOR TO
PROVIDE SOME OF HER KNOWLEDGE ON
THOSE CONVERSATIONS, WELL, THERE
THERE ARE, CERTIFICATIONS THAT
DHS ALREADY PROVIDES FOR,
HOUSING THAT, IS IT'S
PERMISSIBLE TO USE MEDICATION
AND MEDICATION THAT IS
ADMINISTERED. AND WE'RE A STEP
DOWN FROM THAT. SO WE DO NOT IN
ANY WAY PROVIDE MEDICATION. IT'S
A PEER SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY
RESIDENCE. SO THEIR CARE IS
COMMUNITY SUPPORT AND, PEER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES, SO IT'S
JUST THE CERTIFICATION THAT DHS
ALREADY HAS, BUT IT'S A STEP
DOWN SERVICE AND THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE. SO IT IS THOUGH A
LEGITIMATE, INTERESTING POINT OF
INQUIRY THAT WE DID WHEN WE WERE
CRAFTING THE BILL BECAUSE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES, DSS HAS ONE AND THEN
HCD IT WAS KIND OF LIKE WE ARE
IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE. SO IT
SEEMED NATURAL TO PUT IT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OR DSS OR HCD. AND SO
WE LANDED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE A STEP DOWN IN
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE, BECAUSE
WE DO KNOW THAT THEY ALREADY
HAVE THOSE EXPERTS THAT, PROVIDE
THE CERTIFICATIONS FOR ANYBODY
THAT ADMINISTERS MEDICATION, AND
WE DO NOT. SO IT'S A STEP DOWN
IN THAT WAY. YEAH. AND I MEAN,
THE CONCERN IS, AND MAYBE IT'S
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION, I THINK
IT'S WORTH SUPPORTING THE BILL
TO GET THIS MOVING. BUT, THE
CONCERN IS THAT'S ON MY MIND,
WITH DHS IS THAT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THEY HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
ESSENTIALLY, GIVEN THE SCIENCE
OF RECOVERY WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE TO BE ABLE TO COME IN
AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
RESIDENCE IS SUITABLE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIVING THAT EXPERIENCE.
IT'S JUST THE NATURE OF RECOVERY
. AND GIVEN THAT I'M I'M NOT
CLEAR, HAVING RUN SOME
LEGISLATION MYSELF, THAT, YOU
KNOW, TRIES TO NAVIGATE DC'S
ABILITY TO, TO UNDERSTAND THAT,
THAT, THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
THAT INTERNAL EXPERTISE. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS THAT WOULD CERTIFY
FACILITIES OR RESIDENCES FOR,
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, FOR EXAMPLE,
OR THE APPLICATION OF MEDICATION
ARE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE
QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE WHAT KIND
OF ENVIRONMENT SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
BE IN TO, TO STAY IN RECOVERY.
AND, IN AND SO WHAT COMPLICATES
THE ISSUE OFTENTIMES IS THAT THE
RECOVERY, THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
RECOVERY COMMUNITY AND INCLUDING
ALCOHOLISM, ARE ARE PROMISED
CONFIDENTIALITY AND THEIR
PROMISED IN THESE FACILITIES
THAT THEY'RE OPINIONS WON'T BE
POLITICIZED. SO IT'S VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE A
SITUATION WHERE, YOU KNOW, A
STATE AGENCY IS COMING IN IF
THEY DON'T HAVE, THE REAL
KNOWLEDGE TO, TO, TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED TO EVEN DO
THE SIMPLE THINGS THAT WE DO
HERE IN TERMS OF PUBLIC COMMENT
OR THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. HOW DO YOU
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN GUARANTEED
ANONYMITY? HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
YOU KNOW, HOW DO YOU GET THEM
INVOLVED IN RULEMAKING, SO IT'S
A TOUGH ISSUE. I'M NOT
SUGGESTING I'M NOT TRYING TO
COMPLICATE YOUR EFFORTS HERE,
BUT I JUST WANTED YOU TO
UNDERSTAND WHY I WAS ASKING THE
QUESTION. AND CAN I SHARE
SOMETHING ABOUT HOW SHARE DOES
IT? IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S
NOT WRITTEN INTO THE BILL, BUT
HOW. SHARE COLLABORATIVE
HOUSING, SOLICITS THAT, GIVE AND
TAKE IN THAT, COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS IS BECAUSE ALL OF THEIR
STAFF HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE WHAT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
GOING THROUGH IT HAVE BEEN
THROUGH, AND THEY'RE EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAS BEEN ON A
RECOVERY JOURNEY AND HAS GONE
THROUGH ALL OF THAT DIFFICULT
STUFF. SO IT'S NOT THAT THEY'RE
VIOLATING PEOPLE'S,
CONFIDENTIALITY, BUT THEY ARE
SOLICITING FEEDBACK AND THEY DO
TAKE IT TO HEART VERY SERIOUSLY.
SO, AND ANOTHER POINT ABOUT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY IS OBVIOUSLY
DHS. THEY HAVE ON THEIR, STEP UP
SERVICES. THEY ALL HAVE HIPAA
REGULATIONS AND THE THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY'S PRIVACY IS
RESPECTED. SO THAT'S THAT'S
ANOTHER MATTER. YEAH NO I
APPRECIATE THANK YOU THROUGH THE
CHAIR. I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES. AND I WASN'T
NECESSARILY EXPECTING, A
COMFORTING RESPONSE JUST BECAUSE
OF MY, YOU KNOW, INTERACTIONS
WITH DCS, BUT I, I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF THESE
RESIDENCES THAT ARE TRYING TO BE
CERTIFIED WILL HAVE REALLY GOOD
PEOPLE DOING REALLY GOOD WORK,
PROBABLY MOST OF WHOM THEMSELVES
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE. I JUST
WORRY ABOUT HAVING A STATE
AGENCY COME IN THAT DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE QUALITIES
AND CRITERIA ARE. YOU KNOW, AS A
CERTIFYING AGENCY, I DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF CONFIDENCE. GOING BACK
TO MY QUESTION WAS HOW MUCH
CONFIDENCE DO YOU HAVE? THAT WAS
REALLY THE QUESTION IN THEIR
ABILITY TO PULL THAT OFF AND TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
CREATE, YOU KNOW, REALLY
HARDSHIP ON, ON SOME OF THE
APPLICANTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING IN, YOU KNOW, WHO IN FACT
, ARE RUNNING REALLY GOOD
OPERATIONS BUT CAN'T GET CAN'T
GET THROUGH THAT, THAT
BUREAUCRATIC CERTIFICATION
PROCESS BECAUSE THERE'S A GAP IN
UNDERSTANDING IN TERMS OF, YOU
KNOW, BEST PRACTICES AND THE
QUALITY OF WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE. BUT THAT SAID, I RAISED
THE ISSUE. I JUST FELT LIKE I
NEEDED TO SORT OF PUT THAT OUT
THERE, YOU KNOW, WOULDN'T
WOULDN'T BOTHER ME IF THE OTHERS
SAID, WELL, MAYBE THAT'S A
SUBSEQUENT BILL OR SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO MONITOR. BUT I
DO THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
MONITORED CLOSELY IN TERMS OF
OUTCOMES. AND IF I HAD MY
DRUTHERS, I WOULD HAVE SOME KIND
OF A REVIEW PROCESS IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD IF YOU REALLY WANT
THIS TO WORK, YOU KNOW, HONESTLY
THAT THAT COMES BACK IN REPORTS,
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR AS
TO WHAT THE EFFICACY OF ALL THIS
IS, IS, IS ARE THEY, IN FACT
CERTIFYING RESIDENCES THAT, YOU
KNOW, ARE OTHERWISE IN GOOD
STANDING WITH THE COMMUNITY? OR
IS THAT PROCESS BREAKING DOWN?
BECAUSE BECAUSE I'M FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. THAT'S THAT'S WHY
I'M RAISING THAT. ANYWAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. CERTAINLY. LET ME SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WITH, OKAY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND I'LL JUST RESPOND BRIEFLY,
TO THAT POINT, BECAUSE THIS BILL
IS ABOUT UPPING THE STANDARDS
AND REALLY TRYING TO, SEE THESE
AS A MODEL THAT CAN BE MORE
EFFECTIVE, ESPECIALLY WHEN DONE
RIGHT, BUT AS WE DO OFTEN WITH
OUR LEGISLATION, YOU KNOW, I
WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW THAT,
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THAT MYSELF
AS WELL. SHOULD THIS BE
SUCCESSFUL, TO SEE HOW IT
IMPLEMENTS, TO THE INTENT OF
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE AND WHERE NECESSARY, MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE FUTURE IS
SOMETHING I'M VERY OPEN TO
WITHOUT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL DO
A ROLL CALL. MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. SENATOR SKINNER, I
SKINNER I H.OHBA. NO. ACHO
BOGUE. NO. BLAKE SPEER. BLAKE.
SPEER I CABALLERO. CORTEZ CORTEZ
I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I PADILLA.
PADILLA I CIERTO. CIERTO. NO.
BURKE WAHAB 5 TO 2. THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. OKAY, SO
OUR NEXT ITEM IS A ITEM. FOR. SO
WHAT MEANING DO YOU WANT TO OPEN
THE ROLL ON BILLS. I DON'T HAVE
EVERYBODY BACK IN I DON'T HAVE
IF YOU DON'T MIND. I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO COME IN AND OUT, BUT
I'LL HAVE TO OPEN THE ROLL
AGAIN. SO I WOULD LIKE TO
PROCEED AND GET MORE BILLS DONE.
OKAY. APPRECIATE THAT, LET'S GO
TO ITEM 14 AB 2159 MAINE SHINE.
OH, YOU CAN THANK YOU SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AB 2159 AUTHORIZES
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS TO
USE AN ELECTRONIC VOTING SYSTEM
FOR SPECIFIC ASSOCIATION
BUSINESSES AND PARTICULAR BOARD
ELECTIONS, AND APPROVED AND
APPROVING APPROVING GOVERNING
DOCUMENTS. THE DAVIS-STIRLING
ACT, WHICH GOVERNS CIDS,
OUTLINES THE RIGHTS AND DUTIES
OF ASSOCIATIONS AND THEIR
MEMBERS, INCLUDING THE ELECTION
PROCESS, WHICH IS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTED THROUGH A PAPER AND
MAIL BASED SYSTEM SIMILAR TO
CALIFORNIA'S SECRET BALLOT
PROCESS, ELECTRONIC VOTING
ADDRESSES A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN
CURRENT ASSOCIATION ELECTIONS.
VOTER APATHY. WITH MANY
ASSOCIATIONS STRUGGLING TO
OBTAIN EVEN A QUORUM. AB 2159 IS
PERMISSIVE, GIVING ASSOCIATIONS
THE OPTION TO ADOPT ELECTRONIC
VOTING. THE PROCESS FOR
AUTHORIZING ELECTRONIC VOTING
WILL BE PART OF THE RULE
ADOPTION PROCESS, WHICH REQUIRES
NOTIFYING MEMBERS BEFORE TAKING
A VOTE AND PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS TO
OVERTURN THE BOARD'S DECISION.
IF THEY DISAGREE. AB 2159 DOES
NOT CHANGE EXISTING ELECTION
PROCEDURES OUTLINED IN LAW. IT
INCLUDES MULTIPLE NOTIFICATIONS
TO MEMBERS ON HOW TO OPT OUT,
INCLUDE IN THE OPERATIONAL RULES
DURING THE ELECTION PROCESS, AND
ANNUALLY THROUGH THE MEMBER
NOTICE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS LOUIS
BROWN, REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE THE, ME
TWOS WANT TO COME UP TO THE MIC?
OH, I'M SORRY YOU DIDN'T HAVE
THE LEAD WITNESS SPEAK YET.
OKAY, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. LOUIS BROWN, HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE,
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, JUST BRIEFLY, THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE
2000, THE FIRST STATE AUTHORIZED
THIS FOR COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
IN 2005, LAST YEAR, NEVADA
BECAME THE 27TH STATE TO
AUTHORIZE THE USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY FOR HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS. AND LIKE MR.
MAIENSCHEIN SAID, THIS IS A
PERMISSIVE, ELECTION THAT COULD
BE TAKEN BY THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION, WE DID RUN A
SIMILAR BILL IN 2013, AND WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED SINCE 2013 ARE
MANY OF THE ELEMENTS THAT YOU
CAN FIND IN THE BILL. WE'VE
ADDED VARIOUS PROTECTIONS FOR,
PRIVACY AND OTHER TRANSACTION. A
THIRD PARTY INSPECTOR MUST
OPERATE THE ELECTION, AND WE'VE
ADDED OTHER MEASURES IN THERE TO
ALLOW FOR MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS VOTE, WHAT WE HAVE ALSO
DONE IS THAT, WE'VE CREATED THIS
PROCESS AND WE'VE LEARNED FROM
THESE OTHER STATES IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND MORE
INCLUSIVE. SO WITH THAT, THE
ONLY OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT THE ONE THING THAT WE'VE
SEEN SINCE 2013 IS THE EXACT
SAME OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND
THE EXACT SAME MESSAGE IS THAT,
NO, THIS TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T WORK
AND THIS TECHNOLOGY SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED. WE THINK WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THESE 27 OTHER
STATES. WE'VE ADDED THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY,
AND WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. YES,
OUR ME TOOS, JENNIFER WADA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS, WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF KHÎI AND JUST
UNDERSCORE THAT VOTER APATHY IS
A REAL PROBLEM IN ASSOCIATIONS.
THE LARGE MAJORITY OF HOMEOWNERS
VOICES ARE NOT HEARD, AND THIS
BILL WOULD INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU. ANY OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE Þ THERE IS
OPPOSITION. COME ON. NOT
NECESSARILY. CAN I HAVE A
MICROPHONE? THERE SHOULD BE ONLY
TWO AT THE DESK. THANK YOU. CAN
YOU GO AHEAD? GOOD AFTERNOON,
SENATOR SKINNER AND MEMBERS,
OPPOSITION AT THE DESK. YES. GO
AHEAD. PROCEED. WE WILL BE BRIEF
. GO AHEAD. I'M MARJORIE MURRAY,
SENATOR FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW. GOOD AFTERNOON,
SENATOR SKINNER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, WE HAVE HEARD A
GREAT DEAL OF DISCUSSION THIS
AFTERNOON. I WAS REALLY QUITE
STRUCK BY THE DISCUSSIONS ON ON
THE LACK OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE NEED TO HAVE
ADEQUATE HOUSING ELEMENTS TO GET
HOUSING BUILT TO PUT PEOPLE IN
HOUSING. BUT THE MISSING PIECE
HERE IS THAT ONCE PEOPLE GET
INTO HOUSING, THEY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP IT. AND THIS IS
WHERE VOTING BOARD DIRECTORS
MAKES A HUGE IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES. THIS COMMITTEE HAS LOOKED
AT MANY HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS,
ELECTION BILLS. THERE'S A REASON
FOR THAT BECAUSE OF ITS IMPACT
ON HOUSING, THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DETERMINED THAT THESE ARE NOT
SOCIAL CLUBS. HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS. THEY ARE ANOTHER
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT. THEY HAVE
QUASI GOVERNMENTAL AUTHORITIES.
THEY SET ASSESSMENTS. MANY OF
WHICH ARE UNAFFORDABLE, AND
DRIVE PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
SO, THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
CLAIM THAT THIS IS A TRUSTWORTHY
SYSTEM OF SEATING. BOARD
DIRECTORS. WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE FROM VERIFIED VOTING AND
ALSO A RETIRED PROFESSOR OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE FROM UCLA TO
TALK ABOUT THE MANY HAZARDS OF
INTERNET VOTING, STARTING WITH
THE FACT THAT IT BASICALLY
ELIMINATES THE SECRET BALLOT,
WHICH IS THE BEDROCK OF VOTING.
OUR FIRST WITNESS IS C.J. COLES,
YOU CANNOT HAVE YOU ARE THE
FIRST WITNESS. YOU NOW HAVE A
SECOND WITNESS. THE NEXT PERSON
CAN ONLY BE A MEAN TO. THAT'S
THE RULES OF THE COMMITTEE. SO
YEAH. YEAH. WHICH ONE DO YOU
WANT TO HAVE? SPEAK AS THE
PRIMARY, OKAY. GO AHEAD. A
LITTLE CONFUSED, I GUESS. I'M.
YOU'RE GOING TO TESTIFY. I'M
JUST GOING TO MUTE. THAT'S OKAY.
AND YOU ONLY HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME, SO PLEASE START.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SIT AT THE
TABLE, BUT YOU CAN. WELL GIVEN
CONFLICTING ADVICE, THERE. SO.
THANK YOU. OKAY I'M DAVID
JEFFERSON, I'M A COMPUTER
SCIENTIST HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
INTERNET VOTING ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL. I AM A FORMER PROFESSOR OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE AT UCLA, NOW
RETIRED FROM LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LABORATORY. I'VE
ADVISED FIVE SECRETARIES OF
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON VARIOUS
VOTING TECHNOLOGY ISSUES AND
SPENT 25 YEARS STUDYING INTERNET
VOTING IN PARTICULAR, AND MY
MESSAGE IS SIMPLE THERE IS
UNIVERSAL CONSENSUS AMONG THE
COMPUTER SECURITY COMMUNITY THAT
NO CURRENT INTERNET VOTING
TECHNOLOGIES CAN GUARANTEE BOTH
PRIVACY AND INTEGRITY. HENCE THE
SECURITY AND PRIVACY
REQUIREMENTS FOR HÌ ELECTIONS.
IN THIS BILL JUST CANNOT BE MET,
REGARDLESS OF THE CLAIMS OF
VENDORS, IT WOULD REQUIRE
OVERCOMING SEVERAL FUNDAMENTAL
SECURITY PROBLEMS THAT
RESEARCHERS DO NOT EXPECT TO
SOLVE IN IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
INTERNET VOTING IS ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO UNDETECTABLE
BALLOT MANIPULATION AND PRIVACY
VIOLATION BY WHOEVER COLLECTS
THE BALLOTS AND COUNTS THEM.
ELECTRONIC BALLOTS ARE INVISIBLE
, SO THERE'S NO MEANINGFUL WAY
FOR A VOTER TO OBSERVE BALLOT
HANDLING AND NO POSSIBILITY OF A
MEANINGFUL POST-ELECTION AUDIT.
ALL OF THIS WILL LIKELY GIVE
SOME PEOPLE YET ANOTHER REASON,
PERHAPS FALSELY, TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT RIGGED ELECTIONS. WITHOUT
PAPER BALLOTS, THERE WILL BE NO
EVIDENCE TO REFUTE IT. THESE ARE
NOT JUST MY OPINIONS. THE
NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE,
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, CISA, THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF STANDARDS AND
TECHNOLOGY, NIST, AND DOZENS OF
ACADEMIC STUDIES HAVE ALL
OPPOSED INTERNET VOTING. THE
FEDERAL EAC HAS NOT EVEN TRIED
TO CREATE STANDARDS FOR INTERNET
VOTING, NOR HAS ANY STATE,
BECAUSE IT'S WELL KNOWN THAT
THEY WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
MEET. THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
BILL ARGUE THAT SINCE OTHER
STATES ALLOW HOA INTERNET VOTING
, WE SHOULD TOO. WITH RESPECT, I
THINK THIS IS BACKWARDS
THINKING. CALIFORNIA IS THE
NATIONAL CENTER OF TECHNOLOGY
AND SECURITY EXPERTISE, AND
OTHER STATES USUALLY FOLLOW OUR
LEAD ON REGARDING ELECTION
TECHNOLOGY, I DON'T THINK YOU
WOULD WANT YOUR OWN ELECTIONS,
GOVERNED BY INTERNET VOTING. AND
I HOPE YOU WILL NOT INTRODUCE IT
IN HOA ELECTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NOW, THE,
YOU CAN BE THE ADD ON OR OTHERS
MAY ALSO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS JAY COLES.
I AM HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
NONPARTISAN, NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION VERIFIED VOTING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? THERE
ARE. YOU CAN COME TO THE MIC.
YES. THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS IS A
REGISTERED OPPONENT. OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. ALL
RIGHT. MEMBERS ON, TO DISCUSS
NOW, IF YOU HAVE. GO AHEAD.
SORRY. THAT'S OKAY. SENATOR SATO
, PLEASE PROCEED. SO WHILE I
SYMPATHIZE WITH, THE, OPPONENTS
OF THE BILL AND SHARE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SECURITY, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHO WAS, ALEJO'S
ARE NOTORIOUS FOR NOT HAVING
ANYBODY PARTICIPATE. AND SO THE
MAIN DECISION MAKING GETS DONE
BY THE THREE BOARD MEMBERS OR
HOWEVER BOARD MEMBERS THEY HAVE,
AND MAYBE A HANDFUL OF OTHER
PEOPLE THAT WIND UP
PARTICIPATING WITH RULES THAT
ARE ADJUSTED TO ALLOW PERHAPS
THAT AMOUNT OF PEOPLE TO MAKE
MAJOR DECISIONS FOR A, FOR AN
ENTIRE HOA, I LIVED THIS THROUGH
EXPERIENCE, AND THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO, BE ABLE TO GET A FLAVOR
FROM EVERYBODY IN THE COMPLEX
FOR WHAT THEY WANT IN THEIR FOR
THEIR HOA. AND RIGHT NOW IT'S
NOT BEING DONE. AND, AND I THINK
THIS IS A, A GOOD WAY OF TRYING,
TO, TO GET THAT PARTICIPATION
UP, IF THEY FIND THAT THERE'S
FRAUD AND ABUSE, THEN THEY CAN
CHANGE IT AND, AND STOP IT. THE
HOA BOARD WILL HAVE THAT ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND WITH THAT I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE THE BILL. THE WAY
THIS WAS WRITTEN SEEMED LIKE GO
AHEAD, SENATOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AB 1458, 2023
PASSED LAST YEAR, WHICH WOULD
HAVE LOWERED THE QUORUM
REQUIREMENT FOR AN ELECTION OF
AN HOA BOARD OF DIRECTORS, IT
ONLY HAD ONE VOTE. I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS AS TO, HOW WE HAD ANY
DATA YET TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S AN ACTUAL NEED TO EXPAND
THIS A LITTLE FURTHER TO ENGAGE
MORE. IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
IN 27 STATES AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK WITHIN
YOUR OWN DISTRICTS, I WOULD
IMAGINE YOUR HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS REPORT TO YOU THAT
THEY JUST CAN'T GET PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY. BILL.
YEAH SO EVEN SO, IT'S BEEN AN
ONGOING. YES IT'S BEEN AN
ONGOING PROBLEM OF THEM HAVING,
YOU KNOW, 1 OR 2 PEOPLE VOTE,
PERIOD. SO YOU KNOW, WE ALL AS A
BODY, ALL OF US AS A BODY, WE
DID WE WANTED WE HAVE HAD A
POLICY THAT WE WANT TO INCREASE
VOTE. WE DID MAIL IN BALLOTS,
FOR EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW, HAVING
MORE PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN THE
OUTCOMES OF THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
ADS OR IN THEIR ELECTIONS IS A
GOOD THING. YOU KNOW, AT LEAST I
THINK I MEAN, THAT'S MY INTENT
BEHIND THIS IS MORE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS IS A BETTER THING,
NOT A WORSE THING. SENATOR
OKUBO, DID YOU WANT TO ASK THAT
QUESTION OF THE OPPOSITION OR
NOT? SURE. WE'LL GIVE THE
OPPOSITION TO RESPOND. I'M
SORRY. DO YOU WANT ME TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF VOTER
PARTICIPATION? WELL, WE JUST HAD
A BILL THAT ACTUALLY ADDRESSED
THE PARTICIPATION, QUORUM. I'M
JUST GOING TO CURIOUS. DO WE
NEED TO WAIT A LITTLE LONGER
BEFORE WE ADDRESS THIS AND
EXPAND IT A LITTLE FURTHER, SEE
IF THIS BILL, THIS BILL THAT
JUST PASSED IN 23, IF IT
ACTUALLY MAKES AN IMPACT ON THE
PARTICIPATION. WELL THAT'S A
VERY GOOD QUESTION, BECAUSE
THERE'S ACTUALLY A FOLLOW ON
BILL TO THAT BILL THIS SESSION.
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES IS THAT WE
SEE A COMPLETE INCOMPATIBLE
INCOMPATIBILITY BETWEEN INTERNET
VOTING AND QUORUM A LOWERING
THIS QUORUM. HOW DO YOU EVEN
ESTABLISH QUORUM IN THE FIRST
PLACE? IF YOU'RE USING THIS
INVISIBLE SYSTEM WHERE THERE IS
NO PAPER BALLOTING? SO THAT'S
THAT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES AND I
THINK VERIFIED VOTING ALSO WOULD
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE THAT THAT
THERE IS PLENTY OF EVIDENCE THAT
INTERNET VOTING DOES NOT
ACTUALLY INCREASE IN THE OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE BEEN CITED. IT
DOES NOT INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION. IN FACT, ONE OF
THE VERY SERIOUS DEFECTS IN THIS
BILL IS THAT IT IS OPT OUT. IN
OTHER WORDS, VOTERS HAVE TO MAKE
A DECISION 90 DAYS AHEAD OF THE
ELECTION ON WHAT THE PROCEDURES
ARE FOR CHOOSING NOT TO USE
INTERNET VOTING. IT'S A VERY
CONVOLUTED PROCESS. SO THE I
THINK THE EFFECT OF 2159 IS
ACTUALLY NOT ONLY GOING TO
REDUCE PARTICIPATION, BUT
ACTUALLY DISENFRANCHIZE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THE DAIS OR COMMENTS? OKAY.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE A
MOTION YET. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
CORTEZ HAS MOVED, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. OH. HAD YOU ALREADY
MOVED, YOU SAID HÌ. OH, SORRY.
MOVED IT. OKAY. APOLOGIES. I
WILL HAVE IT. THEN. RECORDED
THAT IT'S A SENATOR WHO MOVED
IT. I DIDN'T CATCH THAT. ALL
RIGHT, SO LET'S DO A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY. SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. OKUBO BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. I
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. SATO UMBERG.
WAHAB. IT'S 5 TO 0. THANK YOU.
MADAM, THE BILL IS ON CALL, SO
WE WILL REOPEN THE VOTE WHEN WE
HAVE ABSENT MEMBERS. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE NOW WILL GO
TO, SB ITEM 15 S, EXCUSE ME, AB
2387. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
YOU DIDN'T DO CALL YET, DID WE?
I'M SORRY. WE DIDN'T DO THAT ONE
YET. NO. OKAY WE DID THIS ONE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS, MOBILE HOME
PARKS PROVIDE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA, OFTEN AT MORE
AFFORDABLE PRICES THAN OTHER
OPTIONS. BECAUSE MANUFACTURED
HOMES ARE LESS EXPENSIVE AND
FASTER TO CONSTRUCT THAN
TRADITIONAL SITE BUILD HOUSES,
THEY CAN BE A KEY COMPONENT OF
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS.
HOWEVER IN SOME AREAS, LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESSES AND
EXCESSIVE FEES CHARGED FOR
ADDING LOTS IN EXISTING MOBILE
HOME PARKS CAN REACH THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER LOT
BEING ADDED, MAKING THE ADDITION
OF LOTS IN MOBILE HOME PARKS
COST PROHIBITIVE. AB 2387 ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING MOBILE
HOME PARKS TO APPLY TO LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO INCREASE
THEIR NUMBER OF LOTS BY UP TO
10, AND INCENTIVIZES INCREASES
IN MOBILE HOME SPACES BY
EXEMPTING ADDED SPACES FROM
ADDITIONAL BUSINESS TAXES AND
LOCAL FEES. SAFE GUARDS IN THE
BILL ENSURE THE ADDITIONAL
SPACES DO NOT SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPACT THE PROVISION OF UTILITY
SERVICES WITHIN THE PARK, AND
CLARIFY THAT ADDED UNITS WILL
NOT REMOVE UNITS FOR LOCAL RENT
CONTROL MEASURES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY IS JEFF
NEAL, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURED HOUSING
INSTITUTE. GREAT. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS JEFF NEAL, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURED
HOUSING INSTITUTE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF, BUT DO
WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR EXCELLENT ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE AT LEAST
HUNDREDS, IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
NEW HOUSING UNITS IN THE STATE.
MIGHT NOT SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS ON ITS OWN, BUT
IT IS PART OF AN ALL OF THE
ABOVE STRATEGY. THESE UNITS WILL
BE GENERALLY AFFORDABLE BY
NATURE AT ESSENTIALLY NO COST TO
THE STATE, NO TAX CREDITS, NO
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS. AND IT DOES
SO, AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID,
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS EXISTING
HOMEOWNERS AND THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE, PROTECTS SENSITIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL AREAS, AND HONORS
ALL OF THE STATE'S EXISTING RENT
CONTROL POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS. GRATEFUL TO THE
AUTHOR FOR, Ã THIS BILL, AND
ALSO GRATEFUL, MADAM CHAIR, FOR
YOUR EFFORTS IN THIS AREA IN THE
PAST AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. LET'S
SEE IF WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. CHRIS WIECKOWSKI WITH
UMMA, AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CONTRIBUTING TO
SOLVING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL, IN THE INTEREST OF TIME,
WE JUST THANK YOU AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU.
GREAT. OTHER WITNESSES. ARE YOU
IN SUPPORT? YEAH. HI. I'M LINDA
NYE ON BEHALF OF GSML. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. LET'S SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED. SO
SEEING NONE, GO AHEAD, SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE. YES. JUST BRIEFLY,
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD BILL. I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT AND
I'LL MOVE IT. OH. THANK YOU.
GREAT. WE HAVE A MOTION. GO
AHEAD. YOU CAN, CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT, SO
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL. MOTIONS DO
PASS. COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR SKINNER.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. OCHOA OCHOA.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. CORTEZ.
AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SATO
UMBERG. WAHAB. 6 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. THE BILLS ON CALL. BUT
YOU HAVE SIX VOTES. SO WHEN WE
GET FOLKS MISSING BACK, WE'LL
OPEN THE ROLL AGAIN. THANKS SO
YEAH, TWO TWO BILLS LEFT, TWO
AUTHORS. SO CONSENT CALENDAR OR
THE. YEAH WE COULD DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. LET'S, DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT?
ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO A ROLL CALL
ON CONSENT CALENDAR ON THE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
SKINNER. HI. SKINNER. AYE OKUBO.
DID SHE LEAVE? OKAY, OKAY.
BLAKE. SPEAR. SHAKESPEARE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. SATO YOUNGBERG.
WAHAB. IT'S 5 TO 0. ALL RIGHT,
SO WE'LL KEEP THAT, ON CALL, BUT
THAT CONSENT HAS 5 TO 0 NOW. AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA, WHICH IS ITEM 19 AB 2926.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS AB 2926 WOULD
HELP CALIFORNIA PROTECT OUR
LIMITED AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK
AND PREVENT LOW INCOME TENANTS
FROM BEING DISPLACED. THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IS A
GROWING ISSUE IN OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. STOCK IS DISAPPEARING
AT RATES FASTER THAN WE CAN
BUILD. IN A REPORT PUBLISHED BY
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP, CALIFORNIA HAS LOST
19,249 AFFORDABLE HOMES DUE TO
EXPIRED REGULATORY RESTRICTIONS
ON GOVERNMENT ASSISTED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AND OWNERS DECIDING
TO OPT OUT, SELL OR ALLOW THEIR
PROPERTIES TO BE CONVERTED TO
MARKET RATE, MARKET RATE HOUSING
. THE CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
NOTICE LAW REQUIRES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OWNERS WITH EXPIRING
RESTRICTIONS TO ALLOW BUYERS
INTERESTED IN PRESERVING THE
AFFORDABILITY. A YEAR'S NOTICE
TO MAKE A BONA FIDE PURCHASE
OFFER AND GIVE THEM THE RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL TO MATCH ANY OTHER
OFFERS. HOWEVER BECAUSE OWNERS
ARE NOT OBLIGATED TO SELL, THEY
CAN INSTEAD HOLD THE PROPERTY,
COMMIT TO NOT SELLING, AND
CONVERT IT TO MARKET RATE,
DISPLACING EXISTING LOW INCOME
TENANTS IN THE PROCESS. AB 2926
WILL HELP PRESERVE EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY REQUIRING
OWNERS TO RECEIVE A BONA FIDE
PURCHASE, OFFER TO EITHER ACCEPT
THE OFFER OR RE RESTRICT THE
DEVELOPMENT AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN ADDITION, THE BILL
ALSO MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE PRESERVATION NOTICE LAW TO
INCLUDE RECENTLY ENACTED
STREAMLINING LEGISLATION,
PREVENT TENANTS FROM BEING
DISPLACED OR PRICED OUT WITHOUT
NOTICE, AND PROVIDE NOTICE TO
TENANTS THAT WILL INFORM THEM OF
RENT INCREASES AND EXCEPTION OF
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS, AB 2926
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE ASSEMBLY HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF OUR ANNA LAWLER,
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, AND
ANDREW DAWSON, POLICY ADVOCACY
MANAGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. HELLO, I'M
ANDREW DAWSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
PRESERVATION LAW WAS ENACTED SO
THAT PROPERTIES THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE STAY AFFORDABLE,
WHICH IS CRUCIAL, AS YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE A MAJOR SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER, DUE TO ISSUES THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED, A FEW
PRESERVATION BUYERS USE THIS
PATHWAY. THIS BILL REQUIRES
SELLERS TO RECEIVE A BONA FIDE
OFFER TO EITHER ACCEPT THE OFFER
OR RESTRICT THE PROPERTY. IN
THIS WAY, THE SELLER GETS A
MARKET RATE PRICE FOR THE
PROPERTY AND THE PROPERTY STAYS
AFFORDABLE. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
PRODUCE MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES,
BUT IT'S ALSO VITAL TO ENSURE
THAT HOMES THAT HOMES THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE STAY AFFORDABLE. AB
2926 HELPS MAKE THAT HAPPEN. WE
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND WE REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. GOOD EVENING,
ANDY LAWLER HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, AS WELL
AS THE NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT TO OTHER CO-SPONSORS ON
THIS BILL, IN ADDITION TO
EVERYTHING THAT ANDREW SAID,
THIS BILL MAKES REALLY IMPORTANT
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS TO
VARIOUS NOTICE PROVISIONS UNDER
THE LAW THAT GO TO TENANTS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS THREE YEARS BEFORE
A PROPERTY IS SET TO EXPIRE, ITS
AFFORDABILITY IS SET TO EXPIRE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE CAN BE A
PLAN IN PLACE SO THAT TENANTS
KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING, AND
HOPEFULLY THERE CAN BE A PLAN IN
PLACE TO EITHER PRESERVE THE
AFFORDABILITY OR TRANSITION
THOSE TENANTS TO OTHER
AFFORDABLE UNITS. SO, IT'S A
REALLY EXCELLENT BILL, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ALL RIGHT, OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, YOU CAN DO YOUR ADD ONS
. GOOD EVENING. STEPHEN STENZLER
WITH BROWN SEEN ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
OKAY NHIÀU Dð WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION? WE DON'T HAVE
ANY REGISTERED. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WANTS TO OKAY,
LET ME TURN TO MY. I'LL MOVE THE
BILL. OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION.
ONE MOMENT.
CLARIFICATION. THANKS. ALL RIGHT
, SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR CONCERN, WE'LL ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY, GREAT, SO LET'S TAKE
A ROLL CALL ON THAT MOTION. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATOR SKINNER. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. OKOBOJI. OKAY.
BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR. AYE.
CABALLERO THIS IS CARLOS. OKAY.
IT'S, ITEM 19 AB 2926. CAN I CAN
I ADD AN. AYE, OF COURSE. YOU
MAY. AYE, A CHOBOQ. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO, CORTEZ.
GREAT. AGAIN, SENATOR. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SATO
UMBERG A UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. 9 TO 0. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL, WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
ON CALL BECAUSE MR. SATO WILL BE
COMING BACK. SO WE'LL KEEP IT ON
CALL. BUT YOU'RE LOOKING GOOD.
ALL RIGHT. WE, WE HAD ONE LAST
BILL TO HEAR. OH. HE'S HERE.
OKAY, GREAT. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR OUR LAST BILL, AND
THEN WE'LL OPEN THE ROLL ON
EVERYTHING, SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO YOU ARE HERE FOR ITEM 16,
WHICH IS AB 2460. WE WELCOME.
THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. AB 2460 IS A
CLEAN UP BILL TO MY AB 1458
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
THIS WILL ADD MINOR,
VERIFICATION LANGUAGE REQUESTS
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE
AND WE READ THAT GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO CLEAN UP THIS YEAR.
THIS WILL ALSO CLARIFY THAT
ASSOCIATION MEMBERSHIP MAY
RECONVENE AN ELECTION MEETING
USING THE REDUCED QUORUM. IT IS
NOT UP TO THE BOARD. THIS IS
CRITICAL AS I HAVE LEARNED THAT
SEVERAL HOA BOARDS HAVE REFUSED
TO RECOGNIZE A NEW LOW COMMON
THRESHOLD OF FEAR OF BEING
UNSEATED. WHEN THE VOTES ARE
TALLIED, WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE VOTING
PROCESS IS IN THE HANDS OF THE
ASSOCIATION MEMBERSHIP. TO
GUARANTEE THE CAST VOTES ARE
COUNTED. TODAY I HAVE LU█T BROWN
WITH THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
INSTITUTE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS BROWN,
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE,
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE. WE AGREED LAST YEAR
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
ADDRESS A CLARIFICATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE, WHICH
IS IN THIS BILL. WE'VE ALSO
CLEANED IT UP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE DEFINITION OF QUORUM AND
REDUCED QUORUM IS THE EXACT SAME
IN ALL FOUR DIFFERENT PLACES
THAT ARE IN THE BILL THAT WAS
NOT IN THE BILL LAST YEAR. IT IS
TECHNICAL CLEANUP. WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
HERE WHO WANTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO DO THE ADD ON. I DON'T
SEE ANY. SO PLEASE, OUR
OPPOSITION, YOU CAN COME TO THE
TABLE. YEAH. YOU'RE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO SIT RIGHT THERE. YOU
ARE. HELLO MARJORIE MURRAY,
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW. THIS IS THE
QUORUM ISSUE THAT WE WERE JUST
DISCUSSING. AND IT IS NOW LAW
THAT ASSOCIATION BOARDS ARE
PERMITTED TO RECONVENE A MEETING
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE IF, I MEAN
THAT THIS IS ALREADY LAW,
DETERMINE IF QUORUM HAS BEEN
MET. ALTHOUGH, AS I JUST SAID,
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THIS WORKS
WITH INTERNET VOTING, WHERE THE
PROXIES AND THE MEANS FOR
DETERMINING QUORUM ARE INVISIBLE
. BUT I'VE ALREADY MADE THAT
POINT, BUT WITH REGARD TO MR.
TO'S CURRENT BILL, THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS WHICH WE
RAISED LAST YEAR. AND THAT IS,
FIRST OF ALL, THE ISSUE OF
NOTICE. IF THE GOAL IS TO
ENCOURAGE VOTER PARTICIPATION,
WE URGE THIS YEAR, AS WE DID
LAST YEAR, THAT VOTERS BE GIVEN
AN INDIVIDUAL NOTICE, THAT THE
MEETING IS GOING TO BE EXTENDED
OR RECONVENED IN ORDER TO LOWER
THE QUORUM, THE BILL REQUIRES
ONLY GENERAL NOTICE AND THAT CAN
BE MET IN THE SPIRIT OF THE LAW.
SIMPLY BY POSTING A NOTICE IN
SOME REMOTE CORNER OF THE
ASSOCIATION. IF THE GOAL IS TO
INVITE AND ENCOURAGE VOTER
PARTICIPATION, WE URGE THAT THE
SUBSEQUENT NOTICES BE BY
INDIVIDUAL NOTICE, WHICH CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED BY EMAIL. THERE.
THERE'S ALSO LACK OF CLARITY
ABOUT HOW MANY TIMES THIS
MEETING CAN BE RECONVENED UNDER
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE. IT CAN BE
RECONVENED ENDLESSLY. WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN END POINT AND
THAT IF QUORUM IS NOT MET AFTER
A SUBSEQUENT RECONVENING, THEN
THERE ARE OTHER TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO THE ASSOCIATION TO REDUCE
QUORUM, WHICH IS REQUESTED OF
THE COURT OR REDO THE BYLAWS SO
THOSE ARE THE TWO ISSUES,
ACTUALLY THERE'S A THIRD, WHICH
IS THE PROTECTION OF THE SEALED
ENVELOPES CONTAINING THE BALLOTS
AND THAT THOSE BE PROTECTED AND
NOT OPENED WHILE THIS
RECONVENING PROCESS IS GOING ON.
SO OUR POSITION IS ACTUALLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. AND WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
WOULD HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE QUORUM ISSUE BECAUSE IT DOES
TOUCH ON THE ISSUE OF VOTER
PARTICIPATION. Þ THANK, THANK
YOU. LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO ADD ON
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY. SEEING NONE
MEMBERS, GO AHEAD, SENATOR WAHAB
AND THEN SENATOR CABALLERO, I'LL
ACTUALLY MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. OKAY.
SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD IS
THE IS THIS THE FIRST TIME
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION, I THINK THAT THIS IS
A ACTUALLY, THIS IS THIS IS A
TECHNICAL CLEANUP BILL THAT
REQUIRES BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. AND I THINK THAT I
ADDRESS ALL THE CONCERNS BASED
ON, BASED ON THE BILL OF ESTÁ
THAT I INTRODUCED LAST YEAR. SO
BASICALLY THAT I TRY TO I, I TRY
TO COMPROMISE ON THE CONCERNS
OF, FROM THE OPPOSITION. SO I'M,
I'M REALLY SURPRISED WHY THERE
IS STILL MORE CONCERNS. YES. SO
IS THIS THE FIRST TIME YOU'VE
HEARD THEM OR WERE THEY RAISED
IN THE ASSEMBLY? I THINK, LAST
YEAR WE HAD SOME CONCERNS, BUT I
BELIEVE THAT OUR ACTORS, WE HAD
A MEETING WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND WE ADDRESSED ALL THE
CONCERNS AND MÀ. THIS BILL IS
TECHNICAL CLEANUP FROM LAST YEAR
. YES, I APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU CLEANING UP. YES.
SOMETHING FROM LAST YEAR, IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THERE ARE
STILL TECHNICAL CLEANUP AND THE
WHOLE AREA OF VOTING AND LACK OF
QUORUM ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE, YOU WANT THERE TO BE,
YOU WANT IT TO BE FAIR, AND YOU
WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE NOTICE,
RIGHT? AND, AND I AGREE THAT
POSTING A NOTICE WHERE THE
MAILBOXES MAY BE OR SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW, WHERE THE POOL IS
OR WHEREVER, IS NOT SUFFICIENT,
NOTICE, AND MY EXPERIENCE WITH
EITHER AND USUALLY THE HOA'S ARE
MOBILE HOMES OR THEY'RE,
CONDOMINIUMS AND IN BOTH OF
THOSE INSTANCES, IT'S THE LAST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE. AND SO A LOT OF
SENIORS LIVE THERE. AND, AND
PEOPLE, WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY
THEIR OWN HOME, THEY MAY BUY A
CONDO OR LIVE IN A CONDO. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE, THE RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE
AND MANY DON'T. I GET IT. AND
THAT'S WHY THE QUORUM ISSUE IS A
PROBLEM. WE HAVE QUORUM ISSUES
HERE AT TIMES AS WELL. BUT, BUT
I JUST WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO AT
LEAST CONSIDER, SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. I
THINK THEY'RE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THEY'RE VERY SIMPLE TO FIX IN
THE BILL, IF YOU'RE SO INCLINED
TO, TO DO THAT, BECAUSE I THINK,
I THINK THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED WERE, WERE REALLY VALID.
VALID, VALID. AND IT'S REALLY
EASY TO FIX. IT'S PERSONAL.
PERSONAL. PERSONAL, NOTICE.
RIGHT. AS OPPOSED TO THE PUBLIC.
MORE PUBLIC NOTICE. YEAH. SO
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. OKAY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU MAY HAVE
ALREADY RESPONDED. I DIDN'T KNOW
IF YOU WANTED TO MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE YES. OKAY.
THE BILL DOES GO TO JUDICIAL
NEXT, BUT GO AHEAD, SENATOR. YES
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I JUST
WANTED TO ECHO THE SAME,
SENTIMENT AS SENATOR CABALLERO.
I THINK THESE WOULD BE AN EASY,
IN MY OPINION, VERY EASY TO
ACCOMMODATE WITHIN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY, BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
ACCOMMODATION MOVING FORWARD, IF
YOU ARE SO WILLING TO ENSURE
THAT WE DO ACCOMMODATE THE
CONCERNS ADDRESSED TODAY. I'M.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I'M, YOU'VE
WE'VE HAVE A CLOSE WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WAHAB, AND
THE BILL DOES GO TO JUDICI NEXT,
WITH THAT, WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. OTRO BOGUE. AYE.
OKOBOJI I BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE
SPEAR, I CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA
PADILLA. AYE. CIERTO. HAMBURG.
HAMBURG AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE.
9 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL HAS
ADEQUATE VOTES, BUT WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THE ROLL OPEN BECAUSE WE
HAVE A COUPLE MISSING MEMBERS.
AND, WE ARE NOW, SO WE'LL WE'LL
CLOSE IT OUT ONCE WE HAVE THAT
ADDITIONAL MEMBER. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GREAT.
WHAT? WE'RE GOING TO DO NOW IS
OPEN THE ROLL. STARTING WITH US.
WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR SENATOR
SEYARTO. TO LET US OPEN THE ROLL
ON THOSE BILLS THAT SENATOR
SOURTOE HAS ALREADY VOTED ON.
NONE I THOUGHT HE HAS. HE'S
VOTED ON TWO. BECAUSE I HAVE TO
REOPEN IT. AS SOON AS HE COMES
BACK, HE'S ON HIS WAY. YEAH,
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE TWO
BILLS TO OPEN THE ROLL ON. OKAY
GO AHEAD. THIS IS AB 2093 BY
SOME MEMBER WARD. MOTION IS TO
PASS. HOLD ON. YOU. YES. YEAH.
OH, YES. AND SPEAK SLOWLY SO
THEY CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM 12. THE NUMBER AGAIN.
AND THE AUTHOR AB 2893 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD MOTION IS
Dð PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 5 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATOR CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE
MEMBER UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. 7 TO 2. 8 TO 2. 8 TO 2.
YEAH. SO, CHAIR, MAY I ASK THAT
WE DO A FIRST VOTE ON EVERYTHING
BEFORE WE KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THAT. WE'RE GOING TO DO
THE TWO BILLS WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR SENATOR SATO. AND
WHEN SENATOR SATO GETS HERE, WE
WILL GO THROUGH THE REMAINING.
OKAY. YEAH. I MEAN, AS SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN HERE THE WHOLE TIME,
I WAS HOPING WE WOULD THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT IT'S. YEAH
OKAY. JUST THAT WE HAVE TO GO
REOPEN EVERYTHING AGAIN ONCE HE
ARRIVES. HE'S ON HIS WAY. WE'VE
BEEN TOLD. ALL RIGHT, SO LET US
DO THAT. SECOND, BILL THAT
SENATOR SATO HAD VOTED ON A NOT
VOTING IS A VOTE. SO GO AHEAD,
READ THE FILE NUMBER AND GO
AHEAD. THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1893 BY SOME
MEMBER WICKS. THE MOTION IS Dð.
PASS AS AMENDED, AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 1, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
. SENATOR CORTEZ ORTEZ AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR AYE. SATO
UMBERG UMBERG AYE. WAHAB SEVEN.
THAT'S 7 TO 1. OKAY. AND THAT
BILL HAS EVERYBODY WHO IS ON THE
COMMITTEE AS REGISTERED. OKAY
ALL RIGHT. SO THAT'S DONE. OKAY.
NOW. WE'LL START, BUT HE IS
INDICATED HE'S ON HIS WAY. YES.
LET'S HOPE HE'S RUNNING. WELL,
HE'LL BE OUT OF BREATH THEN.
WELL, HIS NAME IS AT THE END, SO
LET'S, LET'S DO ROLL CALL ON
FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR, RIGHT?
YES, YES. OKAY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, THE CURRENT VOTE IS 5
TO 0. SENATOR BORG A OKOBOJI I.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I CIERTO
UMBERG I UMBERG I WAHAB WAHAB I
9 TO 0. OKAY. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS STILL GOING TO.
WE'RE STILL GOING TO HOLD IT
OPEN. BUT IT'S 9 TO 0 NOW. WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM TWO AB 1789. WE
HAVEN'T DONE THAT YET. OH SORRY.
HI. YAY. OKAY. WE DIDN'T I WILL
REOPEN THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
JUST ALLOW, SENATOR SAWYER.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SAWYER, TO
ADD ON, THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATOR CIERTO. CIERTO
I TEND TO ZERO. OKAY GREAT
CONSENT CALENDARS. NOW OUT. THE
VOTE IS 10 TO 0. WE WILL GO TO
THE FIRST ITEM AB 2338. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAN SAWYER. THAT WAS A
VOTE ONLY. LET'S DO THE ROLL
CALL. OH, SORRY. WE NEED A
MOTION. OKAY. AS, SENATOR WAHAB
HAS MOVED IT, AND THAT IS, THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
OKAY, GREAT. SENATOR SKINNER, I
SKINNER, I OKOBOJI, I. I BLAKE
SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR, I CABALLERO.
NØ. CABALLERO. NØ. CORTEZ CORTEZ
I MENGIBAR PADILLA. PADILLA I
SATO. AMBER UMBERG I WAHAB.
WAHAB I. 7 TO 1. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL AB 233 IS OUT. 7 TO 1.
LET'S GO TO ITEM THREE AB 1840.
OH I'M SORRY WE DID TWO. I
JUMPED TO A MOTION. ITEM TWO AB
1789 QUIRK-SILVA. WE NEED A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR SORRY, YOU'RE A
SENATOR. SENATOR WAHAB IS MOVED.
LET'S DO THE ROLL CALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. OKOBO. I OKOBOJI I BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. I CABALLERO
. CABALLERO I CORTEZ. CORTEZ. I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I PADILLA.
PADILLA I SATO. SERRATO I UMBERG
. UMBERG I WAHAB I WAHAB I 10 TO
0. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL 1840 IS
OUT 10 TO 0. LET'S GO TO ITEM.
I'M SORRY. THAT WAS 1789. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO AB 1840, WHICH IS
ITEM THREE. ARAMBULA WE NEED A
MOTION. SENATOR HOBBS MOVED.
ROLL CALL. MOTION IS TO PASS.
SUMMARY FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATOR SKINNER. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. OCHOA. BOGH.
OKOBOJI. NO. BLAKE. SPEER BLAKE.
SPEER. NO. CABALLERO CABRERO I.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I. PADILLA. PADILLA. I
SERRATO. SERRATO. NO. UMBERG.
UMBERG I WAHAB. WAHAB I 7 TO 3.
ALL RIGHT. AB 1840 IS OUT. 7 TO
3. LET'S GO TO ITEM FOUR AB 1886
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ'S BILL.
DO WE DO WE ALREADY VOTE ON IT.
SO OKAY, SO NOW I DON'T NEED ANY
MORE MOTIONS. WE'RE JUST GOING
TO OPEN THE ROLL FOR ADD ONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 1, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE SATO.
NO. SATO. NO. UMBERG WAHAB. THIS
FILE. ITEM FOUR 1886. WAHAB. AYE
70. I'M SORRY. 1886 UMBERGAON.
UMBERG. AYE 8 TO 2. OKAY. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO ITEM SIX AB 2560.
ALVAREZ OPEN THE ROLL. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING.
AYE. CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
PADILLA CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE.
UMBERG WAHAB. WAHAB. NØ. UMMER.
YEAH. GO SLOWER, HE ANSWERED.
YOU SO SAY UMBERG AGAIN. UMBERG
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. ITEM SIX. ITEM
SIX. OH, WAIT. WHAT'S THE.
WHAT'S THE VOTE ON IT? 8 TO 1.
ALL RIGHT, AB 2560. VOTE IS 8 TO
1 AND WILL CLOSE THE RULE. IS
THE ONLY NOTE. THE ONLY NOTE I
WILL HAVE VOTING NO. WERE YOU
GOING TO HIRE US ON AB 2560?
ALVAREZ OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. OKAY WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
SEVEN AB 1893, WHICH WHEN WE
CLOSED, WE CLOSED IT. YES. OH
LOVELY. OKAY WE'LL GO TO, AB
2243. WE DIDN'T CLOSE THAT ONE
YET, DID WE. ALL RIGHT. YES.
WHEN YOU FIRST GOT HERE. YES ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB 2243 WHICH WILL OPEN
THE RULE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 5
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING. AYE.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
SATO SATO. NOT VOTING. UMBERG.
NOT VOTING. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 8
TO 0. ALL RIGHT. AB 2243 IS OUT.
EXCUSE ME. 8 TO 0. WE WILL NOW
GO TO FILE ITEM NINE AB 2580.
LET'S REOPEN THE RULE. A MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR. CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. SATO SATO I UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG I WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
10 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL AB
2580 IS OUT 10 TO 0. GO TO ITEM
TEN AB 2005. LET'S REOPEN. LET'S
OPEN THE ROLL MOTIONS DO PASS
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE.
CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO. UMBERG
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE
THAT'S 9 TO 1. ALL RIGHT. AB
2005 IS OUT. 9 TO 1. WE'LL GO TO
ITEM 11 AB 2597. LET'S DO THE
ROLL CALL. MOTION IS DUE PASS.
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 1 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATOR CABALLERO. CABALLERO
AYE. CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO.
UMBERG UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 8 TO 2. OKAY. AB 2597
IS OUT. 8 TO 2. LET'S GO TO A
ITEM 12 AB 2893 ALSO WARD REOPEN
THE ROLL. CALL OH 12 IS OUT.
OKAY APOLOGIES. WE ALREADY
CLOSED THAT RULE, WE WILL GO TO
ITEM 14 AB 2159. I DON'T THINK
WE CLOSED THAT. NO WE DID NOT.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. LET'S REOPEN THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS.
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 5
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
SENATOR CHO. BOB CABALLERO.
CIERTO CIERTO I UMBERG UMBERG I
WAHAB. 14 NO, NO NO NO. WAHAB.
NO. 7 TO 1 OKAY AB 2159 IS OUT.
7 TO 1. YOU STILL HAVE TO REOPEN
ON 15. YES WE OPEN OKAY. THE
REST OF THEM. SO WE'RE AT ITEM
15 AB 2387. GO AHEAD. WE'LL OPEN
THE ROLL MOTIONS DO PASS. AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
SIERRA TO SIERRA. KHÎI. UMBERG.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE.
10 TO 0. ALL RIGHT, AB 23870 10
TO 0. YOU DIDN'T CLOSE TO YET.
OKAY AB 2460. WE JUST NEED ONE
MORE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL
REOPEN THAT RULE. I THINK WE
ONLY HAVE ONE MEMBER MISSING. GO
AHEAD. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 9
TO 0. THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR SATO SARATO
AYE. 10 TO 0. OKAY. AND THEN OUR
LAST ITEM IS TO DO THE GABRIEL
BILL. WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
MOTION ON IT. OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT WE ALREADY CLOSED
CALL OR NO NOT YET. ALL RIGHT.
SO WE WILL GO TO ITEM 19 AB
2926. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA,
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL MOTIONS. DO
PASS AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 9 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SEN.
SATO. SATO AYE. 10 TO 0. OKAY.
WE HAVE ONE LAST ITEM. IT
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE A MOTION YET.
WE NEED TO GET A MOTION THAT'S
ON ITEM 21 AB 3160. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL MOVED BY SENATOR
WAHAB, LET'S TAKE OUR ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS. AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION. SENATOR
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE
OKOBOJI. CAN YOU. OKAY. BLAKE.
SPEAR IS CABALLERO. CABRERO.
CORTEZ MENGIBAR. PADILLA.
PADILLA AYE. CIERTO. UMBERG. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
THAT OPEN. TWO MEMBERS LEFT NOT
REALIZING THAT THAT BILL HADN'T
EVEN HAD A VOTE, BECAUSE WE
HADN'T HAD A MOTION ON IT YET.
SO ITEM NUMBER TWO WOULD BE
LET'S HAVE HER PULL IT UP AND
MAKE SURE YOU'RE RECORDED THERE.
OKAY YES, WE DID 10 TO 0. OKAY
OKAY. EVERYONE ELSE IS GOOD.
YEAH. OKAY. OH, WE HAVE TWO
MEMBERS THAT WANT TO. THEY
DIDN'T REALIZE YOU'RE GOOD.
YOU'RE GOOD. THEY DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT WE HADN'T EVEN HAD A MOTION
ON THAT ONE YET. THANK YOU.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE QUORUM.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE LIKE THREE
TIMES. YEAH. SO SO MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT WE SHOULD ALWAYS DO. FIRST
IS THE ONES THAT HAVEN'T HAD
MOTIONS. YEAH. I'M GOING TO BE
UP. OH NO. SORRY BLAKE SPEAR I
SAID YEAH I FORGOT WE HAD. OH
OKAY. YEAH. SO SHE THOUGHT YEAH.
AND HER STAFF IS SENDING HER
BACK I JUST WELL THEY DON'T HAVE
TO COME BACK. I JUST TRYING TO
GIVE THEM A COURTESY. YEAH. IF
THEY WANT TO VOTE, THEY SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT. WELL
WE GOT DONE QUICKER THAN I
THOUGHT WE COULD. NÓ. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GREAT JOB. THANK YOU.
HONOR MARATHON. MISS. MISS WICKS
PROBABLY THE HER BILLS WERE THE
ONES THAT SURE. THE, SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL BE ON
RECESS UNTIL WE SEE IF THE TWO
MEMBERS WHO WEREN'T ABLE YET TO
VOTE ON, ONE BILL THAT IS OPEN,
WE'LL SEE IF THEY ARE WILLING
AND WANT TO COME BACK. YES.
SENATOR. IT WAS THAT GABRIEL
BILL THAT WE HEARD.
A LOT OF RECESS. WE ARE OPENING
THE ROLL ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL'S BILL, WHICH IS ITEM
21, AB 3160. CURRENT VOTE IS 5
TO 0. OKOBOJI, BLAKE. SPEAR.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GREATLY
APPRECIATE.
THIS. GREAT, GREAT. WE DIDN'T
ACT. WE DIDN'T.
THAT WE HEARD. WE HEARD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL'S BILL VERY
EARLY, BUT IT WAS BEFORE WE HAD
A QUORUM. SO THERE HAD BEEN NO
MOTION ON IT YET. SO WE HAD
NEVER VOTED ON IT. SO THAT'S. SO
THAT'S IT? THAT'S IT. SO WE WILL
REOPEN THE ROLL TO, EXCUSE ME ON
ITEM 21, AB 3160, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL'S GO AHEAD READ
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0. TROY
BLAKE SPEAR BLAKE SPEAR I ALL
RIGHT, WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN.
WE HAVE ONE OTHER MEMBER WHO MAY
WANT TO ADD ON, BUT APPRECIATE
YOUR RETURNING AND SORRY. YES,
WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE CONFUSION.
OKAY THANK YOU. HAVE A GOOD
NIGHT. GREAT.
ARE YOU DONE FOR THE DAY AFTER
THIS, I THINK SO. OKAY, GOOD. OH
MY GOSH. CAROLINE, SENATOR
MENGIBAR, WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
YOUR RETURN. WE'RE SORRY FOR THE
CONFUSION. WE HAD HEARD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL'S BILL EARLY IN
THE COMMITTEE, BUT IT WAS PRIOR
TO OUR HAVING QUORUM, SO WE DID
NOT HAVE A MOTION ON IT. SO WE
GOT TO IT AND WE TOOK A MOTION.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, SOME PEOPLE
THOUGHT WE HAD ALREADY DONE SO
WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN THAT ROLL,
WHICH IS ITEM 21 AB3160.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, PLEASE,
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
JOE BOGUE, MENGIBAR MENGIBAR
ACIERTO 8 TO 0. GREAT SO HAVING
NOW COMPLETED THAT ROLE AND THAT
BILL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AB
3160 IS OUT. WE'VE COMPLETED ALL
OUR BUSINESS. SO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING WILL NOW BE
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.